[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the Premiere Online speed Jazz
tournament a knockout filled with
tension drama quick tactics and shocking
moments
oh my gosh for the last seven years and
counting the best Blitz and bullet
players in the world have flocked to
chess.com to prove their worth at this
format
excitement rains every year with major
upsets and intense battles
year 12 invitees and four qualifiers
face off for the title dozens have tried
but only two have ever worn this Crown
Magnus makes it look easy he wins the
speed test Championship spits in a row
who will be this year's Blitz King it's
time to find out
[Music]
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase we
are excited to welcome coinbase as a
presenting partner of the speech s
Championship I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me is my good friend my
co-commentator Grandmaster Daniel
nardiski Donya we had an exciting
doubleheader yesterday how you feeling
today
I'm feeling great Robert got my sleep
after the long day yesterday only a
single match today but what an
incredible match it's going to be
oh these two are gonna throw their
punches at one another we had Maxine
Buster lagrav and Magnus Carlson went a
day ago but today it's all about all
they raise the Fusia and Wesley so Daya
how exciting is this matchup not
exciting at all Robert uh two amateur
players with very little experience this
doesn't promise to be a close match at
all man I'm really I don't envy the
commentators who have to commentate this
starting at eight minutes just kidding
of course it's Reza it's Wesley it's yet
another battle between two different
Generations two different approaches to
the game but both of these players so
experienced so consistent and so precise
uh they are phenomenal players and they
will not be looking past each other but
we have to look at the bracket let's
start at the top where Hikaru Nakamura
entered as the number one overall seed
he is the five-time ringing speed chess
champion he took care of business
against you Yang ying karwana and
abusotara they had a very close match
for Fabi he was able to get through to
the next round nihal and vas chair
legrall they won their opening matchup
so chalk talked in the upper half of the
bracket done here but down in the lower
half we haven't seen one of the round of
16 matches that's nepo against Arjun but
today our attention will be focused on
the quarterfinal matchup between
ferrugia and Wesley so it will indeed
definitely fewer blowouts in uh the
second half of the bracket than in the
top yesterday Magnus Carlson also took
care of business with a nine point
victory over pitted but that was a
closer match uh than one would think
looking at it on paper this match I
think promises to be a close match on
paper as well I just don't see uh the
difference in strength that would allow
either of these players to score the
kind of blowout victory that we've seen
throughout the round of 16.
and somebody who probably would like a
blowout who wasn't so comfortable in his
opening round match was alireza farouza
because against the former candidate
Dimitri on draken a star in his own
right this was a close call it was 13.5
12 and up at the final mark But Done Yet
eight blunders by farugia we know he
cannot afford that against Wesley
uncharacteristically sloppy play against
son Drake and he was down in that match
uh for the first half or so and it
really came down to the wire on draken
almost mounted a last-second comeback
with a crazy final game that I had the
pleasure of commentating there is no
question that Borussia has to step up
his game uh if he plays the same way
heated against him Drake and Wesley so
is not going to relinquish a lead if
alireza starts the match by committing a
lot of blunders
and in his opening round matchup Wesley
did not relinquish that lead it was
quite a heavy lead in his favor against
Le bonaroni and the final score looks
closer because in the bullet Levon took
some games but as you see here eight
brilliances by Wesley so final score 15
now 12 and a half the accuracy was there
no surprise right
no surprise I honestly think that both
Wesley and alirez are going to step up
their game today Wesley jumped out to
the early lead this was a bit of a wild
match with some crazy topsy-turvy games
then the boss levoss Levon lost and I
have a new Port menteau lavast lost a
series of games uh after those initial
series of draws and Wesley never really
looked back there were some scary
moments but as you said it was largely a
wire to wire Victory by Wesley so not so
by alireza farusha who had to make a
comeback against that draken we'll see
what kind of characteristic the match
will take on today
and in some ways those first round
matchups where andrekin left ahead of
alarisa Wesley did that to live on but
didn't look back and so I think you're
right that alireza cannot afford to see
Wesley get out to an early lead and
let's dive right into the numbers
because we're thrilled to have Deloitte
a leader in their field as an official
partner for the sphs championship their
dedication to Excellence aligns
perfectly with the ethos of Chess and
with the chess.com mission to grow the
game in sport of Chess delort is the
official Data Insights partner of the
SEC let's dive into the joy game
analytics and here we have them Dania
you said different Generations the age
29 for Wesley 20 for alireza still so
young but no longer a teenager are you
shocked at all by their head to head
well I'm a little bit surprised at the
bullet but it's really important that
their last meeting was far back in 2020
they they haven't played much in recent
years they haven't played all that much
overall I'm not shocked by their Blitz
Head to Head you know that they're very
very close in strength I think alireza
might be a little bit better in the
non-increment format but with a one
second increment they should be very
very close in strength Robert
and that's an important characteristic
here because in the bullet Chess
Championship all there is a did beat
Magnus head to head but that was one
minute with no increment whatsoever but
let's dive into the second page of our
analytics because I think there are some
huge numbers that tell an important
story we talked about the BCC look at
Ali raises Peak bullet rating three five
two one no that wasn't mistyped Dania
that is a really large number it really
is I mean if you got that number without
context you might think that's total
number of games played or I don't know
total cups of coffee consumed in my life
you wouldn't think that it's that it
refers to a chess rating and yet it does
alireza one of the best bullet players
on the site one of the fastest players
on the site and I think speed is going
to be a major deciding factor in today's
match we're gonna get a lot of time
scrambles you just know it because both
of these players are pretty big fans of
making a lot of moves on their last
couple seconds
and it is the first speeches
Championship that Ali Riza plays not as
a teenager he is grown older as we all
do but alireza has not wanted SEC match
his current run is his best Wesley has
been in the finals three different times
so down in that youth versus experience
type of narrative what do you make of
that from Wesley's perspective yeah I
mean from Wesley's perspective uh he's
more experienced than people realize
with online chess he plays most of the
title Tuesdays he's played a good amount
of Blitz and bullets so he's only 29 I
think chess fans and chess commentators
sometimes have a tendency to overstate
the case it's basically a dinosaur who
was around you know when the T-Rexes
were stomping the Earth no Wesley is
still a very young guy he's still very
very fast and as you like to point out
Robert he's one of the most precise
players on the planet statistically
speaking he makes very very few
inaccuracies and mistakes even in the
Blitz and bullet time controls
well someone else who has been very
precise thus far has been smarter chess
let's dive into the smart adjust
predictions to see how this match shapes
up and wow Wesley the favorite in five
plus one by a point and even matched in
the three plus one predicted but in that
bullet time Patrol I'll raise it a
two-point margin according to smarter
chess 14 half 13 half 55 to 45 win
probability Diana did these numbers ring
true to you yeah despite the fact that
Wesley holds that 6-1 lead in their
current Bullet Head to Head I have to
agree that farugia is the favorite in
light of his recent bullet performances
uh in the one plus one segment which
means that Wesley has to get off to that
good start in five plus one a one point
lead would be good a two or three point
cushion I think would be even better for
Wesley heading into the three-minute
portion
I'm with us he wants to feel that
comfort zone like you did against Levon
aronian and the fans well they don't
think they want to see Wesley win the
match of course many fans in Wesley's
corner but if you look at the
predictions as people filled out their
brackets many more chose alireza farouza
to move on and that these are the
community predictions here 73 of you
want Ali Raisa perus to win your
brackets will have him circled moving
into the semifinals but Done Yet 73 27
I'm not surprised by that because
usually the seeds do the talking
but I think perhaps it will be a closer
match than the community predicts I
agree man the community really giving
that photo confidence to Ali Reza
ferrugia
but it's incredibly evenly matched it's
this match is so unpredictable hopefully
all the residents fall asleep during the
start of that match as we take a look at
alireza and that nice little snake plant
behind him
yeah he has a nice plant there the The
Vibes are in his corner he is set he
looked at the window during his last
smash to regain his composure and
someone who's always composed is Wesley
so the Grand Master who plays for the
United States he's won the U.S
championship before he's won pretty much
every uh important event that he's
played in and so for Wesley he is
somebody who still strives for the
ultimate title in chess and he's been a
Fisher random world champion so he has
achieved so much in his still young
career as you put it yeah he's really
the Jack of all trades Wesley is a
completely Universal player on the board
he's also a universal player when it
comes to different variants and formats
and time controls he's just incredibly
good he's got such a solid foundation
and he's been around forever looks like
he uh might be in a hotel room so I'd be
curious to know uh what he's doing there
is he on a personal trip probably he is
on a chess trip that's a pretty safe bet
when it comes to any anybody over 2 700.
a little smile there from Wesley
yes Wesley's smiling for now but will he
remain so happy when he plays against
alvareza something that is talked about
a lot and I think that it should be
discussed is that Wesley so is so
difficult to tilt he's somebody that he
just plays every single game that feels
like he's fresh all the Rays on the
other hand I feel like he is the more
tiltable of the two and done it we
talked about Magnus with respect to Jan
and Arjun would you say that's the case
that if Wesley gets out to an early lead
that could tilt alireza a hundred
percent there's no question that alireza
is the more tiltable player Wesley a
little bit more level-headed as they
kick off their first game and that makes
it even more important I think for
alireza to set a good tone start off
better than you did against undraken and
avoid the early blunders in the first
couple of games because that can really
put a damper uh on your kind of feelings
toward the match as we have let's see a
night or most probably in the first game
are you a bit surprised to see that from
Wesley who typically plays very solid
repertoires he grew up playing the
French defense he likes to play E4 E5
from the black side but he's going for
the night off
I am surprised I was expecting e45 a
more solid beginning but Wesley uh
trying to deliver the opening Salvo and
uh that's really admirable we got an
early night orph in the night in the
Magnus visit match as well uh and then
never had another night or if the whole
rest of the match so it's always hard to
predict you know what the players are
planning in terms of the opening some
players they repeat the same openings
throughout the match others uh they keep
varying based on uh how the opening
lands based on the opponent as we see a
poisoned Pawn variation but that pawn
cannot be captured because of Knight to
A4 A3 is one of the most reputable
Sidelines to the main Queen D2
isn't it funny that the poison Pawn
variation is one where you can capture
it like normally if something's poisoned
you shouldn't be doing that but in the
poison Pawn you get away with it but why
isn't this called a poison Pawn as we
just want to show very quickly that
Queen takes B2 and this is the whole
point of putting the pawn on A3 is it
takes away both the A3 and B4 Square so
the White Knight goes out to A4 and
traps the queen in its place indeed
can't capture the Knight because that's
defended the Rooks defended and all of
the squares are defended that's a great
point I think the person who named the
poison Pawn must have been biased
against the night or if he he already
evaluated the line before he even knew
what was going on so Knight C6 and the
Knight now drops back to B3 white not
engaging in the center and Wesley
continues with his development I mean as
far as Knight arth positions come this
is relatively on the more positional
side but of course it could get tactical
any second uh if the sides Castle in
opposite directions
and then Knight on B3 helps Shield the
white king once it goes to the queen
side but it doesn't help strike in the
center E4 to E5 would be a great idea
for white but black has two pieces
covering it and when that Queen
eventually slides back to C7 make that
three pieces covering the E5 Square it's
very difficult to see that happen and
black will slide that Queen back maybe
play B5 in the future so Dania opposite
side castling is always fun for us as
commentators but for the players it
means there's a lot to work through
there most definitely is and the first
step for black is to figure out whether
he's Castle in kingside or keeping his
King in the center for white uh who's
got a bigger chunk of the center and
more weaknesses in the center I think
it's less feasible to keep the king
there uh for an extended period of time
but for black he's got this Pawn cocoon
the shivanagan structure with the pawns
on D6 and E6 that are very very hard to
break down and that is why you often see
black keeping the king in the center
either for uh a long bit of the middle
game or sometimes even for the entire
game
right because the king isn't actually
unsafe in the center if white can't get
to it but this group of H6 suddenly
allureza has paused Bishop H4 my
question is will black strike with G5
that is a thematic decision but it's one
that really creates a mess of things as
black gives up a pawn some of these
lines but white loses control of key
Central squares great eye by you and
that is one of those ideas that any
self-respecting night or learner uh
night or player has to learn I actually
think it's the reason why alireza ended
up taking on F6 so that ship has sailed
we saw a similar position in that
carlson-vid game uh I think the second
game of their match optically it looks
like black is better he's got the bishop
pair he's got a beautiful Bishop sitting
on F6 and aiming at the night on C3 but
when you run these types of positions
through the engine you sometimes see
that white has this idea of running his
kingside pawns up G4 H4 and G5 and that
can be a very powerful Pawn storm that
can be hard to deal with
and the Queen on F3 is so important
because it defends that Rook on H1 if
that Queen were on D2 and the Knight on
C3 as you're pointing out then this is a
slower path for white you wouldn't be
able to play H4 and G5 so quickly
because that Rook would be loose back in
the corner so that Queen is doing it all
and that Rook on D1 is keeping the queen
on C7 honest there are no Knight A5 type
of ideas for black to try to trade off
some pieces because D6 will be loose
great insights black can also try to
meet fire with fire here with uh the
aforementioned G5 but G5 oftentimes run
into runs into this classic idea white
plays E5 D takes E5 and then sticks a
knight on the Square that was vacated by
the pawn and with the bishop on F6
having lost the support of the Jeep on
white develops a major initiative so I
think black is no choice but to ignore
the possibility of G5 and maybe even
Castle Queen side that seems to be what
alireza uh what Wesley is indicating
with his last move I actually think he's
a lot likelier to go Queen side than
King side at this point but instead we
see him play the prophylax G6 trying to
keep the bishop on the long diagonal
and his Bishop stays in touch with the
rook in the corner and that square is
even more important than the piece
because if White had played G5 uh black
would have been able to take on G5 and
take on C3 shattering white sponsors
that's actually a pretty important line
Daniel the fact that the Rook on h8
would be defended by the bishop on C3
that's a great great line there and that
is the reason why uh alireza resisted
the Temptation keeping his Pawn on G4
for now instead beautiful maneuvering
chest I love what he's doing with Rook
H3 connecting The Rook to the Knight
dropping the queen back but the second
idea I think is to double the Rooks on
the D file and we continue seeing a lot
of parallels between the Carlson Vivid
game uh where vidit also went after a
direct attack on the D6 Pawn I think we
will see Rook H to D3 and of course now
G5 is once again uh a very likely
possibility
and we briefly saw a question mark on
Rook to Da which probably means that
Castle's Queen side was the engine's
first choice but from a human
perspective that is so risky especially
with the queen on F2 and Knight coming
to A4 if that King had actually been on
C8 we could have seen some of the dark
Square control from white but as it
stands that King is perfectly happy in
the center it can Castle kingside Now
The Rook left H3 and went towards the
center Castle in kingside is much more
likely
it's much more likely and it's harder
for a white to shatter Black's King side
because of the placement of these pawns
G5 can always be met with H5 and black
can kind of maintain uh that pawnshell
on the king side instead we see alireza
playing on the other side of the board
Knight to A4 and is he going to sink his
teeth into the B6 Square yes but with
the queen trying to get the Queens off
the board and soften Black's control
over the D6 Pawn obviously Robert this
could backfire because the Knight on B6
is going to be temporarily stranded but
it's going to be very hard for black to
actually attack that Knight
love the move Queen B6 though I was
thinking Knight B6 and wondering if that
Knight did in fact get stranded but this
loosens up the D6 Pawn as you mentioned
uh Wesley he's thinking here he's not
automatically going to trade Queens but
his Queen is under direct threat so what
how do you defend if you don't take on
B6 you play Rook D7 but that loses touch
with the D6 Pawn as well these
dispositions they can fall apart in a
hurry absolutely I mean queen B6 Knight
B6 there is no good way to defend the D6
Pawn of course you could drop your
Bishop back to f8 but how ugly is that
you're also allowing moves like Rook C3
there but I was gonna say the only
accurate move in this position he's
played it and it's Queen to B7 and now
that reinforces the attack on the Knight
because the queen is now protected and
if alireza trades on B7 which he
basically has to Black Cat's a much
better version of that end game with the
bishop already deployed on a good Square
I love moves like that right the queen
trade was offered and if this were over
the board someone pick up the queen and
move it slightly and instead of going to
capture the queen just in front of it
and now White's hand is four so he's
thinking is alireza is there a move
besides Queen takes B7 his Knight on A4
is under attack there's the crazy Knight
beat it to C5 when the Knight is clearly
Untouchable because of Checkmate on d8
but after Knight bc5 black trades Queens
on B6 first and because the Knight makes
contact with the bishop I don't think
that white loses material directly I
think this is precisely what alireza is
trying to puzzle out it doesn't seem to
work according to the computer it took
him about 30 seconds to figure it out
and he does follow up on his main idea
the Knight now Parks itself on B6 and
now Wesley's got to figure out a way to
either defend the pawn on D6 or generate
counter play on the other side of the
board to distract alireza well now that
you mentioned that at first I would say
Bishop fader King E7 but G5 comes to
mind as an idea for black because you
said distract if I were to open up well
what's Happening Here Rook D7 check if
you take only five so that's a great
move all of a sudden Ali Reza has
positional dominance that was overlooked
by Wesley I think as evidenced by his
delayed reaction to that move he has to
close the center with D5 but now white
is all over him on the queen side
I'm still a little bit worried about
alirez's night but this night is
completely unattackable and farrugia can
continue uh to accumulate the initiative
by sliding The Rook over to C3 Wesley
kind of hanging by a thread here Knight
takes B7 will be met with Rook takes D7
and you called it Robert you've got to
be very careful not to allow G5 if
you're alireza and look at that move
Knight F6 the bishop slides back because
it was under attack it was loose on B7
and now white can play G5 and keep that
Knight cemented on the F6 square that
feels really uncomfortable for black I
wouldn't love opening the H file if I'm
thinking about this from alirez's
perspective but then Knight on F6 that
is a beast yeah can play G5 should play
G5 and he did play G5 and Wesley
exploiting his only asset attacking F4
it's sacrificed by farrugia Rook takes
F4 he wants Knight to D3 no but that
doesn't work because of Rook C4 and I
think all the Reza might have overlooked
that detail he's got to go for Knight
takes C6 and things get completely crazy
in the first game
yeah this is wild look at Wesley what I
love about top players and look at this
King takes Knight on E6 that is
unbelievable he could have just taken
with his Bishop he's walking his King
into the middle this is King of the Hill
wind for black it also might be a chess
win for black he has no fear because
that King cannot be cornered white has
insufficient material to mate the king
now you can simplify by removing this
knight from the board maybe bringing the
other Bishop out to E6 and black is
likely to win a second Pawn on the king
side that would end up in a technically
winning position for Wesley instead
though he brings his Rook to F2 one
second for farouza as he continues to
chase the King around the board
wow but now it's winning for black the
king is if it goes to H6 it gets Rook H1
it goes up to H4 and G3 and now the king
is completely safe and Wesley's winning
material it's over
yeah
G2 What a fine by Wesley this is one of
the coolest opening games we've seen in
the speeches championship and now it's a
technically winning position a little
bit of work is still required for Wesley
who's got seven seconds on the clock
he's got to work his King out of the
checking zone of black of White's Rook
now he's gotta unpin his bishop and he
loses a pawn wait a second
that's a really important Pawn because
now how do you actually attack White's
remaining three over there the white
king will just sit on either oh he went
C3 he wants to trade it but the engine
didn't love it no but now he's gonna
simplify on D4 and he's gonna try to set
up some sort of a fortress I think with
only eight seconds Wesley doesn't have
the time to figure out the optimal
winning setup here I don't even know if
it's winning I actually think it's a
draw I think it's just a fortress
there's no progress to be made here
and White's moves are so easy King B1
King A2 King B1 King A2 at some point
you have to take with the B4 script but
King A4 and this is what's happening
right now but the king can't stay on A4
forever well if you're Wesley I think
you have to try to play B4 at some point
and it's not even a fact that when you
do that you're gonna be able to win
White's last remaining Pawn but I feel
like that's Black's only attempt if you
can get rook and Bishop versus Rook you
can milk that out for another 50 moves
and hope for a mistake
and this is one of those games where if
it is in fact going to be a draw alireza
earned it by staying afloat by making
that King run from the King side back to
the queen side and stealing a pawn at a
critical moment so how easy is this draw
because I honestly think that white just
shuffles The Rook back and forth and
there's very little black can do the
only thing white should avoid is trading
Rooks because you CA unless you can
guarantee that you can liquidate Black
slash remaining Pawn but that's very
very hard to do because anytime white
plays B3 and A4 black just plays B4
alireza doing the right thing by keeping
his rook in the vicinity of the third
rank
and Wesley takes away the king's square
but the Rook just goes back and forth
back and forth rookie three he's forced
oh my gosh he's gonna win
what a recognition by West he tricked
him he set that up from a distance
he lulled him to sleep alireza kept
going rugby three Rook a three Rook B3
he had already reached the conclusion
that Wesley didn't see a single way to
make progress It's precisely at the
moment when he switched off his brain
that Wesley set up that four-stroke
trade unbelievable he wins it in the
last second literally
that was Unreal and from Wesley so I
really felt like he was earning a
victory throughout that game the way he
took on E6 with his King marched out
into the open stole a piece and then
still played on Wesley that was
unbelievable stuff but for Ali Reza you
have to get over it that was a bitter
defeat in that game but now in game two
it's a whole new position a whole new
set of circumstances yeah what a game
that game had so many different stages
and absolutely no shame in losing a game
like that if you're far Asia you fought
to the last drop of blood and right now
they have a very topical line in the
Karo Khan where White's last move pins
this Knight on E5 obviously you do not
want to go Bishop D6 and blunder the
Knight to F4 as far as I remember there
is a very enterprising Pawn sacrifice
with this move Knight to E4 the other
possibility is Queen E7 that's the more
straightforward move in order to unpin
the Knight but after Bishop to B5 check
there I think white might hold a very
minuscule Edge
and when we're talking about specific
players I think Wesley would have
preferred to see Queen E7 because he
loves these tiny advantages he's one of
the most precise players in chess
history Knight E4 at least makes things
Messier and that's more farrugia style
it really is and I also think this is
objectively sound for black white can
now take twice on e4 and reinforce the
pin but already in that situation black
can bring the bishop out and defend the
Knight I'll show this if we could pull
up an analysis board real fast as Wesley
puzzles out these complications what
happens after Bishop D6 is that white
lacks development and even though F4
looks like it wins a piece it actually
allows this incredibly nasty check on H4
what does this check do well this check
counterpins the F1 so that after the
king moves black can unpin the Knight by
Castle in kingside then drop the Knight
back to G6 and obviously White's
position is completely in shambles after
Bishop D6 I'm pretty sure that the main
line is Knight F3 but now black and
Castle once again and again using some
simple tactics in order to ensure the
safety of whatever piece lands on E5 you
cannot take because of rookie 8 Wesley
having calculated these lines decides on
uh a more relaxed approach with Bishop
B5 check
and this seems like a very Wesley
position he is playing against the iqp
the isolated Queen Pawn that variation
that you just showed was really
something and an important line to
remember because you can't just go
material grabbing without development
from White side so Bishop B5 check a
black plays Bishop to D7 I think that
white can even play Knight F3 now
because I don't think black can take the
99 F3 as G takes F3 wins a piece oh
that's really lovely because Bishop
takes B5 runs into Queen takes B5 with
check and then you do lose the Knight on
e4
any poison and this just looks good to
my eyes for white so black probably is
just a complete development but you do
need to watch out for this F3 idea that
even if the knights trade is black in
danger of losing a piece at some moment
yeah black can actually take on B5 and
then meet Queen takes B5 with Queen to
D7
and that engineer is a very likely Queen
trade now in general when you're
fighting against an isolated Queen pawn
queen trades are will be in this case in
White's favor because you can much more
easily pile up on the pawn without
having to worry about uh having to
secure your king side against Black's
active pieces so that's not the most
desirable option against someone like
Wesley so farouza has to be very careful
um as you hinted at a little bit earlier
Robert going into positions that are up
Wesley's alley
in this position it's like for white you
Castle you put a rook on D1 Bishop on E3
bring your knight from B1 out to D2
there's this long-term nagging Advantage
for white and back in the day when Kappa
Blanca was playing he would have
salivated over this type of position
because when you have an isolated Pawn
you need to use the open files in the
adjacent lines the C and the E file but
Black's King is still in the center the
d-pawn does feel a bit tender uh there
is actually no defender of that pawn
just yet so I feel like for Wesley as
soon as he gets his King to safety he's
gonna try to pile up pressure on that
pawn and From perugia's perspective you
know that what do the textbooks
recommend when you possess an isolated
Queen Pawn well it's to maximize the
activity of your pieces in order to make
it as difficult for your opponent as
possible to focus his efforts on
surrounding and ultimately winning that
pawn that means if you have a bishop
bring it out to the square where it
causes maximum angst and I think that
square is C5 not only because you're
pressuring F2 but you're also directly
preventing the move Rook to D1 now
obviously white can play Bishop B3 but
if he plays Bishop E3 too early well
maybe black can play Bishop takes E3 and
then you can't recapture with the queen
or black interest castle and keep the
tension but that's exactly what we're
seeing we're going to see a trade on E3
a trade on D7 and farouza is probably
going to follow up by putting a rook on
the gate and trying to play against that
Queen on E3
and the queen is misplaced out in the
open like this that Queen belongs in a
square like B3 uh but as you're
indicating the Knight coming into F4 is
something that is going to be worrisome
and now that we have a trade on e4 black
just takes with the pawn fixing the
structure don't see why black would be
worse no black is definitely not worse
after d takes E4 probably not that much
worse after Rook takes E4 either but if
you have a chance to eradicate the
isolated Queen Pawn especially if you
can do it with Tempo then why not Wesley
establishes uh it's still a nice Knight
on D4 even if it has no Pawn to blockade
but look at farusha starting to advance
his Pawn Phalanx on the king side F4 is
a very very nasty threat because it
could be followed up by the shattering
move F3
speaking of shattering moves even if
white tries to stop that whoa I would
say with G3 there could have been F4
nonetheless but he goes F4 himself like
you can't do that with my Pawn in the
way and look at the rerouting of the
knight from E7 up to D5 at the right
moment F4 will be a bit tender and also
that E3 square that Queen will always
need to keep an eye out on it otherwise
that Knight will be jumping around
and the queen jumps back to E2 a much
safer more invulnerable Square than E3
farusha brings his other Rook into the
center looks like if anybody's playing
for a small Edge it might be black here
yeah this turned around so quickly there
was that weakness on D5 now there's a
strength on e4 it is a protected pass
pawn and that move it earned a question
mark I think that for black you got to
get out of this pin that's clear Queen
C7 has a double attack the F4 Pawn
directly and queen B6 check will be a
nuisance with the B2 Pawn being loose
and actually after Queen C7 how are you
playing to defend this Pawn on F4
because I don't believe you could do so
with your queen as Queen to F2 walks
right into Pawn to E3 oh that's a great
Point E3 is such a nasty idea and just
to follow up on your great Point uh
about the pawn on e4 being Black's
creative strength that is the very same
Pawn which just a couple of moves ago
was sitting isolated on D5 but rather
than going to C7 ferrugia goes the other
direction Queen F7 that must be a relief
for Wesley Queen C7 would have posed a
very very nasty challenge to the F4 pawn
it might have forced the weakening move
G3 now Wesley gets a Tempo and he uses
this Tempo to prepare a doubling on the
D file and also ultimately preparing to
highlight that the Knight on D5 although
it looks nice it doesn't have the
support of any pawns so it's not truly
stable
and now white gets the coordination much
desired quarters Rook F to D1 you take
over this D file uh trades oh actually
A2 is hanging I completely missed that
yeah I did I didn't see that either
okay so Queen takes A2 now B7 is hanging
so that doesn't make it very clear
um wow I I really didn't look at the A2
Pawn but now that I have versus queen F7
makes much more sense I'm not really
known for my ability to spot attacks on
Corner pawns they don't really matter
all that much anyway I'm kidding of
course at this level they do 93 and now
it's the F5 Pawn that's under Fire but
Rook D3 using some great tactics to
defend that pawn Knight takes F5 runs
into Rook to D5 and it's so important
that the classic tactic with Queen takes
D5 and 97 doesn't work because that
square is guarded by black snipe
such good awareness from farrugia
because he plays G6 now he wins Connect
Four that pawn chain is beautiful from
H7 to E4 and that Rook on E1 is very
passive so that Rook couldn't even trade
off for the black Rook look at the
domination The Rook on D3 is clearly
been in its counterpart the White Queen
is the only reason that this game isn't
even more in Black's favor
and queen D7 turns the game further into
Black's favor doubling heavy pieces on
the D file establishing essential
presence with Black's Queen very hard
for Wesley to find a source of activity
he's doing his best what a Brazen move
as he advances his Pawn to G4 throwing
caution to the wind and trying to
disrupt this Connect Four Pawn chain for
Russia comedy drops his Knight back he
says I don't mind the queen trade
because in the ensuing end game I'll
have that connected passer and I'll have
a more active Rook
this looks great for black look at this
uh carpet rolled out to E6 King F7 King
E6 F5 will be defended then the black
king is ready for the end game so for
Wesley the big question is can he trade
Rooks does that help him because King
and pawn and games are very similar to
King and Knight end games with the pawns
remaining and it looks like if we get to
a King and pawning game white could be
in huge trouble most King and pawn named
Games should be lost because of the
presence of this pre earlier I said
connected I meant to say protected pass
Pawn on e4 which completely immobilizes
White's King in any pawn end game now
the blackrook could swing back toward D3
that seems to be a really good parking
spot and the problem for white is
actually that this F4 Pawn is a lot
weaker than it appears because anytime
whitesnite moves away from E3 the Black
Knight is going to sink its teeth into
D5 and you might end up losing your
entire King side which is why I would
start with Rook D3 and then consider the
move Knight T5 and that's exactly what
ferrugia is doing and there's our answer
Wesley doesn't mind a rook trade but he
will have to refrain from the nitrate in
the event of Knight D5 I think there's a
huge problem here and he goes Knight to
D5 but if we can bring him a now sport
very quickly I think that Wesley had
something instead of Knight D5 I was
wondering if he could have taken on G4
because if you take with a Pawn on G4
it's what you want to do Blacklist H5
and suddenly there's an outside pass
pawn and a central pass Pawn that you
have to deal with and you see the Evo
Mark all the way down that black would
have actually been winning in a
situation like this so I think Wesley uh
you know he is fortunate to be in the
current position as the engine seem to
say that I have to get to the live board
Donna that suddenly white is actually
doing perfectly fine
and it's a John Pon m game Wesley
actually went for that pawn end game and
decided that black has no way to break
through for Russia is trying his best
but look at Wesley giving away his C
Pawn in order to capture the e-pawn and
now both sides are at a standstill a
great save there by Wesley so who was in
Dire Straits uh for a couple of moves
there toward the end but alireza wasn't
able to bring the hammer down and Wesley
keeps his one-point lead in the early
going of this match
and Wesley was able to save the game and
it wasn't that much worse for him but in
game one alireza who came so close yeah
so close yet so far that's what they say
so for uh I'll raise it still early he
has the white pieces now we have this
Italian game set up and Daniel should we
note that Wesley switched away from the
Sicilian do you think there's any
specific reason or is he kind of playing
dodgeball
he might be playing dodgeball so the
question is always was this part of your
pre-match agenda did you come in
planning to switch openings or did you
not like something about how Ali Reza
responded to the night or if maybe he
wasn't entirely expecting uh the bishop
G5 line from ferrugia it could be a lot
of different things he could also be
testing the water so he could be telling
himself I'm going to try three or four
different systems and I'm gonna choose
the one that works best as we go into
the three in the one minute portion
where getting a comfortable position out
of the opening becomes even more
important
and speaking of comfortable positions
look at this not a single Pawn has been
traded there's no tension between pawns
but Knight to D5 so all there is it
throws that Knight forward please take
me with your knight that way I get that
little baby fork with my Pawn hitting
both your knight and Bishop and so that
won't happen and if Bishop takes D5
white is able to play e takes D5 and
very importantly that pod on A3 takes
away that B4 Square so that D5 Pawn it's
doubled it may seem like a weakness it's
not easy for black to get to that's a
great point and the same concept uh
comes in where the Knight can't drop
back to E7 because there's a bishop
there otherwise once again white would
have lost the D5 Pawn by force and so
Wesley has to essentially live with that
Knight for the foreseeable future how is
he going to work around it well probably
he's going to play bishop f8 and then he
actually will have the positional threat
of Bishop takes D5 and Knight E7 So
eventually perusa has to decide what
he's doing with this Knight this might
be his last opportunity to secure the
bishop air if he wants it instead he
focuses on Queen side expansion with B4
and once again what is he going to do
with this Knight
that's a really good question and a lot
of us would say wait don't you guys talk
about the bishop pair being an advantage
this is a closed position so taking that
Bishop on E7 that wouldn't lead to much
of anything because in closed positions
Knights they can see over pieces Bishops
they stare into them so I think that was
a good call by all there is to leave
that dark Square Bishop where is that
Bishop 1 f8 going it has all of its own
Pawns in the way
yeah but that move because it permitted
the Knight to drop back to E7 it
effectuated a trade of two minor pieces
much to Black's relief so Wesley does a
great job of disarming that night on D5
and farouza continues his campaign of
Queen side and Central expansion the
pawn comes up to C4 which does create
you know a medium-sized weakness on D4
but that square is very well connected
protected by White's remaining minor
pieces you could bring the bishop up to
B2 or E3 connected protect it I don't
know the difference between words in the
English language anymore
I think that they both work and here you
see uh the bishop on G7 for black is
Wesley gonna strike with F5 that's one
of the big questions in this position
that's playing in the king's Indian
style but is it maybe biting off more
than you can chew he first has to deal
with his Knight I think that Knight has
a tough choice actually and he goes to
E7 but where to from there that's why I
didn't like that square yes one Robert
Hess would point out the pawn and the
night they're on the same file and
there's two squares between them never a
good sign for a knight that once an
active future that is why I would have
preferred to drop the Knight back to d8
looks like an even more passive square
at first Until you realize that the
queen could then drop back and the
Knight could find a beautiful home on E6
where it controls uh these Key Dark
squares in the center and on the king
side so 97 might be a slight positional
in accuracy but if Wesley follows it up
with F5 and manages to run this Pawn
down at four later on he might be able
to play G5 and deploy the Knight to G6 I
think that's exactly what he's trying to
do and I'm curious what farugia will
come come up with in response to this
idea
I'm almost surprised that Westies on the
black side of this position he showed me
this I would say oh Wesley's gonna play
a positional Masterpiece from the white
side he is going to expand on the queen
side as Ali raises just say with A4 and
at the right moment white will think
about playing C5 but if white plays C5
black has D5 and we need to calculate
what happens with that pawn I would say
Pawn push through that black is not
going to open up files at least not for
that Rook on C1 so we see A4 play first
I think black can consider it any moment
A6 Donya to open up that Rook on A8 but
again after A6 will white leave the pawn
there will white play B6 these aren't
always easy questions to answer they're
very difficult questions and if I saw
these moves in isolation right C4 B5 A4
and from black side F5 and quite
possibly F4 and G5 you would think that
this is actually a king's Indian you
also have a fan cutter Bishop on G7 so
it's amazing in how many ways this
position resembles a king's Indian
struggle with white attacking on the
queen side and black on the king side
there's the answer to your question
Robert Wesley meets alireza at the top
with A6 he did not want Reza to push A6
and weaken some of these light squares
on the queen side
but what a good response from farusha
Bishop D2 protects the A5 pawn and white
wants black to take on B5 for two very
important reasons after ab5 cb5 The Rook
on C1 hits C7 but also white will have
access to an outside pass Pawn so that's
why Wesley said I'm not going to budge I
open my Rook to f8 I'm getting that
kings in the attack ready but know what
else the bishop is doing on D2 it's not
in the Rooks path from E1 so there could
be some tactics on the e-file at the
right moment to me that that further
raises the appeal of playing the move F5
F4 because you are depriving white of
the opportunity to take on F5 and maybe
follow up with something like D4 I don't
think that's a dangerous idea because D4
could always be met with the obvious E4
but it's curious to me that Wesley is
delaying the move F5 F4 he might even
want to play G5 with the pawn still on
F5 what do you make of his decision to
keep the tension on the king side is he
maybe trying to double Rooks on the app
file
he could and I think that's why Oliver
took an A6 but I usually trust Wesley's
instincts in these positions I was
looking at D4 for white at the right
moment because of the Rook staring
through the e-file towards the queen but
look at ferrugia he says now is the
right time for C5 and if black plays D5
which we're just seeing Queen B3 perhaps
and there are pins in all directions
pins and x-rays Queen B3 is a lovely
move to immobilize the D5 Pawn of course
you could play e takes D5 but then
you're creating an accessible weakness
on D3 you're also potentially allowing
black to unpin his Queen and then Park
the knight from E7 to C6 that looks like
a pretty ideal setup for white uh for
black that is and white will be saddled
with a bunch of weak isolated pawns on
the queen side so it's all well and good
that alireza engineered this queen side
pressure but he's kind of left with a
bunch of long-term weaknesses so he has
to continue playing for the initiative
in order to counterbalance that what a
move
I love that move because if the Knight
takes you've opened up the C file so the
White Queen go to A4 Rook takes C7 to
follow and suddenly it's the black king
that's the one in some danger and if you
don't take that pawn on C6 now you
prevented black from playing C6 himself
so the D5 Pawn is a Target and now
that's up with D4 as you point out and
while there is a played Bishop B4 let's
try to get good knight for White against
the questionable Bishop on G7 now if you
could reposition this Knight if Knights
move diagonally and you dropped it onto
D5 white would be positionally winning
the problem is that this Knight on F3
has no easy path to get to any of the
squares that it wants to go to and
another excellent defensive move by
Wesley a counter-attacking move sticking
The Rook on an outpost attacking A5 and
it actually seems to me that black is
better because he's got the protected
faster on D4 He's Got The Rook on f8
staring down the Knight and again white
is saddled with these weaknesses on the
queen side let alone the fact that
alireza is down to 20 seconds and Wesley
has managed his time excellently
such a fantastic series of moves from
Wesley he has gotten rid of all of his
problems he just stole a Pawn on A5 now
he can bring his Rook to well not now I
mean Rook A3 runs to The Rook takes C7
but they're looking at this A6 pawn it
might be the little Pawn that could and
get to the other side
and Rook C5 would be a way to circumvent
the pro the Tactical problems with Rook
A3 of course there you would be giving
up the A6 pawn and he does play Rook A3
so I'm sure he sees Rook takes C7 I'm
curious does he want to play Queen D6
there then white goes Rook to D7 you get
some crazy tactical Struggle No he just
takes on C7 and takes on C6 that's
simple that's strong and it's very very
hard to play against and queen C3 I
think is going to force a favorable
Queen trade in a winning end game
oof and that's easy to miss if you're
far Asia especially when you don't have
time but the Rook on f8 was loose Queen
C3 forces the Queens off and that is a
protected pass Pawn protected by what
you may say that Bishop on G7 that if
the Knight moves to say D3 can go into
the D4 square and then it's going to be
difficult for white to deal with this uh
this stuff's a C2 now and then
but C2 Rook C1 Rook B8 right that's
that's it
Knight D2 in that position
I guess holds on but no Bishop 63 yep
and that's exactly what we're gonna see
the problem with these positions is that
your background kills you your Rook
can't move past the back the first rank
there's no way that you use the measly
resources at your disposal to both stop
the pawn and prevent black stroke from
getting to B1 or to D1 West they're just
gonna take a little bit of time here he
always does this Robert he's so
methodical he's going to calculate
everything out to its completion before
going down a particular line
and he brings his Rook to d8 and that
should be that it should be but that
pawn is getting very far so Bishop B2
that way you can promote the pawn with
the help of your Bishop riding The Rook
so The Rook can slide to E8 after the
pawn goes to E7 good recognition by you
and by Wesley another very precise game
from Wesley so the one thing to avoid
here is the tempting Rook D1 because
their white actually does go E7 okay
Bishop F6 also wins because Rook D1 is
now Unstoppable and the bishop will give
itself up for the pawn what a game
surgical Precision there Wesley with the
black pieces in an Italian an opening
that he knows so well with both colors
how do people beat Wesley so how does
that ever happen
I'm wondering the same thing maybe it's
by playing the king's Indian
that's a good try and Hikaru Nakamura
has a very famous victory over Wesley so
in the black side of King's Indian uh
but in all seriousness Wesley he's so
accurate he doesn't take huge risks he's
very hard to tilt as we talked about
it just seems like it's borderline
impossible to beat him unless you're on
your A Plus game which always has not
shown just yet today but the the Wesley
so that we saw show up these last couple
of games is the Wesley so that I
remember in the chess.com Global
Championship he I think didn't lose a
single game I want to say that entire
finals in Toronto and
he it wasn't like he was playing top C
Turvy games and he was getting lucky he
was holding absolutely everybody
including kikaru at arm's length he
wasn't even close uh to losing a game at
that tournament and I'm starting to see
that boa constrictor Wesley show up
today of course it's still very very
early in the match let's see Folly Reza
can create counter chances in this sharp
King's Indian position which is really
up alirez's alley I like this opening
choice
and one of your favorite openings the
Knight gives out to H5 it wants to hop
into F4 and Wesley reacts by stopping
Knight F4 but creating weaknesses in
front of his own King that Bishop on C8
can slide to H3 but I wouldn't go for
that I think it's a mistake that newer
players make Dania where they're so
tempted by a square that they now
control they want to attack a rook but
the Rook wants to be on E1 anyway so
playing Bishop H3 can only help White
I agree completely Bishop HB Ricky won
and that Bishop is neither here nor
there the typical attacking Motif uh in
combination with Knight H5 is to bring
the queen out to G5 but what does that
do you might think well you're not
really trying to sack the Knight on G3
and you're not the idea of Queen G5 can
actually be to prepare Knight H5 to F4
because the g-pawn is pinned against the
king so I like Queen G5
do you see any other moves that might
appeal to alireza here
issue is tempting I just I'm not a huge
fan of it unless it leads to somewhere
concrete so yeah I'm out of options
Queen G5 does look very very strong but
what is he worried about do you think he
sees Queen G5 thinks that white well
maybe a knight B5 right B5 and then
there's I think C7 I think that's what
he's worried about yeah Knight C7 and
the D5 Pawn is hanging so in that
position you already have to start
calculating Knight F4 very concretely
Knight F4 also could run into H4 so
things get incredibly messy and if black
doesn't capitalize on his attacking
opportunities as so often happens to the
king's Indian you're in trouble on the
other side of the board so the margin of
error is very very thin
all there is a down a minute and a half
it's been like this all of the five plus
one thus far Wesley gets a huge lead in
The Clock alireza you know he finds he
good moves he fights but he when he gets
into that kind of time travel against
Wesley's accuracy it's not been going
well for him
okay Bishop H3 is on the board but your
point is well taken Robert he didn't
make this move in five seconds which
means he is aware of the deficiencies uh
of dragging The Rook to a square it
wants to go to anyway I'm very curious
how he's going to follow up I'm still
partial to the move Queen G5 and maybe
the idea of Bishop H3 was to make sure
that the Rooks are connected so that he
could bring the a rook over to d8 if the
necessity arose uh just kind of
reinforcing the D5 pawn and in the event
of Knight B5 Rook d8 would take the
sting out of uh a night jump to C7
so that makes perfect sense and he goes
for Queen to G5 I like that decision by
alireza and now after Knight to B5 as
you mentioned the Rook can just slide to
d8 Knight F4 is coming the one downside
of your Bishop being on H3 is that your
knight can't get to H3 because after
Knight F4 you might want to hop in with
that check but this is a complicated
game and Wesley and all there is a both
will take their time
and this is exactly the kind of position
that you want if you're far Asia you
don't really want to have it two minutes
down on the clock and we do see Knight
D5 on the board and now a big moment for
farouza Rook 88 might be the direct idea
of bringing the bishop to H3 but it's
definitely not the only move you could
shove this Pawn down to D4 and try to
open up the D file and only then put the
Rook on d8 of course D4 runs into Knight
E4 Knight F4 is very much possible it's
a move that has to be calculated I'm not
going to pretend like I know what's
going on after Knight C7 and my maybe
neither do the players this is a
position where in a Blitz game you make
a lot of your decisions intuitively
such a difficult moment here for Wesley
and for Ali Raisa because black playing
D4 as you said gives the access to E4
Square for that white knight so at first
glance that looks like something you
don't want to do but Rook a to d8 then
the Knight system D6 in front of it
anyway D5 is loose B7 is under attack
The Rook 98 is threatened it does feel
like white could seize the momentum of
these Excel moves and I'm very worried
Donya about alirez's clock I mean in a
classical game I could totally conceive
of spending 20 or 25 minutes in this
position alone weighing the different
candidate options again if you sacrifice
something and the attack doesn't work
out you lose the game right that is the
price you pay for for playing and
opening like the king's Indian as Ali
Reza drops now to a minute on the clock
and those three extra minutes that
Wesley has garnered with his rapid play
uh is I think going to come in very
handy over the next couple of moves
well you said rapid play just reminded
me that these two did just face off in
the Champions chest tour and all the
ways that won their match two and a half
one and a half so Revenge might be on
Westy's mind and we mentioned this
earlier but just to reiterate the point
that before that rapid match against one
another the last time they played online
was in 2020. so they have not played
each other much online over the years
but right now Wesley is in the driver's
seat all the reason is not moving he's
under 30 seconds Donya incredible 24
seconds as he plays Bishop to E5 that is
not a move which we mentioned the idea
though very clear he's trying to
circumscribe the activity of the night
he's preventing Knight C7 but he is
offering up the D5 Pawn Wesley has to
figure out whether he's taking it and if
so with what piece my instinct would be
to take it with the queen Knight takes
D5 does run into Rook Ada and white is
experiencing major problems in the
center but such a typical Wesley move he
doesn't engage and he tries to set up
the potential idea of that for although
Robert F4 immediately is not a threat
because blacken simply capture on F4 and
there you're actually benefiting finally
from bringing your Bishop out to H3
look at all of his clock I mean he needs
to make a move he's down under 10
seconds he plays Rook 888 so King H1 is
one of those moves that you can get away
with when your opponent is down three
and a half minutes the time management
has not been particularly good for
others
and I thought Bishop F1 deserves
attention instead he goes Rook G1
reinforcing the threat of f4 forcing
alirez's Bishop back apparently that was
a mistake and he's allowed the Knight to
sink its teeth into D6 and I worry that
Black's position is about to start
crumbling after a well-timed F4 maybe
even right now I was gonna say what time
is it it's uh F4 it's four times you
could play it the queen has to move
Bishop takes H5 G takes H5 Queen takes
H5 where is that Bishop on H3 going
it has no squares Bishop takes H5 you
might have to sack and exchange on D6 in
order to vacate a diagonal back for the
bishop but that's not going to cut it
and this is the problem with having five
seconds you might make the right move
one time two times even three times but
this position has no end in sight you're
gonna have to keep finding the right
moves over and over and over again and
you're not gonna get away with that
against someone like Wesley he will find
a way to put you in a position where you
literally don't have the time to figure
anything out properly
Wesley's been thinking and he still is
up two and a half minutes that's such a
bad sign for all the reason and Bishop
takes H5 that looks obvious he's gone
for that now
oh F7 is hanging
okay there are some light Square
weaknesses though Robert maybe some sort
of Bishop G4 Bishop F3 is what alireza
is praying for and at this point all he
has is a prayer because he's got five
seconds he's dropping all of his pawns
he has to try Queen H5 here get the
queen to F3
oh he plays Rook to f8 and isn't that
Knight hanging on C6 with Queen 65 to
follow
it is I think we take C6 wins the game
and at that point it's too late for
Queen H5 because if Queen takes D5
and the Queen's now there so queen of
three is a Checkmate threat
oh okay oh what a Wesley so move G4 oh
that's so nice
that's beautiful Bishop takes G4 would
disarm the threats against White's King
and runs the bishop D4 check which ended
the game I think we've reached the
midpoint break of the five plus one
segment we'll see
no I think this game is going to count
because they have okay gone below the
midpoint uh the Friday Reza I think he
wants halftime just to shake it off it's
still very early and Daniel you had the
call for some of these previous matches
against Dimitri on draken wasn't on
draken up by three points in the five
plus one he was
so history if it's going to repeat
itself that would be good news for
alireza but Wesley so isn't Dimitri on
draken with all respect meant to Dimitri
we were just talking about how Wesley
almost never loses and thus far he's
lost precisely zero times and that last
game it felt like alireza was coming
close but and it's easy for me to say
I'm not the one facing Wesley in a
complicated position but he sabotaged
himself Robert by bringing himself down
to five seconds in a completely
undefined middle game position there's
almost no scenario where you can survive
against Wesley with five seconds to
three minutes
it doesn't matter if you're better or
not
I'm with you you can see farooza he is
unhappy right now he is really not
liking the way this match is going but
what he should be liking is the clock
situation suddenly he's the one who's up
what's about to be a minute on the clock
and that means he can press
and the reason Wesley is investing so
much time has to do with figuring out
whether he wants to play G5 he can take
this in two completely opposite
directions a more tactical Direction
with G5 of course he also could have
castled kingside as is more conventional
now why is this so committal obviously
black is not going to Castle anytime
soon and you also have to reckon with
the idea of D4 blasting open the center
and if black doesn't handle that
position with tremendous caution his
position is liable to blow up
and the thing is you should throw
caution to the wind if you're farooza
you need to time these things well you
can't just go all in for an attack by
playing D4 and then dropping the E4 Pawn
that could give black the necessary
resources to save his own King black can
Castle in some of these positions but as
you highlight the knights you're
probably coming to G6 first the king
castles that goes with the G7 it's hard
to attack that black king with that pawn
those pawns and those Knights no
completely and and you're absolutely
right yeah black does in fact sometimes
Castle kingside
um a lot of newer players believe that
anytime you push a king Side Pawn up
then the King has to remain in the
center but white doesn't have you know
the necessary Firepower on the king side
to really punish black for making these
weaknesses to my untrained eye and I do
play the Italian with black I'm not too
experienced in these types of positions
I feel like Black's got a great position
I mean Knight G6 already threatens
something like H5 H4 and you absolutely
can get blown off the board on the king
side if you don't Counter-Strike
promptly with D4 but D4 gives up the E4
pawn and I think we're gonna see Wesley
capturing it and meeting D takes E5 with
D5 to keep the center closed
this looks very promising for black and
it's I think this game specifically
could be dictated by the match score
that Ali razor feels like he needs to
take risks but the person that you
typically do not want to take risks
against is Wesley so because he's not
somebody who starts frantically
searching without objectivity he's
someone who look at him he's barely
changed his posture the entire day thus
far and he just calculates he does not
get phased he's so impressive and the
only thing that has prevented him from
winning a speeches Championship is
tokara Nakamura he's prevented a lot of
people he's been the only thing that's
prevented a lot of people from winning
uh the speed Chess Championship but
Wesley included when when he's on form
he's like a well-oiled machine and right
now he has to decide whether he's
playing T5 and whether or not he is
garnering the bishop pair or trying to
trap Black's Bishop White's Bishop with
H5 instead he's gone for a different
route Knight to F5 he threatens to take
twice on G3 that Bishop on A7 is one
could argue the unsung hero it's really
the piece that's making Black's machine
run
and you can't even take on e4 because
once you do that black takes back with
the pawn which hits the knight in F3
almost forces a queen trade and I feel
like White's position is really falling
apart already
White's got a terrible position because
there's no defense against Knight takes
you through if you're not taking on e4
and I'm with you I think that end game
is even worse than the middle game you
can't go King H1 because black will take
on G3 and then you'll actually lose even
more than a Pawn on F2
this is not a good set of games for
alireza and the half time cannot come
soon enough it will happen after this
game he'll be able to take a break but
look at him he can't even look at the
position that he has because he
understands that Wesley is favored in
this game as well
he's borderline lost and it's not like
Wesley will take twice on G3 and stop
there no no no that knight from G3 can
Circle back to H5 and then plant itself
on F4 and then Wesley will start
advancing his other pawns you know G4
and queen H4 the debilitating thing is
that alireza has nothing going at all on
the other side of the board there's
nothing on the queen side Black's got no
weaknesses It Feels Like Only Wesley
gets these kinds of positions on the
black side of an Italian in which he was
the one who played G7 G5 to unbalance
the game he succeeded except White's the
position White's the one with an
unbalanced position not black because
it's because Wesley times these things
well some players they speculate they
throw their pawns forward Wesley doesn't
do that and remember you were the one
calling it out that Wesley spent about a
minute on the clock trying to figure out
if G5 would work he spent 41 seconds as
I see here it does work it was the
perfectly acceptable move now he has a
great position because white perusa he
got a little bit too ambitious and look
at farugia it's like he doesn't even
want to be playing anymore
and he's doing the same thing he did
last game except for a different reason
there he was deciding between three very
tempting candidate moves or two here he
has no idea what to play I mean this is
a position in which 50 years ago I think
an old school GM might actually resign
in disgust and I was going to say I
think Knight D4 might be the Lesser evil
I think alireza did a great job of
finding the move which affords him the
most practical chances because the game
isn't over and this still is a Blitz
game Knight D4 poses black with a
dilemma black can take twice on D4 black
can take once on G3 and then take on D4
you know it's like you're standing over
a buffet at Golden Corral you have to
decide which pieces you're taking are
you getting the stake first or are you
getting yourself some rice there are
some complicated decisions to be made
here and Wesley himself is down at two
and a half minutes and the problem is
after you eat all of that you get a
stomach ache so you have to be very
careful if you are Wesley because Knight
D4 Pawn takes D4 Bishop takes D4 there's
some Bishop B5 check ideas there and
that G7 the G5 push can't hurt you quite
badly so look at Wesley he does not want
that full stomach in terms of Pawns he
wants it to win a bishop which is pretty
much upon where it sits on G3 he wants
an even Fuller stomach he doesn't just
want uh you know some Buffet items he
wants the black caviar he wants the
champagne with the move H4 now the
typical response of course is for white
to push the h-bomb but guess what after
Knight takes two three you have to take
back with the F Pawn and then the black
Bishop would take on D4 with check and
then eat another Pawn on B2 alireza
throws away the epon to get himself the
E5 score but even that is not going to
help because Bishop E5 is just going to
be met with F6 he is getting crunched
here is Ali Reza farouza in this fifth
game
I don't even have suggestions for him he
could take the Knight on e4 but we keep
highlighting how that doesn't actually
solve White's problems the D4 Pawn will
be loose he's going for that maybe look
what he's doing just Knight C3 if Queen
takes D4 will he like Queen c one or
something it doesn't look good though I
can't find a legit try
he might have to exchange queens and
play Knight takes C4 and play that
horrible horrible Pawn down end game but
that's the least of his problems there
Black's also got the bishop pair and
monster coordination and even with the
Queen's off the board the prospect of
black you know running the pawn up to H3
and inducing light Square weaknesses on
the king side uh is is no less scary
than with the Queen's on and Wesley
continues to just play perfectly he's
making all the top engine moves he's not
giving alireza a chance here
no and what can others do queen C1 is
probably not by even E3 uh for black
just cutting off that Queen and other
takes on C7 and trading Queens all right
I see the problem for black is the E4
Pawn is a bit loose you can't throw in
this E3 push as I was saying but it does
open the position up for some of White's
pieces all right Alvarez is fighting and
Wesley while still up on time it's not
three minutes just one in this game but
another Super accurate move Rook C8
forcing this bishop to decide and it
cannot decide to drop back to G3 because
of H4 it might have to try Bishop A5 I
thought he plays Bishop to D6 because
the queen defends that Bishop through
the X-ray very important for newer
players to realize that Bishop is not
hanging it's defended by White's Queen
and now the pawn E4 is defended by The
Pawn on F5 so it looks safe and sound in
the middle of the board and for Wesley
he trades Queens though King F7 bring a
rook to d8 and he's trying to swap
everything off this is honestly an
artist at work and alireza cannot take
this position any further and can you
blame him
no I cannot but look at Wesley so we
have the five head cam on screen
wherever he is it doesn't matter if it's
a hotel room or his home and a new room
in that home he leads this mesh four and
a half to half Donya this is as
one-sided as you could possibly imagine
it's so hard to believe that the person
virtually sitting across from Wesley is
Ali Raza farusha who's used to doing
this to other people he's not used to
this being done to him Wesley is playing
some of the best chess that we've seen
thus far in the SEC surgical Precision
every game he is up by four points and
we're barely even getting underway
what does alireza have to do during this
break to rebound Dania
I mean the openings aren't going well
the middle games aren't going well he's
taking too much time I think that's the
biggest problem olly Reza has to lean on
what he does best which is Play Good
intuitive chess he can't dig himself
into a hole on the clock he's got to
reevaluate some of the openings and he's
got to come back with a fresh head a
fresh pair of eyes and a fresh desire to
come back from this hole that he
suddenly finds himself in
we'll see if he's able to do just that
the players they get a break hopefully
some refreshments will do the same but
do not go anywhere it's more from
alareza versus Westie on the flip side
of the break here speech's Championship
who's that by coinbase
[Music]
thank you
I'm Andrea and I'm Alex and we've been
playing competitive chess since we were
six years old
we started by focusing on classical
chess but later we fell in love with
playing Blitz and bullet online
chess has been around for more than one
thousand years but that doesn't mean
that we can't modernize it Financial
systems have been around for even longer
sounds like it's time for nothing and
coinbase is doing just that
re-envisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent also huge thank you to
coinbase for sponsoring competitive
chess and making events like the SCC
happen go to coinbase.com update the
system to learn more
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash this Barbarian
might not Crush you on the board but he
certainly can Crush you with the board
talking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects and other people's pieces
the battleheart in Valkyrie might give
you a game once she's done arm wrestling
egg Gollum
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her those fear her you'll need to
bring your A game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare
play them all on chess.com
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase Rusty
show is the second most experienced
player in the field he has been a
Mainstay of the speed test championship
and Donya he has done very well in
previous editions in fact in deep
quarterfinals there's only one player
who has beaten him in recent years and
that was Maxine versus Cher lagrav but
he is undefeated in the first round and
there you see it in the quarterfinals
only to Maxime a year ago with the
Eagles match and look at the people he
beat and look at the margins by which he
beat them he had a relatively close win
against mvl in 2019 he crushed bit it he
crushed Duda he beat Bobby by eight
points Wesley is so consistent in the
SEC it's honestly unbelievable
it really is and Wesley he lost a Maxima
year ago that doesn't come with too much
of a surprise when you see the form that
Maxine was in yesterday and was in a
year ago in the SEC so these players
they're all the leaders of World Chess
they are capable of beating anybody else
in the field of course it's been Hikaru
Nakamura and Magnus Carlson at the top
but Wesley so with the lead that he has
right now he wants his first SCC crown
he does indeed and he's showing that
with every move that he's making he's
winning games in a variety of different
openings and in a variety of different
ways after that ultra competitive first
game that went back and forth and
ultimately ended in a draw it's been
smooth sailing for Wesley on the board
and on the clock and that might be the
biggest source of concern for Ali Raza
he's got to speed up he has to start
trusting himself and I like his choice
of King's Indian he got a good position
the first time
um no reason to do anything drastic and
start playing anything extreme
no that's one of the things that we talk
about often is that we often blame
openings for our losses we lost the game
we remember that we played the Sicilian
no more Sicilian no more night off but
it hasn't been an opening issue for
alireza it's been a clock management
issue where we're used to seeing him
play in the blink of an eye here he's
been way too deliberative he's spending
so much time when he knows the positions
in the first King's Indian game we saw a
gligarish system that's where white
plays Bishop E2 and Bishop E3 before
Castle link King side here Wesley opt
for the classical system and we saw move
seven Knight to A6 by alireza ferocia
which is often considered the main
sideline uh to the Marvel Plata
variation which is the night coming out
to C6 and you get very similar
structures uh in this line black has
just pushed G5 followed by F5 White's
probably gonna take that pawn and we're
gonna get a very interesting open Center
type position where I think ultimately
White's idea is often to go after
control over the E4 Square
this looks like a lot of fun right if
you're far Asia this position just looks
much more appetizing than some of the
other ones he's had and look at the
clock Wesley he's doing the right thing
spending his time but this is one of
those games where alireza he should be
comfortable he is such an excellent
player in these King's Landing positions
quickly drops his Knight back will take
back on F5 down to your King's Indian
player this looks quite nice so
typically you're not recommended uh to
give up the E4 square but I think there
are extenuating circumstances in this
position two of them to be exact first
of all white can't take a knight and put
it on e4 I mean he can but then he won't
have any Knights to speak of in two
moves so in order to actually secure
control of the square white might have
to make a very compromising move such as
F3 which creates you know a host of
other weaknesses on the king side the
second factor is that black has enduring
play on the king side with the idea of
pushing the h-bun the queen could slide
over to F7 the Knight could make its way
to F4 so looking at this position and
reducing it to control over one square
where does not tell the whole story The
King's Indian is a far more complex
opening than that Robert and finally I'd
point out that of course that Knight on
A6 isn't going to be there forever uh
we're likely to see it either on B4 or
on C5 in uh in due course
it's a great Point by you that the queen
going to F7 and maybe up to G6 black
will be able to fight for that E4 Square
so Knight B4 now I think it's a little
bit too obvious what your threat is you
want to go Knight to C2 so white will
slide The Rook to C1 but that is an idea
to keep in the back of your mind I think
that alireza Queen F7 it keeps the
Dynamics in his favor without forcing
anything I would go for that
interestingly if the queen were to be on
G6 in this position night before uh
would have been a far more enduring
threat but he takes a completely
different avenue he plays the move H5
and that is a pawn sacrifice right white
could take that pawn what does alireza
intend in response I actually do think
that it is night before he wanted that
D3 Square for his Knight and Wesley
declines the sacrifice plays the move
that I mentioned earlier and I think
alireza's got a great position after
something like Bishop H6
Wesley didn't want the pawn the bishop
wasn't going to get trapped over there
but black would get clear compensation
on the light squares so Bishop H6 looks
very appealing then you can eventually
play G4 is black opened up that Bishop
on the diagonal he said goes Queen F7
you can't really blame for that and your
knight E4 idea I don't think that white
is playing the uh assuming Black's gonna
take twice on e4 but you can see Queen
G6 compete for that square by putting
your queen on the diagonal and if white
plays Bishop D3 well then we may start
thinking about some trades and you're
bringing a piece away from your king so
black could probably strike at some
moment with H4 and G4 I think you
characterized it best this position is a
lot of fun uh mostly for black but if
white can stabilize the Knight on e4 and
play Bishop D3 and kind of defuse uh the
Flames of the king side attack then from
a positional standpoint uh White is
better especially if you can effectuate
the trade of light Square Bishops black
might be left with kind of a lame King's
Indian Bishop on G7 that's precisely why
I think black should because position
this bishop on H6 and try to get G4 and
as a matter of priority to make sure
that this bishop has a clear role to
play and to make sure that this clear
Knight has a role to play alireza might
want to play Knight C5 before white
shuts it down with the move B4
I think it's now or never for that
because the Knight gets sidelined with
the move B4 and he goes H4 first and
then eight three wow what a good choice
We had the same intonation but I don't
think you can play G4 right because
Knight takes G4 Pawn
whoa let me show that's that's gorgeous
as we see G3 for that reason really
really quickly G4 go ahead obviously
even in the game you can still play
Knight G4 because of this tactic with
Bishop C2 and queen takes F2 with Queen
G2 made to follow
incredible and white cannot move this
queen to E2 because there's a bishop
there and he's played not Knight G4 but
G4 but this move is based on a very
similar idea F takes G4 I think he wants
to play Knight takes G4 since we still
have the analysis board up Bishop takes
you for Bishop takes you for same
problem for white where the bishop on F2
is going to be lost with Checkmate as we
go back to the live board after G4
this is exactly the type of position
that alireza wants and you can see by
his clock he's headed on time Wesley has
more difficult decisions to figure out
take on F3 at any point I like Queen G6
you know why because gf3 would have
given white an easy move now White's not
sure can I ever take on G4 I personally
don't think so that looks like a very
bad decision and if you don't take on G4
what are you gonna do for white
because black has a million ways to
improve his position Knight A6 to C5 I'm
a broken record I've been mentioning
this move for a long time but it is an
integral part of a lot of setups in the
king's Indian you could also play in the
center with a move like C6 black hasn't
sacrificed anything you haven't
committed to playing only on the king
side and Wesley trying to bring as many
pieces to bear on the king side as
possible but his position very
unpleasant I also really like alirez's
time management this game he's left
himself with a significant amount of
time to puzzle through these
complications
Knight C5 looks so appealing to my eyes
there's no way Wesley wants to take that
Knight because the hands block all of
the important dark squares and the black
king is safe and sound the white king
that's the one in the line of fire so
Knight C5 looks good to me C6 also looks
pretty good after that I'm not seeing so
many obvious plans I do not want to take
on F3 right now that allows White's
pieces Knight takes back the Knight H4
and suddenly the black has a lot to
figure out
I'm also partial to the concept of of
doubling Rooks on the f file the problem
is that that might not be a very good if
not might not be a very efficient use of
time because even after you complete the
doubling what are you doing after that
you're not really going to play G takes
F3 I would assume anytime soon because
that kind of helps white get his pieces
to better squares but as I say that Rook
F7 appears on the board you know all
there isn't very well after all you
played countless bullet and Blitz
matches against him it makes a lot of
sense I just wish if you're thinking
about this from him getting back to the
match that he played that move more
quickly because Rook F7 is a move that
doesn't really change all that much it
has an obvious idea behind it but he did
lose a lot of his time and Advantage
okay so big question for Wesley can he
put a piece on e4 should he put a piece
on e4 and I guess the answer is yes and
should alireza capture it or should he
just continue with his campaign of
kingside expansion with Rook AFA well
there's a clear problem that the G4 Pawn
is loose in these positions so if you
keep taking things on e4 well that G4
Pawn becomes whites for the taking I
would play Rook a to f8 he kept the
status quo once why not do it again I
don't think white particularly wants to
open up the king side I don't like that
move at all because Knight takes E4 runs
into Rook takes F7 and you called it
Robert not only is G4 loose but all of
Black's pieces would have been loose in
that position this is a very big
committal decision to give up your light
squared Bishop Ollie Reza's counter play
on the f file better work out or he's
going to be saddled with not only a
weakness on G4 but also light Square
weaknesses all over the king side I'm
not even sure that he's truly
threatening uh to play the move Knight
takes E4 because White's Queen could
move up to D3 or C2 and the Queen on G6
being undefended is a huge tactical
problem here for white uh for black in
the long run and Wesley exploits that by
shutting down this Knight with B4
and strategically blacks in huge trouble
white can play Queen D3 Rook F5 Rook a
to F1 and I don't easily see how black
parries those ideas the king side is
well defended by those Bishops on E3 and
E2 and Bishop H6 that's the one idea
that comes to mind for me but the White
Queen could still go up to D3 and keep
every important Square defendant Bishop
takes E4 is a really panicky impulsive
reaction you just don't play a move like
that unless you have a very clear
follow-up in mind because giving up one
of your main attackers is just not
something that you want to do unless you
get something in return and he's got
nothing in return except more weaknesses
and now a big time deficit for the first
uh for the first time in this game
he doesn't know what to do with any
yeah he brings his life back to B8
because the 986 was doing absolutely
nothing I really liked that decision and
here's a question done Wesley whoa whoa
whoa Rook F1 what is he doing well he
just lost the game on the spot
Rook F1 and he can resign he drops the
bishop on G4
and considering how the first five games
had gone to see Wesley just blunder like
that from a plus position he shakes his
head I'm having a hard time believing it
because at that point it seemed like he
had complete central control
and the crazy thing is even if you know
I always like to ask myself what if this
uh concept had not existed would the
sacrifice then have been Justified and I
think the answer even to that question
is no because black could have taken
with the bishop and gun Bishop G5 there
was absolutely no need to seek more
Adventures on the king side you could
have just accumulated your initiative
with Queen D3 doubled on the f file Etc
but Wesley too many hands spoil the
broth and that guy that time he got way
too fancy it was very unwessy-like
conclusion to that game just blundering
away not even blundering a queen in one
move but he just took that night I said
look at him he's still shaking his head
about that decision he cannot believe he
went for that exchange sacrifice
could that have been a mouse-up could he
have intended recap 5 doesn't really
matter at this point maybe he was
intending Rook out five I was under the
impression that even Rook F5 failed
tactically to Knight take C4 but I guess
that's in the past now what a crazy
moment and that is exactly the kind of
infusion that alireza faruja needed
look at the position now bring this
bishop out to G5 so in some of the
previous games there's a knight on F6
black one H6 and G5 here are the knights
on E7 that means that once the king
escapes the pin there could be an F7 F5
not so easy to escape that pin though
because the queen on B3 and Bishop on C4
are ready to pick off that F7 Pawn
I suppose I mean a move I would play in
bullet is Queen E8 with the idea of King
h8 and F5 but it's also very superficial
and when you play a move like Queen E8
you you indicate your intentions very
clearly to your opponent what could be
the idea of Shifting the content maybe
it's to protect the pawn well why would
you protect the pawn oh maybe it's so
that you can move the king away why
would you move the king away well
probably to play F5 so when you play a
move like Queen E8 you want to be really
confident uh that you will be able to
carry out your main plan and Wesley
takes a much more positional approach he
simply chases the bishop off of G5 that
leads directly to a bishop trade on E3
but the pressure on F7 Robert is now
further accentuated by the semi-openf
file
Queen E8 now makes a lot of sense
I am worried about Bishop takes F7 and
Knight G5 that actually looks like if
black plays like Rook B8 isn't that just
a good tactic for white
say that again which one like if Bishop
takes F7 Rook takes system Knight G5 and
that King looks like it's in big danger
I think that's worth showing let's make
a random move for black rooked Bishop
takes F7 great eye by you now not Knight
takes C5 why because after Knight takes
C5 black defends the rook and F7 very
common mistake among newer players but
you have to go to G5 attacking from
three different sources black has to
take white takes on F7 black does have
two pieces for a rook Robert but after
something like D4 White's got a big
enduring initiative against Black's King
the Knight can come out and this just
doesn't look all that appetizing too
he's played one of those random moves he
played a move on the same side of the
board
he went
B6 in the game
does that change anything or can I'll
raise it pick off the F7 Pawn
well I would imagine that he would at
least devote some time to it but I think
he just trusted Wesley Bishop F7 was
interesting but probably unclear
ultimately
yeah that's one of those words right
it's complicated it's unclear it's
unclear yeah dynamic balance but it's
true that we saw the eval bar didn't
react so strongly to that sacrifice
saying that there was a force draw for
white we know that but maybe there was
nothing more at least not at first so
Knight A3 I can hop to B5 Black's
position is unpleasant so I do think
this was a good choice ultimately Reza
yeah he's keeping the status quo he's
not doing what Wesley did at the end of
the last game he senses that Wesley
might be reeling after that blunder and
there's no reason to give Wesley a bunch
of forced moves especially when you have
a hard time evaluating the ensuing
position here you know that you're
better you know that you have an
initiative and Knight d8 by Wesley so is
a nice defensive move I think he wants
to meet Knight B5 with either Queen C6
or even maybe Knight E6 I don't know if
he can get away with that but it appears
that he can because Bishop takes E6
Bishop takes E6 hits whites Queen and
white doesn't have time to take on C7 no
he does want Queen D7 I stand corrected
Wesley defending like this it's actually
very instructive because it looks bad
for black look at this last bunch of
moves he brought his Queen from d8 to EA
his Knight back to d8 is Queen up to D7
it looks very cramped and if the engine
says so what what does white have going
for him he needs a doubles Rooks he does
that but here comes C6 and then D5 and
that Bishop C4 that could get trapped
yeah The Dominoes start falling and
White's pressure on F7 is now a thing of
the past verus just not in time the
double Rooks on the up file he was one
tempo short because if his Rook was
already on F1 then in that position he
actually would have been able to take on
F7 at this level it always comes down to
one tempo Wesley occupies the center
chases the bishop uh to a much less
desirable Square it is technically an
outpost Robert but it's not really doing
anything on B5 and now the Knight on A3
doesn't have any prospects either
you really would like to replace that
Bishop with a knight and put that Bishop
on a square like C2 so you can play D4
and strike in the center but now for
Wesley I would slide the queen up to D6
and I'm worried about his clock I'm
going to be honest with you I I think
that black has a pretty solid position
at the moment but it's some turn in the
near future fridge is going to strike
with a D4 or an E4 or even a C4 and
Wesley will have to calculate that
the side that controls the pawn breaks
controls the position except here black
of course has this big big Center you
called it D4 is on the board now the
instinctual reaction is to play E4 and
the additional benefit of this move is
that G5 now traps White's Knight but for
Russia could continue with C4 French
style and then after G5 he could stick a
knight on F5 and sacrifice in exchange
this exchange sacrifice unlike the one
in the last game actually has a chance
of working looks fully Justified because
there are those weaknesses the F5 square
and the F6 Square in front of it look
like they're white Rooks for the taking
C4 seems to be a great move look at the
clock I'll raise this up about a minute
and if not for C4 I guess you could play
like G3 but that seems very weakening in
front of your own King
yeah you've got an opportunity right now
to pounce while Wesley's pieces are
still relatively discombobulated you do
not want to go G3 and weaken more light
squares that gives black exactly what he
wants and it's a much easier position
for black to play especially if you can
push G5 and F5 to solidify his Center
so is G5 a huge threat because white can
play Knight F5 right now let's say black
had a free turn g595 that D5 Pawn is
quite tender so I'm not sure how huge of
a thread G5 is and all there is it goes
for C4
and the Big Moment of Truth will we see
G5 you know there is the classic idea
that having said a you have to say B but
I think given the clock situation and
given Wesley's stylistic Tendencies he
is not going to play G5 that position
looks you know very remote from the kind
of position Wesley wants to have with
one minute and indeed he puts his Rook
on C8 applying pressure on C4 trying to
get farrugia to be the one to release
the tension on D5 and give blacks Knight
really really nice prospects in the
center makes perfect sense black Now
controls the open C file the queen for
white should probably slide back to D1 I
don't actually see another Square for it
so oh it's Quincy too but I wouldn't
want to put my queen in the Rooks pack
so he does effect Slide the queen back
to D1 and now done it that Queen kills
the G4 and there are still Knight out of
five ideas things of that nature but if
I'm Wesley right now I'm probably
getting my knight out of d8 I don't like
it sitting back there Knight B7 Knight
D6 as you're pointing out it covers F7
and F5 cover step 7 F5 it reinforces the
E4 Pawn which is a slight weakness and I
really like the fact that Wesley
actually took with the bishop on D5 that
gave him a Tempo which he is now using
in exactly the way he should be using it
now if Ali Reza wants to play Knight F5
then he should do it now because once
the Knight gets to D6 that Knight is
going to be stranded on H4 I think
Knight F5 is one possibility Bishop A6
is another Robert to trade off that
Knight and guarantee the long-term
possibility of Knight F5 instead he
works on solidifying and improving his
other Knight but I don't know about that
and wessie seems to know about is give
me your bishop and the C4 Square that's
going to be useful for that Bishop
because after Bishop C4 the white Brook
is kicked out of F1 I really like
Wesley's position all of a sudden
I like his position too he's got a
monopoly over the dark squares without a
bishop to supervise the activity of
White's other pieces I feel like Ali
Reza's attack on the king side has
suddenly become
toothless you can't even really call it
an attack you can't even call it an
initiative he's got no actual targets
and no actual threats despite the
impressive you know positioning of his
Rooks and his Knight
yeah the real issue is that he can't get
everything at the same time he wants to
leave his Knight on C3 but he also want
to trade the knight in H4 for the Knight
on E7 so if he can get Knight F5 in
which he not he's not he would have been
okay now he's much worse and our old
friend Robert Mr G5 that old friend
actually my minute make an appearance
now now G5 is a very serious threat and
alireza might have to play this very
ugly looking move G3 instead he tries to
Fight Fire with Fire Queen H5 and a calm
response from Wesley soak do you want to
go Knight G6 now if you're Ali resin get
rid of this God forsaken Knight on H4
you do want to make that move I think
black goes up a pawn though you swap
Knights the blackworks slides up to F6
to kick the queen out of the sights of
the B6 pawn and then B5 is loose at the
end there I just think that this is a
Wesley so game where he can play for two
results
great call I think Bishop takes B5 is
possible in the long run first he
improves the position of his King he
might also choose to reinforce the F5
Pawn with Rook C to f8 and his Bishop on
C4 is a jack of all trades it's an
attacking piece but it's also a
defensive piece preventing white Struck
from redoubling on the f file and Ali
Reza's King side activity is now firmly
a thing of the past
and now black is up upon the F5 Pawn is
defended he moves his Bishop back to C4
no Knight D5 jumps no chaos in the
position
dining this looks really really strong
for Wesley and I'm trying to figure out
for Fuji if this is gonna work he's
pushing his Pawn but now it's maybe
creating weakness out of it and Ali Reza
this is the way he plays Bishop C4 to
prevent Knight D5 and the moment that
this that square is occupied by a pawn
as Ali Reza Falls to a second and tries
to generate King side play he sticks the
bishop on The Outpost and now the D5
Pawn is a very serious weakness that
could be targeted by a later B5 B4 but
right now no he does play B5
is crumbling the F5 Pawn is defended now
the Knight comes off the board and I
think for her Wesley a second extra Pawn
that should probably do the trick but
we're getting into a double Rook end
game and you can't take on G4 because
the G7 phone was pinned what do you
think Donna is Wesley gonna convert this
yeah well there's another pawn and
there's another one of B2 and too many
extra pawns two too little time and yet
another surgical surgical Italian game
by Wesley coming back from that
disappointing first loss of the match
Wesley loses a game and then immediately
plays what is a clinical showing of
technique right the guy just is hard to
face he was shaking his head at some
point he couldn't believe his exchange
sacrifice but now looking at me
stretching
it's not like Wesley doesn't show
emotion you know you can tell when he's
disappointed first of all alireza is
gone
hopefully not gone from the match I
don't think the plant has the capacity
to play The King's Indian defense but
with full due respect to that plan it is
a nice plant but I don't know if it's uh
done it's you know David bronstein
King's Indian reading in uh recent
months but just to complete the thought
Robert
um and this is getting a little bit
concerning Wesley does show emotion you
can tell when he's disappointed but he
doesn't let it impact his play if
anything he's like a reverse tilter he
loses a game and he's like I'm actually
going to play better in the next game to
rebound as quickly as possible alireza
what's up hello
the plant does look nice and fresh it
looks like it was watered recently and
hey oh my gosh maybe he went to the
bathroom a quick bathroom break and if
you're gonna go to the bathroom I think
the start of the game is the right time
and in another position even though it's
move two with an extra minute for Wesley
and is Wesley doing this
yeah I think he might be no
[Laughter]
yeah Wesley Wesley's not a gentleman
yeah he's what a jerk you know that's
the first person you think of when you
think of you know a really nasty person
is Wesley so yeah obviously we're joking
but Wesley you know he has a hit long
history of you know someone their
internet goes out for a little bit he'll
give the time back he's such a polite
person but he has not been polite in
this match five and a half one and a
half he's up by four points Donna as we
reach 12 minutes 50 seconds remaining in
this time Patrol
have to cut this to three or do you
think even if he's down by four he'll
still have a legit shot at winning the
match well I think because of farugia's
bullet Acumen he will have a legit shot
if he keeps this within you know within
reasonable limits if he's down by six or
seven no you know the match is over if
he can keep this under five going into
the bullet he will have a chance by
definition but right now given the way
these five minute games are going
they're still 12 minutes in this segment
he's got to make sure not to lose the
next two games that's got to be the most
near-term goal for alireza perusa do not
let this get to a five point lead or
higher and look at the opening he's
playing from the black side he is
playing for a win but these are the
types of positions that you go too far
in like let's say you play B5 here as
let's move out of making bullet chess if
Knight takes B5 back did you just give
your opponent a pawn I don't actually
see the follow-up
yeah this line of the same ish I've
always struggled with tremendously from
the black side Andrew Tang is one of the
actually one of the world's leading
Specialists on this structure with the
white pieces he's got some brilliant
bullet games here uh where he just seems
to Castle and then play H3 and then play
F4 and kind of blow black off the board
so it's very important for black to
generate counter play on the other side
of the board benoni style uh trying to
squeeze in B5 sometimes even playing C4
and jettisoning upon in order to open up
the boulevards and avenues on the queen
side
and once it stops B5 for now but after
Bishop D7 we will see B5 in the near
future and it's important to flick in H3
only at the right time from black
because if white stops You by playing H3
himself that gives away the very
important G3 Square some dark Square
problems for white but if uh black
Russia's H3 then white pushes through
and there could be issues
absolutely and that is why Wesley is
taking his time trying to decide on the
Move order here does he play A5 does he
Castle does he play this small move H3
in order to prepare F3 F4 which is a lot
more appealing because it would actually
trap the knife on E5
that night needs some place and that B5
moves helps free up some squares for it
but the bishop is in its path the G4
Square under White's control so F4 is
going to be one that you always need to
keep an eye out on so Wesley's thinking
here Diner which approach do you think
he's gonna go for
I would start personally by castling the
problem with the move A5 is that it
doesn't truly prevent black from playing
B5 in fact black can play P5 anyway and
after the on Passat black takes on B6
with a queen and you could argue well
the A6 Pawn is isolated at the end of
the line that could not be further uh
from being consequential in this
position this is all about piece
activity it's about whether black can
harness the queen side in order to
generate pressure on the B2 Pawn then it
is about you know a particular weak pawn
and Wesley he does indeed keep the
status quo by castling will we see a
benko style Pawn sacrifice with B5 the
answer is yes
the answer is yes indeed the one bit of
great news for Wesley is that if we get
a swap on B5 then Knight will take back
on B5 and even if B2 is eventually lost
the C4 square if you can plant a knight
on C4 from the white side against the
benoni you're often feeling good
and I think that's precisely what uh the
deciding factor was Wesley actually
taking on B5 with the bishop which is a
curious way to capture it but it's a
sensible way to capture the pawn because
if black trades on B5 the D6 Pawn will
also be hanging and Robert even if it
wasn't you sometimes see the knight from
B5 dropping back to A3 precisely in
order to generate and Garner control of
this all-important C4 Square
and bicycle the bishop you get Queenie
two in some of these important lines so
if you're afraid of Bishop B5 Knight B5
Queen B8 which attacks the Knight and
protects B excuse me why I could play
Queen E2 and protect that Knight
but Queen A6 here I think is an
excellent move that hits the Knight and
defends the D6 spawn and also controls
the C4 Square so even if white does play
Knight A3 black can actually continue by
bringing the Rook to B8 and I think
there's no doubt in my mind that black
has enough compensation for the pawn but
for Russia has to tread very carefully
over the next couple of moves to make
sure that his pieces remain in the
center and aren't ultimately pushed away
by a combination of white playing F4 and
white planting a knight on C4 the next
few moves are going to be pivotal in
this game your credit six is a very good
idea is what's he smiling over there he
looks pretty happy
it looks he looks like he just found a
box of cookies in the street
maybe his cat came to play but Queen A6
hits that Knight on B5 I think the
Knight has to retreat and typically we
want our Knight in the center but here
the Night Belongs to the rim because it
will eventually go to the C4 Square
now here's the Tactical problem that
white is dealing with uh if white
defends the pawn which is very likely
you can't play you would love to play B3
that would be ideal but obviously you
drop the Knight after white plays
something like Queen C2 blackened move
the Knight away from F6 and it creates a
very instructive threat of Rook takes B2
and did we forget about this bishop on
G7 which which has been hiding amongst
the trees
he went for it Knight takes D5
oh my gosh and venra takes B2 scratch it
he's went right before give everyone
analysis board there because I think
that might have worked for alireza
Bang
bang and Rook takes B2 of course the
main idea I think it does work white has
to take on B2 otherwise you lose the
Knight on A3 and now bang discovering
the attack on the queen and even though
White's got a lot of pieces for the
queen Robert you've got this protected
passer on C5 and you've got a very very
active peace tandem only black can be
better in a position like this that was
a viable alternative
so it would be a queen of two pawns for
rook and two minor pieces I understand
why all the races didn't go for it
because if we get back to the live board
this still looks great for black it's
worth the pawn sacrifice it's like a
Banco Gambit and the B2 Pawn is targeted
where is White doing the pieces are not
very active here I actually think this
is a better try because it's less
forcing
it's less four seconds so it's gonna
milk more time off Wesley's clock and he
doesn't have a lot of time to begin with
he's now under a minute and something
I've been pointing out for most of the
game Robert the move F4 white never
found an opportunity to play H3 which
means F4 is yet again met with a
devastating Knight G4 and Wesley has to
resort to passive defense on the queen
side I feel like alireza is a couple of
accurate moves away from crashing
through there is Queen E2 here there is
a move like H3 and it's certainly not
easy to conduct the initiative from the
black side either I really like H3
though because the F3 point will be soft
and queen E2 will hit the bishop on E3
and the opponent of three simultaneously
so I think H3 is a very accurate move
here because typically white pushes
through you don't take on H3 you make a
move like G3 or G4 but Queen E2 will
threaten Checkmate on G2 not to mention
the F3 Pawn is loose great insight and
the immediate Queen E2 would have run
into this beautiful defensive resource
Knight to F1 when that Knight defends
the bishop the other night defends the
Queen and Black's Queen would have been
driven out of E2 now after G3 Queen E2
the F3 Pawn would have been hanging in
that line and so Wesley has to allow
farooja either to take on G2 or to dive
into D3 with this queen or both
so Queen D3 they're still at Knight F1
move that you mentioned so white is
hanging on but then there could be a
rook takes B2 idea so you have to be
very very careful here oh this is
actually a critical moment because
Knight F1 Brook takes B2 would turn this
in Black's favorite
great eye knight C2 the only move that
doesn't lose on the spot hitting the
rook and protecting the bishop still
work to do for farrugia both sides now
down to 30 seconds
what would you do here for black go back
to B8 or something like that yeah I
would probably go Rook B8 apparently you
don't have to move the Rook at all
because if white takes it black can take
this all-important bishop on E3 and
these massive dark Square weaknesses on
the king side will cost white the game
but how do you accumulate the initiative
that's a hard question to answer and
farouza decides to keep the status quo
with Rook B8 and B3 from Wesley he's
keeping his extra Pawn but Knight to H5
to be very careful is the queen Force
now yes but then black can take on B3
and it feels like White's minor pieces
on the queen side are in big trouble
Rook takes B3 Knight takes D6 can white
get away with that probably not
but why not the engine hates it is it
Rook C3
because two
uh-huh oh it's nice
you gotta play F4 and counter attack the
Knight on E5 and white stays in the game
that's such a hard time to play
gotta find it
and he does yes he does oh
what's going on now so how many pieces
are just got traded off
a lot and I think the worst is behind
him I think Wesley's suddenly playing
for well now it's a drop but incredible
how did he survive that
it's incredibly difficult to beat Wesley
so is what we say and he proves true
every single game
I would have almost taken the bishop and
tried for Bishop E5 obviously this is a
dead draw but whoa he's lost the pawn
though Wesley with a sloppy move
now wait a second oh the table base says
it should be a draw that makes sense but
it doesn't feel that easy for what
anymore no what blacks couldn't play C3
and drop the bishop back obviously
but yeah I guess it's a force wait wait
wait wait this does not look easy with
the F Pawn going up
and he's got one second on the clock I
think Wesley's gonna lose this how do
you draw this
King D1 only move and Kingston OH you
and it looks like he's got a fortress
that is unbelievable he gets Bishop E1
just in time takes on C3 and white
Queens first but this is a draw oh my
God and it's black who barely draws the
game white almost won the queen there
Black's King was close enough to his
Queen to ensure a trade of Queens what a
game
everything down the stretch there was
perfectly timed that F4 move from Wesley
saved him and then he trade off pieces
even when he went down a pawn again he
found the right squarespers pieces he
maintains his four-point lead but for
ruja he's much more combative now than
he was at the start I was gonna say we
might see the first King's Indian of
Wesley's career from the black side but
no he stays true to his repertoire plays
a grunfeld that is one of his favorite
openings for most of his chess career
and I think this is called the uh
Russian system one of the sharpest
responses to the grinfelder white plays
Queen D1 to B3 and essentially compels
black to give away the center with d
takes C4
and Mom and jarv I feel like he hits so
many games in this line and if look at
this position white has gained a lot of
space with pawns but black is going to
strike back by the time they B5 and the
C5 and with White's King still in the
center these positions can collapse very
quickly
yeah I mean you you cannot play moves
like Knight G5 if you haven't very
carefully analyzed this position with an
engine people have analyzed it with a
lot of different engines for many many
years and this line still is in an
active state of evolution that just
tells you how complicated the grunfeld
is
Knight G5 earned a question mark he's
going after the F7 Pawn he wants E6 to
follow that looks worrisome but the
Knight goes to B6 Dania black continues
to develop pieces and open up lines for
the others and there is a sitting on the
position and not allowing C7 to C5
it's possible that the idea of Knight G5
was to induce Knight B6 and you might
ask well why would you induce a move
that black might seem to want to play
anyway and like you said black now can't
play B7 B5 and black can't play C7 C5
either and if white can maintain the
Integrity of this little Pawn chain in
the center it does make it difficult for
black to attain maximum piece activity
so if I'm Wesley so I'm gonna try to
find a way to get this Queen off of C5
you can play the immediate Knight D7 but
then in the long run you're potentially
running into E6 ideas so perhaps you can
start by chasing the Knight away then
you could bring the light squared Bishop
out to E6 and clamp down on this
potential Outpost and finally you could
complete your minor piece development
with Knight D7 so my untrained eye it
seems completely fine for black it seems
fine for black but I think the
frustration really stems from the fact
that C5 isn't going to happen anytime
soon not with that Knight on B6 that's
not the placement you want you want the
B6 Knight back on D7 to the play C5 but
it has your drawing with that Arrow
there and Knight and E4 stops C5
permanently I would much rather be white
even though I see the evaluation bar
saying Wes is the favorable side
I agree that from a purely positional
standpoint if white can maintain the
clamp then there's no argument white is
strategically better black might have to
use tactics to solve the problems in his
position maybe in some situations you go
Knight D7 and then you play the move C5
anyway you sacrifice upon in order to
get rid of this Knight and in order to
open up the C file obviously any
self-respecting grunfeld player has to
be ready at a moment's notice to
sacrifice a pawn or even more for peace
activity
well he goes back to D7 the problem with
C5 is that when white takes back with
the pawn the 96 will be trapped
hilarious oh my God what a lion that's
actually why it would have been a good
idea to bring the bishop out first
ah so you could Retreat your night
F5
that caught me by surprise
and I think he is stubbornly trying to
prepare C5 so if white snipe moves back
let's say to D2 he relinquishes in large
part uh his grasp on the C5 square and
therefore
perhaps white should consider Knight C5
looks like a good try he goes back to D2
because C5 D takes C5 then Knight on B6
is still trapped so what is black doing
here that Bishop on C8 looks terrible if
you go rookie E8 that feels slow
he's going Knight B8 Bishop E6
great call oh my gosh
look at you
thumbs up for Wesley
oh that's sick
that is nice because he's just
controlling the dark squares I had one
game like this in classical chess where
you is it looks like a queen's game but
it you know the accepted but it started
from a gridfeld and you just control the
light squares in the center
in general I love moves where
essentially you undevelop your pieces
even if that is purely a Transit point
on route to a different Square I still
think these types of moves produce a
strong aesthetic effect and this is a
case in point the Knight is not going to
stay on B8 it's going to move up to C6
and apply pressure on D4 but it looks
like Wesley has achieved great Harmony
without even having to push C5 or B5 he
might actually push the same Pawn on the
other side and try to soften White's
control over the D4 square with G5 G4
much like in that Italian it looks like
white is down about 510p black has
Castle for three minor pieces whites
Queen went to B3 and C4 and C5 and 84
moves with that Queen and that Knight
that's now on F3 didn't that Knight go
to F3 to G5 to E4 to D2 back to F3 like
he's moving the same pieces over and
over again he wanted the Strategic plus
but it's so time consuming
God yeah he has made one two three four
five moves with the same piece and we're
not even at move 15. I get modern chess
and all
that's all well and good but when you
flaunt opening principles to this extent
development still makes its presence
felt and I think Wesley should take the
opportunity to push G5 restrict the
mobility of this Knight prevent it from
accessing F4 and he does just that
ferocious not getting out of the opening
and a lot of these games are the white
pieces
I like this position at first because he
stopped C5 but now I don't like it at
all because he's moved his Knights a
bunch of times and his Queen and his
poor Bishops look at the bishop on F1
it's not playing the
yeah exactly the bishop C1 hasn't done
anything and now if black just blocks
the check with Pawn to E6
what exactly is white aiming for
it beats me E6 threatens the totally
devastating G4 if you lose the D4 Pawn
you can basically resign because the E5
Pawn will fall alongside it so perhaps
these six should be met with Bishop E3
but Wesley just doing Wesley things that
is such a typical Wesley so move going
for the end game going for the blockade
on the D5 Square rather than throwing
the pawns at White's neck and going for
mate
such a strong move right there because
he's also taking control of the light
squares on the queen side that if you
trade Queens on D5 a knight B4 will hit
you and C2 and D3 are blacks Knights for
the taking the bishop comes out to E6
The Rook comes out to d8 of course black
is a G4 or F4 and take more control over
key squares Daniel this looks miserable
for white and Olive he's nearing a
minute on the clock
I don't see a move here I think you have
to trade Queens on D5
and then what I mean again G4 F4 and the
worst is when your opponent is both
positionally better but also tactically
winning and I think that's what we have
here Black's got this Monumental
blockade on D5 but for a piece activity
standpoint black is also much much
better on that front alireza declines
the queen trade but this reeks of
desperation
the queen has moved how many times now
B3 C4 C5 A3 B3 six times back to its
initial Square five times with an iron
F3 twice with the Knight on E2 all of
these pieces are moving over and over
again and look at Black's forces there's
aimed at the White Center Knight takes
D4 is a threat Knight takes resignable
G4 is the thread you I think you're
correct that you could probably resign
here and just get it to three minute
awful I mean Ali Reza literally has made
three moves the whole game and we're on
move 18 19.
this is not what you're looking for if
you're trying to come back in this match
but Wesley so he did lose one game we
said he rarely loses that's true but he
refuses to lose outside of what he
sacrifices in exchange for no reason
yeah that's the sad thing for Ali Reza
even the game that he won you know he
won it thanks to a blunder the games
that Wesley has been winning he's
demonstrated Superior understanding of
the opening as we see the frustration
spilling over for alireza Fusia he knows
this position is hopeless you called it
Robert I think we're gonna see G4 and
then we're gonna see a relatively simple
tactic with Knight takes D4 and maybe I
spoke too soon maybe we will see the
move C7 C5 but it will be played for
entirely different reasons yet again
Wesley's so good at taking his time but
he has demonstrated superiority
essentially all areas of Chess as we see
alireza the final attempt to stir things
up with a sacrifice it's not going to
work Bishop takes C5 will end it I loved
the idea from Reza but after Bishop
takes E5 you stop White's only threat of
Knight to F4 the D4 Pawn is pinned he
might just resign after this move the
good news for him is that he's about to
get he resigns after that move and
Wesley so takes a five point lead a
commanding start to this match for
Wesley he leads by the score of seven to
two and I was gonna say the one bit of
good news for alireza is that this time
control is over
I think Wesley made exactly one mistake
and the crazy thing is this is a bit of
an exaggeration but not much Wesley made
exactly one mistake in this entire match
thus far and that was the move Rook
takes F6 every other game it seems has
been played at such an incredibly high
level this is some of the best 90
minutes of SCC chess that we've seen and
that is definitely not an exaggeration
we're used to seeing alireza dominate
his opposition what has happened here
and what does Ali resin need to do to
change the momentum of this match well
to some degree Robert if Wesley
continues to show this level then you're
kind of screwed and you have to come to
terms with reality obviously the time
management has to improve alirez's
performance in critical positions has to
improve I just think he needs to start
playing more fundamentally sound chess
trying to seek the kinds of positions in
which he feels comfortable the kinds of
positions that he's gotten out of the
king's Indian if he can get those same
types of positions with the white pieces
I think he'll give himself a Fighting
Chance
I'm with you I think he also will play
more quickly in the shorter time
controls he has to you don't have a
choice you just don't start with as much
time and so he is a bullet Phenom we're
used to him playing quickly and well we
ought to give a shout out to our sponsor
coinbase here the presenting partner did
you wish that your financial systems
were as fast and smart as the 2023 speed
test Champion presented by coinbase they
can be check out coinbase.com update the
system today or use the command coinbase
and chat to learn more those systems
they need to be as fast as alireza
farusia in bullet chest we'll see if he
can speed up this is the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase like
the players we'll take a break and win
return it's a three plus one time Patrol
the magic Team all the reason
[Music]
thank you
this course is about white playing D4
all the tools you need to get an
advantage with Wyatt and not be tricked
early in the opening
now it has a really long complicated
name that I'm going to mispronounce now
so you can make fun of me okay don't
make fun of me too much I'm trying to
help you here it's called the cello
binsk variation and I'm probably
mispronouncing cello bins that's why I
call it the A6 sloth
foreign
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.chess.com iMessage or
use the command iMessage in chat to
learn more
Grand Masters can then lose 10 pounds
and burn 6 000 calories just by sitting
yeah so I've actually been spending a
lot of time getting in shape wow that's
great what are you doing mostly like
Rook lifts oh I've never heard of that
it's a thing don't look it up
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
the premier online speed chess
tournament a knockout filled with
tension drama quick tactics and shocking
moments
oh my gosh for the last seven years and
counting the best Blitz and bullet
players in the world have flocked to
chess.com to prove their worth at this
format
excitement rains every year with major
upsets and intense battles
this year 12 invitees and four
qualifiers face off for the title
dozens have tried but only two have ever
worn this Crown Magnus makes it look
easy he wins the speed test championship
who will be this year's Blitz King
it's time to find out
[Music]
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 speeches
Championship presented by coinbase
Oliver is afrogen needs no introduction
but he is eating a banana hopefully
getting that potassium and rebounding in
this match
want to hear a joke about potassium okay
I want to hear a joke about sodium nah
oh my goodness your science jokes were
not lost on me I appreciate that a good
chemistry lesson for those of you out
there and well other ways of farouza
Chess and him that is chemistry they get
along very well he is the youngest
player to surpass 2800 classical ratings
he was just 18 years old at the time
he's won the Singapore cup he was the
third place finisher at the recent full
of Chess Championship it is his first
SEC appearance since 2020 and Donna he
does not want this appearance to come to
an end but right now Wesley so is
flexing those muscles yeah he most
certainly does not want it to come to an
end but unfortunately the kind of form
that pursued alireza farisha during his
match with Dimitri and draken
particularly in the five-minute segment
you know that's the kind of form he
showed against Wesley now I'm not
implying that he played terribly he
didn't play terribly there weren't a lot
of one move blunders but Ali Reza's play
lacked the kind of shine the kind of
luster that we're used to seeing from
him the kind of tactical Brilliance and
sharpness and time scrambles he was
taking too long in the first staff of
the portion in the second half of the
portion he's just been getting
completely outplayed that's all there is
to it
and Wesley was shooting through those
tactics he was not famous he in fact was
the one who threw away an advantage by
trying to go for a tactic of his own and
that's the problem when you play Wesley
so he does not take these huge risks
he's not just going to throw away games
very often so for alireza he needs to
take it by the mantle he needs to go for
it he's a grab the proverbial bull by
the horns indeed he does yeah Wesley
throw did not make an appearance today
he holds a five-point lead it is a big
mountain that Mr faruca has to climb and
it all starts with a good start in this
hour-long three plus one portion yet
another King's Indian this is music to
my ears you know that already
oh you love a good King's Indian and the
key word there is good that for Russia
he's played some I like a bad one too
yeah you do but Peruzzi he's played well
in some of the moments but he's gotten
himself the time trouble but remember
this when his Knight went to G4 Pawn to
F5 this did look very good for black
yeah they are reprising the gligarich
system from their first King's Indian
game that is where the white Bishop
comes out to E3 and white temporarily
delays kingside castle and often white
delays it for quite a bit of time you
often see why dropping the Knight back
to D2 trying to get this Knight out of
G4 in this game for Russia drops it back
on its own volition and I think he is
preparing the same exact plan that led
to a very successful position in their
first King's Indian affair
and Wesley he took quite a bit of time
to retreat his Knight and first is doing
no retreating right now he is thrusting
his pawns forward he wants to break open
the position and there's one essential
difference Daniel that Knight went back
from G4 to F6 in that previous game here
it's on H6 so if you take on F5 the
Knight can recapture back that gives
white the E4 square but that Knight may
head to D4 or take this bishop on G3 I I
think this is a slightly better version
of the type of position they had earlier
but in the context of a three minute
game I still like black and it's not
just because it's a king's Indian from
an unbiased perspective this D4 Square
the fact that black eventually has the
idea of pushing the h-pawn up the board
although I don't know under what
circumstances black will actually make
that happen whites trained his Bishop
Queen battery on that square so I'm
really curious to see how farugia
unravels his initiative here will it be
with Knight C5 yes it will and what will
be his subsequent steps
and getting rid of that night that was
on the rim is a good idea if the Knight
takes that would be a bad decision from
White yes you double the pawns Diner you
like to say that pawn structure is often
overrated by people but if the knight
ever takes on C5 and the B6 Pawn takes
back that's bad news for white oh
absolutely BC would establish a monster
outpost on D4 it would also open up the
B file for long-term pressure against
the B2 pawn and typically with white you
want to refrain from playing a move like
B3 because should the Knight disappear
from E4 Black's Bishop will have a much
brighter future with this Knight on C3
less supported so for Russia continues
to operate on the queen side continues
to grab space and prevents uh the idea
of b2b4
and h3h6 com moves but the movie H6 does
free up the black queen which was tied
down to the G5 Pawn we may see a queen
E8 Queen G6 but that doesn't get you
anywhere because if you play Queen eight
this bishop H5 at any moment although I
said that and now that is off the table
Queen D2 loses sight of that diagonal so
Dania for black queen eight to me that
one looks good Queen a queen G6 we're
familiar with that maneuver he carried
that maneuver out uh with with great
success the previous time that they had
this structure it's not the only move
you could consider putting the Knight on
D4 planting it on the Outpost farusha is
taking a a slower more methodical
approach completing his development I
still like bit Queen E8 he puts his
Bishop on E8 rather than his Queen where
is he bringing that Bishop is he
bringing it to G6 or is he preparing H5
um Knight D4 and H5 traps that Bishop oh
so I would be oh what oh how do you save
that Bishop
great call H5 is a huge threat it should
be pointed out it H5 doesn't win the
bishop because white could put it on E6
but it would win a big pawn and Wesley
taking drastic steps to open up a
retreating Square for his Bishop but it
comes at the cost of the Integrity of
his kingside Pawn structure
and that pawn is captured the good news
for Wes is Bishop can slide back to H3
if black plays H5 but I'm going to
abandon that plan I don't want to push
my pawns into Kingston anymore now that
I'm up one let's get that Bishop from E8
up to G6 maybe I can even slide a rook
to F4 in the future there might be
tactics on the E4 Square this is exactly
what ferrugia was looking for in the
first game of the three plus one portion
he's got a much better position he is up
a pawn and he's got so many easy ways to
continue improving King H7 you called it
Robert Queen E7 coordinate the Rooks
maybe double on the f file
I love this for alireza there are no
points of entry for White's pieces those
Knights and D4 and C5 control all of the
key squares and at some moment I'm not
sure when there could be a capture in E4
but what uh already says what are you
talking about I'm going to go back to F5
hit this bishop on E3 maybe Knight G3 is
in the air as well so Wesley is forced
to retreat absolutely he has to retreat
to F2 and he has to maintain control
over this E4 Square both sides now under
a minute and of course it's not enough
to accumulate all of your pieces on the
king side you actually have to find some
way to break through and this is
partially where alireza has struggled he
sunk a lot of time into actually finding
the crushing blow what do you make of
this move I don't give the question mark
I like it he wants Bishop H6 he's trying
to free up a diagonal for that bad
King's Indian Bishop bad Bishops defend
good pawns I know a certain commentator
who likes to remind fans of that yeah
and then the Knight comes in with a
single check but Donna that's just one
and wait a second Queen G5 Queen Bishop
H6 is that oh my God that I would have
re-trapped the queen what a crazy idea
that would have been
what's The Happening Here is H4 loose or
that walking into other pins well it
walks into Bishop F6 and you'll have a
hard time extricating the knight from G5
but perhaps you could support it with F4
using your own pin against black screen
still feels like black is better
borussia's got the initiative here but
he has to tread very carefully rookie to
Knight F4 for example would allow Queen
takes up for so you've got to watch out
it doesn't quite lose a piece but that
would not be good for black so he's
deciding where to move this Rook he does
go up to E3 but now that I can save him
that's F4 and it could go further back
to G6 and dislodge this bishop trouble
brewing for Wesley F4 anyway
Westie says what trouble I have no fear
but alireza he swaps on H4 and whose
King is worse to my eyes done yet it
looks like the white king but at night
on G5 is so strong it's so strong it can
jump to E6 at some point and farooza
trying to plug the G file by sticking
his Bishop punch you for that was a
great move and the other Bishop is going
to come out to E5 with great effect
by losing material yeah it's really
going to hurt because even Queen G5
check that looks like a single check the
King goes up to H7 and then Rook to G oh
why do you go in the corner
apparently Whitehead Knight F4 and
Knight G6 and that would have given him
a new lease on life
oh Queen H7 what a move that is the
queen comes in and it looks like farouza
he's he's gonna be able to scoop up a
victory here it looks like it's checked
me by force
King H1 Bishop F3 is made in three
nasty but he goes oh Queen you won
because he couldn't block the bishop 3
was still gonna be a mate
and you could even take the Knight on F6
but he checkmates on E2
okay so Oliver is a farugia a better
start here in the three plus one now
it's a four point deficit Danny you said
this as long as Alvarez is within four
to five points he sells legit shot in
bullet because we saw his Peak rating
was over 3 500.
and for Wesley that looked like a
shakier game than we're a customer is
seeing from him
and the significance of that game for
alireza yes it's important to make up a
point but this is the best game that
he's played all match this was his only
wire it was his second victory of the
match it was his only wire to wire
Victory thus far so I think that game
served to convince him that yes I
actually can beat Wesley so I can
outplay him and what on Earth do we have
here this is actually a known line
it is a known line but I don't know who
actually wins more often because the
position is wild black is up a full Rook
an entire Rook the Knight on H1 is good
is gone but you have to get to it so
here I think the line goes King H7 and
after Queen E4 check don't they just
make some kind of repetition there
I think they do and I think it's Wesley
who
makes the spicy move D6 is he aiming no
Queen E4 check you could not go Bishop
F5 because of Knight H4 but I guess he
drops back not to H7 but to F7 in that
situation Knight D5 man I would be
terrified of playing this with black
terrified
and I'd be terrified for both colors
because I say yeah that King on G6 again
getting mated but if I don't Checkmate
it I'm down a rook and at best I'm down
in exchange and against Wesley so we've
seen how accurate he is when it's mop up
duty but Wesley shook his head what is
he thinking about
I just wanted to shout out a funny
comment in the chat someone said that
this looks like a reverse Traxler and I
think that's a pretty apt
characterization because it's not
usually it's black going Bishop C5 and
sacking on h8 here it's white playing
Bishop C4 and sacking on H1
what is White's next move
he needs to come out with Knight F4
check King A7 Queen E4 check King G8 we
might see a drop like that with Queen
going back and forth and D5 and E4 that
seems to be a reasonable outcome here I
believe that if white doesn't Force the
draw he could be in big trouble
and especially given the clock situation
farusha
probably told himself that I have this
draw in my pocket Wesley cannot do
anything to decline it so he might be
investing essentially the rest of his
time searching in vain I think for some
way to stir up complications there is
this crazy move E6 to shut down the
bishop and set up the mate threat Queen
E4 but I just don't see himself playing
that for I don't see through oh he did
just as I said it he played E6 wow and
you want to hit take on E6 because
Knight F4 check will win that Bishop on
the Square and then Black Knight on H1
is still trapped so King H7 seems to be
the only possible move here and then
after Queen E4 check King goes to G8 the
problem is that Rook is stuck in the
corner and there's a very famous game
Daniel what's the game with the uh King
on G8 Rook on AJ come on you can do it
the famous game with the King on G8 Rook
on h8 is it Stein as one of our one Bart
11 nope it's a much more modern game oh
is it more Savage Maura Savage MBL from
Beale there it is Rook H7 so that was
the dynamic there what just happened so
alireza jumped to C7 won the rook in the
corner material is completely even but
isn't Black's Knight stuck
and whitesnite is not stuck that's the
second part of the equation wait I
thought he should have evacuated his
Knight with Knight C7 see now he's moved
his Bishop out to E3 in order to keep
this Knight at Bay Robert but black and
go Bishop D7 Knight C7 and Rook C8
actually traps White's Knight on C7
which is a pretty uncommon type of
pattern normally when the Knight reaches
C7 it evacuates to B5 or D5 but here
both of those squares are covered and I
think black is okay
and even if black were to lose a pawn in
a position like this you can say it's
going to be opposite color Bishop still
good chances to hold but I'm not even
sure if white is able to steal a pawn in
this position because you have to go
after the Knight on H1
it's crazy the white actually white can
play Bishop take and he did he does and
that is the best move because the
knight's technically not going anywhere
black obviously cannot trap the bishop
because B6 is unprotected
wow okay so I was gonna say that even if
white grabbed a pawn it still gives good
chances but that's not really the pawn I
wanted to give up because Black's
remaining pawns on B7 and D6 they're
vulnerable they're isolated I like this
opening drive from alirez and I like the
fact that he didn't make the force draw
that I thought he might go for he's
feeling opportunistic I think he's
feeling so much more confident after a
win like that under his belt as Wesley
tries to generate counter play on the
other side of the board B7 B5 opening up
an attack on the bishop Bishop can park
itself on D4 which I think is the best
Square on the diagonal you could throw
in Bishop B6 maybe uh to induce Rook C6
but I don't know what the significance
of that would be
I think Bishop D4 looks great I think
black will play Bishop F5 and after Pawn
to C3 he'll go for a B4 push and
something like that but Bishop to B6
first The Rook should probably slide up
as it does but done it isn't this a plan
for for black Bishop F5
okay you have to go C3 and then B4 and
I'm throwing Rook A6
oh and that's exactly what we're seeing
Rook A6 threatens A2 and white king
could actually be subject to a lightning
attack by Black's excellently
coordinated pieces Wesley puts the
Knight on D5
will we see this mover k6 at some point
such as now
but look what all the reason was he
wants to keep his past a pawn even if
black is able to gobble up the sea Pawn
somehow the outside pass Pawn can be
very dangerous and I don't even say a
way to win these pawns on the queen side
because the white king can Venture
towards B2 the Knight could come up to
D4 this looks like a very difficult hold
for black totally the eval bar is so
misleading the computer saves these
positions pretty regularly and pretty
easily but for a human imagine dealing
with this outside passer on a force
supported by a rook behind the pawn and
your point Robert is very well taken
alireza actually sacrifices a king Side
Pawn why did he do that in order to drop
the Knight back to B3 and set this Pawn
in motion but I love the way that Wesley
is defending that Bishop controls the
promotion square and in some situations
he might even give his Bishop away for
the pawn but get rid of White's other
pawns with a drop and look at that move
by Fusion he allows it discovered check
but all of White's important pieces are
in dark squares there's no valuable
check to be had and look at West he's
pushing the H Pawn it's slower than the
a pawn but it's running up the board
and the bishop a much better piece at
dealing with past Pawns in the night
this is suddenly a three result game you
can conceive of a scenario where white
yeah he goes Knight C7 and A8 Queen but
remember black is gonna have connected
passers this time they're actually
connected passers on the other side of
the board a move like Rook H1 could pave
the way for a sudden turnaround victory
for Wesley
Rook H1 would have been so sick instead
he pushes his Jeep on and right C7 that
Bishop is going to have to sacrifice for
the pawn but I think if your white just
go after the bishop don't uh six and how
is this not it's winning right
oh I don't know Rook A6 there apparently
was winning in Knight D5
oh that's a good find you cut that
Bishop off
and he's found it Bishop back
is this the third time if you're playing
Rook B6 so he couldn't afford to play
Rook B6 it would have been a draw but
still winning for white it's winning he
wins the bishop and Wesley last chance
that H Pawn still scary Rook B8 is down
to two seconds but you're not in time
you get a queen the G pawns are not
quick enough and farrusia takes one of
them he's gonna take the other and he is
going to win a second consecutive game
what a finale
Ali Reza faruja gives up a rook still
ends up a pawn ahead gives that pawn
back but converts in the end game in
Wesley so's style a great comeback in
the making right now from Fusion and
what a game from all sides he had a draw
in his pocket most people would have
taken that Perpetual without even
thinking Borussia took a minute he found
that E6 idea to keep the game going and
it wasn't the most precise end game play
How could you play precisely in a
position that sharp with only a couple
of seconds but it was enough to pose
Unstoppable practical problems
to Wesley and it's only a three-point
match
and Wesley who had seemed unbeatable has
suffered two straight defeats at the
hands of alireza faruza now we have a
closed position in the center and black
would like to open up the king side look
at that move King h8 you can expect
Knight G8 Pawn F5 but black excuse me
white will go for the B4 Pawn push of
his own man that game was bananas
literally because we saw the reservous
eating a banana and I guess the energy
that he got from that serves him well G4
by Wesley this is a much more typical
idea Robert than somebody who isn't
familiar with Kings Indian positions
might make it out to be you're trying to
discourage black from playing F5 which
now carries the positional risk of
weakening the E4 Square something we've
talked about quite a bit
this F5 move is dangerous both Kings
will come under the crossfire of the
enemy pieces that E4 Square though it is
whites for the taking or not says Fusion
okay so he's going to recapture with his
bishop and again I like Black's position
White's main asset here is that g file
right that's the file that white is
going to try to use to make black regret
playing F5 but black input either of two
pieces on on G6 either he can go 97
Knight G6 or he can drop the bishop back
to G6 and that is a very well protected
Bishop I think alireza has more than
solves all of his opening problems here
obvious has been doing well on the black
side of these King's Indians it's his
style he likes active play he doesn't
want to sit and passively defend and
look at that King on H1 it's not as
happy as you would like it whereas the
King on h8 has so many pieces around it
and yet Rusty goes into this plays F3
trying to secure the E4 Square Donya I'm
not even saying this just because you're
a Kings Indian fan I also am liking this
for black
and black could stir the pot by playing
E4 that's a move which has to be very
carefully considered because you're also
giving away a couple of important
squares with that move in particular
you're allowing the Knight to sink its
teeth potentially uh into E6 and I think
that that's what olures is calculating
yep and he plays it I love it
opening up the entire Center and the
King on H1 we're going to talk about how
lonely it is if you open up the diagonal
there that Bishop on F5 is going to
thrive
the bishop on F5 is going to thrive and
White's Pieces Just Don't Jive
that Knight on F4 is going to get traded
off and 96 Garners the bishop pair I
think it's a viable option it might be
why it's best option but clearly after
Bishop takes E6 and queen takes C6 white
doesn't have enough compensation
no that just looked good night instead
takes on G6 over here and look at
farrugia he's doing that super gym thing
they don't immediately capture with a
piece he decides eventually to take with
a bishop rather than the pawn but done
it where to next for either side because
white he's a fair way to put the Rooks
blacks Rook on A8 likely going to E8 and
that Bishop on G7 it's so strong it
controls this long diagonal and that is
why white trades it off and I think Rook
88 is at least to me almost a pre-move
you can just throw that move in and then
you can start deciding exactly how
you're going to try to convert uh your
Superior piece activity into something
tangible now you don't necessarily have
to play tactically uh if you're alireza
ferrugia if the queen moves away from D7
one positional idea involves bringing
the Knight around to this beautiful E5
square and exerting pressure on C4 that
is why I think Wesley is keeping the
tension in order to not allow the queen
to shuttle over to the king side let's
see how olly Reza spins out his
subsequent initiative maybe a move like
rookie five not easy at all that's for
sure
these things are tricky because the
Kings can get unsafe in a moment's
notice but I like Black's coordination
you see the Rooks and Ian f8 they're
defending one another there's one white
working A1 one white Rook on G3 they
seem to be just not coordinated the way
you would like and that Bishop on G7
even once it comes off as it just has
yeah we should go to the end game
what happened there there was a huge
missed opportunity both sides missed
that in the end game white could have
played Knight B5 and then maneuvered the
Knight around to E6 the square that
we've been talking about but via C7
because black would have had to burn a
Tempo uh consigning The Rook to
passivity after Rook to d8 big big Miss
I still think that the position is
trending maybe in Wesley's favor
although it's hard to say in the event
of the queen trade robber black snipe
might access this monster Square on D4
and is there anywhere to go the queen is
stuck on H4 you can't escape with it
Queen G4 does not look appealing oh so
it said we do see the trade oh Rook G6
is hanging oh you gotta go King G7 black
is lucky to have that move I don't know
if alireza saw that or not but he
doubles back at exactly the right moment
Bishop to E4 continuing to pressure the
bishop we've got a really sharp end game
on our hands
and it's a rook F4 what is inside Bishop
takes G6 and after H5 Rook G3 go after
that weakness on G6 so Black's Knight
eventually we'll try to go out to F5 and
oh there is a plays Rook at four but
this end game it looks like both sides
have their chances don't fall asleep on
this Knight B5 Knight c796 idea I think
neither player is really looking toward
the queen side and now Knight B5 loses a
lot of its luster he plays it anyway
though and I think alireza has to try to
cover the C7 square instead he
counter-attacks The Rook Wesley shuttles
it over to the other side of the board
and he is really really trying to get
this Knight around to E6
gone
wait a second that Knight on A7 is out
of play here Comes Rook E2 and Rook F2
and then Rook can't go back to G3
because the Knight E2 great inside the
E2 Square will be used by either The
Rook or the Knight I think Wesley's just
losing here he's got insufficient
material to defend his King he's gonna
get checkmated
and he goes Rook up so here comes a rook
down to the second rank I'm not even
sure which one should go he gives it the
p7 I would check but that's not a big
deal Knight F3 Rook F2 this is
completely over I mean look at Wesley's
pieces how does he expect to defend the
king against Black's entire Army when
there is a million made threats staring
him down the face
nothing you can do here comes a rook up
to the F2 square at night first I guess
to F3
lean exchange up and a checkmating net
anyway on the first rank or you could
just start collecting all the queen side
pawns this is resignable and he does
resign and I can't believe we're saying
this but Wesley has lost three games in
a row to start the three-minute portion
what a Twist in this match Robert
and Wesley the unfazible Wesley so it
seems like he is reeling right now
because Ali is afraid three straight
victories down there I think that Wesley
the one thing he could be happy about if
this is a long game it will send them
into that halftime break
absolutely he needs a break he needs to
reset and he needs to figure out exactly
what's going wrong here in comparison to
the five plus one portion well I'll tell
you what farusha is doing better his
time management has been excellent he
has trusted his intuition and his
performance in critical moments
particularly tactical moments has been
far superior to what he was showing in
the five plus one portion particularly
that last game Robert it wasn't perfect
but he didn't make any big mistakes
throughout the entire middle game and
ultimately it was Wesley who cracked
first at in the end game by gobbling up
that pawn on A7 and allowing The Mating
attack
and Wesley goes to the Carroll Khan in
this game you see that white has stolen
upon a C5 but the C5 pawn and the E5
Pawn can quickly be targeted by Black's
pieces that said Donna I tend to like
openings where you steal Pawns in Blitz
chest because then you force your
opponent to prove that they have
sufficient compensation compensation
often being a vague term that we as
commentators use who are unclear what's
going on a stealing pawns sign me up
Knight F5 would threaten to eliminate
the bishop and then recapture the pawn
but in this line you often see the
bishop parking itself on this beautiful
D4 square there's one tactical detail
Robert that is integral to an
understanding of this line I'd like to
show it really quickly if we could pull
up in an Osborne Knight F5 Bishop D4 a
newer player might say well wait a
second Knight takes D4 CD Knight takes
D4 and because the King has E7 the
classic technique where you sack your
queen and check on B5 that's not it that
doesn't work instead after Knight takes
D4 there is the sudden check on A4 bang
and even though the night covers the
queen takes the bishop on G4 this is
very easy to miss and it is the reason
why uh Ali Reza or Wesley so does not
jump into F5 and instead plays A6
and that moved Bishop D3 but now we
raise it afterwards that's what I'm
confused about he just allowed black to
take a Central Pawn
and version gives the check but Wesley's
in time to block with his Queen and this
looks better for Black Knight takes E5
was blundered by alireza the point of
Asics was to cover the B5 Square because
in that position Knight takes E5 would
have allowed that classic Queen
sacrifice and white would have recovered
the material with interest now it feels
like probably an equal ish end game
maybe white is still slightly better I
don't know
Hmm this position is one where white has
the para Bishops and some potential
queenside expansion but as you're
pointing out black can also strike on
that side of the board because C5 will
be a loose Pawn in some of those
positions it's such a hard position to
get a handle on because both sides have
so many different plans and pawn
advances black and play in the center
with E5 on the queen side with A5 on the
king side you know with something like
F5 so hard to get a handle on where the
pieces belong here and I'm curious how
alireza is going to defend the C3 Pawn
there's our answer King D2 but is he
walking into a potential E5
knee 5 with E4 threatened 14 the bishop
and the Knight also E5 there is D4
potential just trying to explode the
center as that King on D2 could be in
some danger so he said puts a knight on
E5 the engine didn't love it
and I don't love it either because how
is he going to recapture right Knight
takes C5 would have run into the very
nasty pinning move Bishop D4 and the
bishop on E5 seems a little bit
misplaced you want to pawn on that
square you don't necessarily want to
Bishop hogging Prime real estate in the
center now I feel like white is a little
bit better
yeah I mean Black's moves King E7 that
is a step one but where do you actually
put your Rooks what files are gonna open
up and he answers that immediately by
playing D4 and now that we have opposite
code Bishops I think all there is
Advantage is not so significant his only
chance I think to spark the Flames of
the initiative is somehow to go after
this B7 Pawn he's obviously threatening
Bishop E4 but Wesley was not born
yesterday I think he's gonna Castle
queenside killing two birds with one
stone protecting the pawn and connecting
The Rook with the bishop when black is
probably not worse at all
no I mean this bishop on D4 is a healthy
piece and black kids are throwing the
pots at the board E5 and F5 and then
white might have to deal with an
opposing Central expansion from black so
F3 played before you can expand I'm just
going to eliminate that possibility
Dania I feel like in a classical game
these two would agree to a draw in the
near future yeah they would kind of look
at each other and say let's go to dinner
in a Blitz game the way that this game
is likely to end in a draw is with a
mass liquidation down the D file Wesley
will likely drop his Bishop back at some
point he doesn't want to play E5 because
that would drop F7 and I don't think
alireza really has a choice other than
to acquiesce to the liquidation and a
draw is a completely fine result it's a
stable result I think alirez has got to
be thrilled with the way that these
first 30 minutes have gone
although a drugs also good for Wesley
because it means he's no longer losing
he lost three games in a row him as a
very easy hold from the black side that
must feel good as the chess player
because you're told win with white draw
with black and I love the fact that
Wesley has started this game with E4 the
king's Indian isn't working out for you
you have to put your pride behind you
and your only consideration has to be
maximizing your chances of success we
get a fresh opening a rosalima or Moscow
variation and this line has been all the
rage recently
it has and this queen on D4 it looks
like he can be kicked by Black's pieces
but there's no Knight going to C6 and
there's no Pawn to E5 because then you
give up the D5 Square these are big
decisions that black needs to make and
as you're pointing out the Knight and F3
that can also reroute towards the queen
side so both sides have their fair share
of ideas yeah this Knight D2 Knight C4
maneuver is one of the most important
ways in which white can reinforce the
attack on Black's two main weaknesses B6
and D6 right now both of these pawns are
very well defended but should a knight
land on C4 black actually uh in those
positions has a very hard time keeping
D6 Under Wraps Bishop G3 would be
another way to hit that pawn directly
and try to induce the move E5 which
obviously creates a big positional
weakness on D5
yeah that doesn't look so nice for black
at first glance but then you realize
that black is actually situated quite
nicely if that night we're gonna try to
jump in the center but speaking of nice
jumping the center Knight back to D2
this was your idea to go to C4 and black
can't push the pawn to E5 at any moment
that does loose enough control over D5
which I don't love and so what else
comes to mind can black get away with D5
down there or with the king of the
center is that way too risky I've tried
playing D5 in these types of positions I
think alirez is probably calculating it
but in my experience it's almost always
too risky and there's a specific reason
why if you envision the trade on D5 at
the end of that line White's Queen is
going to be aimed at the G7 Pawn which
means the black can't really easily get
this bishop out of f8 nor can black
Castle Queen side that would be illegal
because of the bishop on H4 so White's
pieces are just better situated they're
better equipped to handle the opening of
the center so my vote would be either 95
or E5 but this is a pretty drastic
measure it's it's very clear to me that
Wesley has essentially won the opening
battle
that D5 square is looking juicy and in
these positions you reroute your knight
to E3 using oh I'll say using C4 Square
I love that move by trading Queens you
soften up Black's defense of the D6 pawn
and also the B6 Pawn that is a very
astute move by Wesley and there's a nice
tactical underpinning to it you're not
just playing positionally in the event
of the trade you would have taken with a
knight and there would even be some
mating ideas with the Rook capturing on
D6 right now Wesley is firmly back in
the driver's seat he is playing
positionally and I think he's going to
drop his Queen back and reinforce his
control over the D5 square with either
Bishop C4 or even Knight C4 and then
your idea Robert 93 95 is very much on
the menu
Knight C4 hits the B6 ball oh yeah
that's my Pawn because the pawn D6 is
pinned so this looks like a huge problem
for alireza it's a positional Nightmare
and let's just point out that if white
can trade the light Square Bishops and
then one pair of knights black is
saddled with this horrible dark Square
Bishop that doesn't have any open
diagonals yeah that's an absolute
classic illustration of good night
versus bad bishop and there is a reason
why a lot of these textbook positions
actually arise out of sicilian's gone
wrong because in many Sicilians gone
wrong black is indeed forced to play E5
and then if white can crunch down his
control over the D5 Square you get those
types of positions instead Ali Reza
desperately trying to stir the pot by
taking on e4 was that a poisoned Pawn
I'm wondering because Knight takes E5
threatens Checkmate in one with Queen
takes F7 forcing black to Castle and
then I'm already looking at ideas with
Knight takes F7 Bishop C4 Bishop H5 you
could stare in all directions but
unfortunately for Alaris it looks very
iffy for his King
There's A really lovely idea that would
have involved taking on E5 and then
later sticking the Knight on G6 because
the Knight would be untouchable now
that's a moot point because the bishop
controls that square and I think that is
the reason why Robert his move order was
very imprecise I don't think that Wesley
should have allowed a bishop to land on
e4 now if he plays Bishop C4 after Queen
E8 that's precisely where he would have
had the move Knight G6 now he doesn't
have that resource and I think alireza
is very much holding on
that's an essential point that the G6
square is not whites for the taking but
let's say Wesley plays in True Wesley
style and he does it I was going to ask
you if he trades the light Square
Bishops isn't white just simply better
no White's definitely still better
probably even clearly better Pawn takes
E5 Bishop takes E4 is a very pretty
tactical justification opening up an
attack on The Rook I think alireza has
to trade on D3 and bite the bullet
because now he's allowed Knight G6 again
rookie a bishop C4 and he's gonna drop
material
you were just talking about this idea
Knight G6 hitting the rook and Wesley
first plays Bishop C4 I can't really
blame him for that because how does
black actually save the material
well not with Queen E8 again because of
Knight G6 he's got to go D5 and jettison
upon but he's not just jettisoning upon
White's also going to be super super
active in the ensuing position this is
borderline technically winning but with
you know 40 seconds or so for both sides
anything can still happen
and there are a couple players you never
want a pawn down position like that
against Magnus Carlson of course Wesley
so might be my second pick of players I
would never want to face in a technical
end game so we're seeing this position
where white controls the D file has an
extra Pawn but the good news is black
doesn't really have any more weaknesses
in his Camp so that gives him some
chances it does but Wesley reinforces
the threat of wait now Rook D7 should be
the same
he's got 97 inaccurate and Alvarez is
still in the game despite his incredibly
ugly Pawn structure it's technically
winning Robert but with the open e-file
anything can still happen
and let's point out that if the queens
and one pair of Rooks get traded there
are good drawing chances for black
anyway because one extra Pawn is often
not enough to have a Winning Edge in end
games with Rooks but this is what I'm
talking about when there are open files
there is tactical potential Wesley has
allowed a rook to sink its teeth onto
the second rank Queen F4 was a huge
threat in that position and so Wesley is
suddenly the passive one
yeah and the queen of B4 stops that oh
oh Queen E5 that's that's sweet back
rank Checkmate lovely move trying to
shuffle the queen over to F5 and attack
the F2 Pawn now Queenie two
oh threatens Rook D1 and White's got to
be careful not to get mated on the
background that's a very easy Motif to
miss
and now that's why G3 was played to give
the king some space and the black king
goes up I don't really see how white
plays for win here with the F2 Pawn
being such a clear Target
I was gonna say moreover black is okay
with the queen trade because his Rook is
so much more active and his King is
going to be more active as well this is
a draw I I don't think alireza should
have any trouble holding this together
although Wesley did a great job there uh
of ensuring that he still has the extra
Pawn
this is a much better version of what it
was before because White's Rook was
passive now white has a very active Rook
so what alright is going to do is King
H7 King G7 back and forth I don't think
the white king can escape especially
after that move Rook to B1 The crucial
defensive component here is that pawn on
G4 which is keeping the white king in a
cage white can't really push the F Pawn
because of a second ranked check Wesley
has nothing to do other than to repeat
moves that is an infuriating result for
Wesley so who was winning Robert at some
point in one move with Rook D7 instead
of Knight D7
and all there is a farooja we see him on
the screen he looks a lot different now
that he leads the three plus one time
control by a score of four to one he's
much happier even if the overall match
score is still in Wesley's favor I think
farrugia is the only player who could be
smiling at the moment honestly such an
incredible turnaround in this match for
rooster showing what he is made of he
was reeling he was down by five now it's
a completely different match it's a new
match and it's a six to eight match
Wesley has to step it up in the second
half of the three plus one portion
has just been a different player in this
quicker time Patrol Donya we know that
alireza is the favorite in the bullet so
what is Wes's mentality Like That
Remains the question well let everybody
sit and think on that one when we return
from the break here at the speed
distances
[Music]
thank you
foreign
why did you on passant bro I swear to
God ambassan should be enforced all my
friends watching and this is taking
forever play faster if I can move this
poem backwards it would basically be
Checkmate oh and draws are dumb
I should be able to flag him no matter
how many times I repeat moves 1400 years
and it's the same game every
time you know what it's time for some
updates I'm tired of this I'm I'm doing
it still mate is now a win for the
player who gets stalemated you're
welcome Eric Rosen hey it's the Rosen
trout pawns can move backwards why is
that a never not been a rule pawns can
move backwards now every piece should be
allowed to on passant what
how
gunzo update enter Wiseman ending
there's just two kings on the board what
is this Purgatory this is so awesome
what we're doing here got guys we're
changing chess why can't people just
move however they want whenever they
want
[Music]
now on C4 actually explodes
pawns are weak no more pawns can promote
on the first move
I'm not sure I made the users as happy
as I thought I would maybe chess doesn't
need an update Financial systems do need
an update though coinbase is working on
just that re-envisioning an entirely new
Financial system that is decentralized
and fully transparent thank you coinbase
for sponsoring competitive chess and
making events like the speed Chess
Championship possible go to coinbase.com
update the system today to learn more
oh he's I was here I was lost oh okay
well hey hey let's go oh no I think you
should have just done that sure I got
14. we beat it let's go no 15. unreal no
first try eight in a row nine in a row
baby let's go
let's go I gotta oh cool I got a little
achievement thing I honestly really
enjoyed that that was really cool
become a chess.com Community streamer at
go.chess.com start streaming
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we return to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase this
is alireza this is Wesley this is the
SCC and Dunya we have had a great match
thus far but it kind of feels like two
different matches all in one
it completely feels like two different
measures the three plus one segment at
least the first half of it could not
have been more distinct from what we saw
in the five plus one portion I started
getting worried Robert as commentators
we don't love blowouts because they're
less fun to commentate I was worried
when Wesley jumped out to that
five-point lead that he was one or two
wins away from entering that blowout
territory instead it's a two-point match
alireza wins one more game and he is
within sight of actually tying this
match going to the bullet which would be
absolutely huge for his chances of
success
there are very few players on this
planet who could force Wesley so to
relinquish a lead Ali reason is one of
them Wesley he's such a veteran of this
experience in the SEC but it's not
always about experience sometimes the
youth Prevail and for allereza fuja he
was third place in the bullet Chess
Championship he's done well throughout
the Champions chess tour but he has not
exited the first round or excuse me past
the first round until this year in the
SEC so don it's a new year and likely a
new ferrugia man that's got to be the
biggest water bottle I've ever seen from
Ali resin good to know that he stays
hydrated he gave him some some potassium
that banana really helped Elevate his
game to the next level big big game
right now right the momentum clearly on
alirez's side Wesley coming off a very
frustrating game and he would in which
he was unable to convert a brilliantly
played opening into a full point and we
have
a rosalimo another rosalima I should say
you know this has been an opening tour
of sorts we've had Kings Indians then
Wesley has white went to E4 for Wesley's
Blackie starting with a night orb then
went to E5 now to a rosalimo so I think
he's being hard to pin down although he
also probably wants to basically a
little bit more solid as far Asia did
win a bunch of the decisive games in the
recent stretch H3 is a pretty uncommon
move fun fact this is the line Wesley so
recommends in his E4 uh three volume E4
chessable course except Wesley's move is
the immediate D4 that's also the main
line farrugia delays it by playing H3
kind of a kg flexible approach perhaps a
more positional approach than the
immediate D4 and we see Wesley very
committal decision to play E5 is he
gonna follow up with no never mind it's
ferrugia's turn it's a strike at the
center
D4 played and if you take on D4 again as
black and the White Knight takes that
Bishop on G7 is a happier piece the E4
Pawn is more vulnerable this is an odd
Pawn structure Dania I do tend to like
this position from the black side
because I feel like white is quite
likely to overextend although I would
argue that Black's top priority should
be to play D6 and open up the bishop and
try to secure the D4 Pawn that might
have been better achieved by dropping
the Knight back to E8 in order to
reinforce the D6 Square the Knight on D5
is more vulnerable than it looks it
looks really good right it's shielded by
the D4 Pawn but it can still be attacked
diagonally either by the bishop which
can come out to C4 or I was going to say
by the queen which comes out to B3 and
this Knight just doesn't have all that
many appetizing squares to drop back to
you don't really want to go to E7 Robert
is you're starting to give white a
pretty major lead in development
especially if this Knight comes out to
E4 and clamps down on these dark squares
and the way Wes is looking at the board
right now he's kind of side eyeing that
night what are you doing there why are
you sticking out like that how come I
can't protect you and for black you get
thrown in with like H6 right now but
that gets very spicy because the White
Queen will take the Knight on D5 and
after H6 takes G5 though Knight takes
back on G5 the black king starts to feel
in danger
I think that's exactly what's going to
happen great call by you and it's
important to avoid the instinctual
Bishop H4 alireza might play it but not
without proper thought because Bishop H4
affords the Knight a beautiful Square on
F4 instead he gives the bishop up on H6
and now takes on D5 but wait a second
wait a second now black has a Tempo and
black can use this Tempo to travel to
situ with his Knight what is all there
was intending against that we already
know Oliver is not afraid to lose a rook
in the corner at full rook and Wesley he
trusts him I guess if his Rook to E8
staring at this E5 Pawn but don't I
think you were a hundred percent correct
then Knight B4 that was the better move
that's why rookie earned a mistake
question mark I honestly feel like this
is as close as Wesley comes to tilt
right he's not playing H5 H4 but he
seems a little bit dejected in the way
that he was playing I think in the five
minute portion he would have devoted at
least another 10-15 seconds to
calculating an ip4 maybe from a time
management standpoint a move like rookie
8 is the wise decision as we see alireza
bring the Knight to A3
but do you see Wesley just go for a
catwalk you know he went back he ran
went down the runway he's back in his
seat and quickly plays B5 so not sure
what's happening in his background there
but B5 was a good move stopping that
night from entering the center of via C4
but that was a really sloppy move by
farusha I thought he should have gone to
D2 and then to E4 he wants F6 or D6 now
the Knight on A3 is completely stranded
and to make matters worse Wesley is only
one move away from consolidating with
Bishop B7 and white is it trouble
because if white loses the E5 Pawn not a
shred not an Iota will remain from
White's initiative just a couple of
moves ago
and that is why he wanted night eight
through brother Knight D2 he didn't want
to give up the E5 Pawn but now that
Knight is offside it's not doing much as
you said Bishop B7 a very obvious move
threatening Knight takes E5 oh I think
it still works out for black Bishop G6
Knight takes E5 tactically speaking
black is ahead lovely tactics because
that Knight on E5 will both guard G6 and
F7 I'll show this for newer players who
might be excited at the prospect if
Bishop takes G6 black responds with
Knight takes E5 this is a discovered
attack on the queen a defensive move
because F7 is guarded and if the queen
drops back the Knight travels back and
takes the bishop on G6 great calculation
by Wesley let's go back to the live
board because we have apparently another
mistake by alireza faruja who just seems
to have lost his composure in this game
and now maybe Wesley can bring the Rook
to C8 and once again threaten Knight
takes E5
and it looks like Wesley has played Rook
to see it as we get back to the live
position I'll raise it down under 20
seconds Knight takes E5 is a huge threat
there's no Rook C1 because the bishop on
H6 is so strong
man this is turning out into such a
frustrating game by faruga who got
exactly what he wanted and he's still
trying but with five seconds I don't see
him holding this position together Queen
to D6 but Rook E6 chases the queen away
oh sorry he didn't do that
F6 would not be a very good move but
this reminds me of the five plus one
Donya where wessie got to huge lead on
the clock and alderiza was scrambling to
make his last moves the position is not
lost for white it's not good but it's
not completely lost there are a lot of
tactics in the air but I think Wesley's
gonna play a tricky move and you just
highlighted D6 Square D6 feels like a
tricky move that white can just collapse
after the advice my coach shared when
your opponent is in time or if you want
to make non-forcing moves moves that
pose practical problems and mainly that
force your opponent to make decisions
that's what you see Wesley doing here
Bishop G7 right he's making these
relatively non-committal open-ended
moves although I thought D6 would have
been a much more effective strategy at
opening up the center and posing
problems wait he's watered a piece
had no time but Bishop takes Knight
would have stolen the bishop in the
center and this is why you need to
conserve your time if you're alireza oh
my God what a huge mess he moved the
right piece but he didn't drag it two
squares he only moved it one square and
Wesley should be able to convert his
Advantage now although it's still not
over
no because the black king is open at
this stage the F6 Square for example if
you take on B2 Knight F6 check would be
a fork
and Wesley obviously refraining from the
repetition he just repeated once to gain
a couple seconds and King g7's a heads
up prophylactic move preparing F5
and Quincy went back looks very strong
for black there it is and the beat
Dupont is D3
just one a piece
well done it's over oh he's blooded me
oh
[Applause]
and you said it was over but you did
think from that side of things and this
is why you have to have laser sharp
Focus Donya laser sharp Focus you need
to keep that the whole time because you
see that that is what you need in order
to win those games and Ali Reza did not
resign can I do an instant replay for
players who maybe didn't follow exactly
what happened there as we see an allop
and a Mainline alopin in the next game
I'm totally speechless right now here is
the end of the game Wesley did
everything right once he blundered that
piece and first didn't take it this is
the problem with pre-moving when you've
got six seconds on your clock you need
to take at least half a second per move
you don't think that there could even be
a threat right you think that white is
out of threads white is out of ideas
Queen H6 and it's literally made you
don't even lose your queen you literally
get mated unfreaking believable
those dark squares were not under
blessed control I mean that should have
been a win for Wesley but Shoulda Coulda
Woulda it doesn't matter what we have
right now is a one point match Donya
Wesley is still leading but that's so
easy to forget given what's happened in
these last six games in the three plus
one and that was the most debilitating
game of all because think about it you
win that game with the black pieces you
get white you have all of the momentum
back you lose it's literally a one point
match all of the effort that Wesley
devoted into the previous two games he's
only got half a point to show for it but
I really really like the way that he's
handling the situation I think he's got
a winning position out of the opening
again
and this is what you can't do if you're
Ali Reza you cannot give Wesley that his
confidence back because when he's in
Rhythm we keep talking about he's
exceptionally difficult to beat but when
you give him a Checkmate attack in the
first 15 moves of the game that's a
problem it's a show online let's bring
up an analysis board here Bishop G7
fails tactically to a fork that Queen B5
check is step one but then once the King
goes to f8 there's Queen takes B6 and
Knight D7 check at the end lovely and
you know what's crazy at the at the end
of this line it's another fork and you
also drop the bishop well well explained
this is just tragic for alireza and he
did make his move he decided to bring
his Rook to C8 but now he's woefully
underdeveloped Dania and White's
initiative rages on and white could pick
up the pawn on A5 I think my coach would
always make an emphasis on this when
you've got the initiative a lot of
players they tunnel vision attacks but
the reality is don't be afraid to cash
in if you can take upon an A5 and get a
protected passer on the corner of the
board you absolutely should but look at
the filigree Precision by Wesley before
taking the pawn he first sticks his
Queen on E5 this is 2700 Chess at its
finest he is provoking another weakening
move either F6 or Rook G8 which will
deprive lack of castling rights and on
the next move he's finally going to
harvest the pawn on A5
Exquisite and the black pawn had to take
on C6 because their pins in the diagonal
now you're inducing another weakness
before grabbing this Pawn A5 Wesley it
seems like he lost his footing
completely but it's not where's he going
so you know losing his footing he's no
longer in his chair he keeps getting
away from his computer for a second he
might be losing his footing but he's on
his feet and he's back he's back in the
camera Zone
and converting this position not the
easiest job in the world but given his
time Advantage I don't think he'll have
any trouble
right because the black king won't be
truly safe the e-file is open and Wesley
so is still seeking his first win in
this segment and that's all to think
about and speaking of wild E5 when your
king is in the center try to trap the
queen but this is what per this is by
the way wifers is such a difficult
opponent and bullet he finds these
tricks so quickly I mean just look at
this we don't have to bring up an
elsewhere it's just one move but I'll
make them on the board d-e no that is
not the one move and the queen is
trapped out of nowhere just like that so
what do you do if you're Wesley well you
have to forget about the D4 Pawn because
Black's not about to take it with his
pawn and give away a massive check on E1
or is he maybe feroza does take on D4
and say
at least I'll die with a full stomach
he does well yeah Yasser would be proud
but in this position rookie one check is
tempting Brook D1 pins that pawn to the
queen Knight E4 just going forward looks
pretty good so white has many options he
chooses the night jump and a bishop to
E7 there's Bishop H6 once again
preventing black and castling yeah this
is so debilitating and even from a
positional standpoint white is better
because
well because there's that a pawn which
is going to shove forward to A5 and then
perhaps to A6 so even on the off chance
that black does manage to Castle he
won't have solved all of his problems
and forget about that he's gone King F7
he maybe wants to Castle by hand I
actually like the way that Ferris is
defending here thus far
and what if white pushes the a pawn up
the board like you were suggesting A5
the Knight comes into D5 bring your
queen back to C4 hit that D4 upon and
then push A6 and just run that pawn up
the board is black in time to deal with
all the threats
I don't think he is and I think
farouza's only chance of a miracle
comeback is the milk Wesley's clock down
below 30 seconds because we know Wesley
has struggled in these low time
situations in the three plus one portion
any invests some time plays A5 well done
and the queen I think is gonna bring be
brought back to C4 hitting this very
vulnerable Pawn on D4
and whoa C5 that looks like a move that
loses the spot like Rook D1 Knight C3
trap oh that's beautiful room T1 and
Knight T3 is gorgeous geometry but
Wesley banking on that pawn looking for
Arusha though trying to go King G6 and
trapping the bishop now wait a second
this game is still far from over
so Wesley gives up the bishop against
the king go back king of seven Knight D6
check
but black is only one move away Robert
from playing something like rook f8 and
tucking the king away on the safest
square that it has been on essentially
all game long
but this is where the clock is so
important look at first time 4.7 seconds
if I'm Wesley I'm playing maybe Knight
takes C5 here just grab it along when I
can the black king won't find any
shelter
and white doesn't really have to hurry
white is technically down a piece here
but you could even play a slow move like
G3 just to make some Luft and look at
Wesley he does just that he keeps his
composure and he's taking all of Peru's
response here this should be completely
winning for Wesley sobity he needs to
find the way to nail in the coffin here
whoa
he allowed the pawn to go forward and
here comes D2 and rookie one check
the move Queen F5 didn't actually carry
any threats
and rookie one is a massive threat
the Black Knight is such a good Defender
and if King G2 at some point if you're
scared you can win Queen D5 check but
Wesley has to move
and look at that he set up a trap he
allowed the queen to move forward to
take on D2 because the black king gets
mated Rook Cafe
he missed it
oh my God this is crazy now farooza is
back in the driver's seat
there's no Checkmate but can black
actually move here Rook F7 Rook f8 might
be a draw it's a draw ferrugia has to
repeat moves
black has no choice my goodness but but
I say this as if it draws a bad result
for farouza
this is crazy
wow farrugia just won't lose he's doing
his best Wesley so saying I will not go
down in any single game Dino this is
incredible let's watch the opening of
this game but I do want to do another
instant replay I want to show the missed
win by farugia there with rookie one
which I think Wesley might have even
allowed deliberately and then the Mist
win by Wesley so which is the most
shocking to me I'm gonna bring up that
game if we could pull up an analysis
board here real fast first of all H4
it's like you know your your city is
burning down and you're busy like
painting your walls or something rookie
one and they getting this over Borussia
plays Queen T4 but then there's a
shocking thing this is basic Betty Rook
f8 check Robert deflection you have to
take and queen takes C4 white has way
too many pawns here black can take some
of them but at the end of the line okay
white should be still uh technically
winning in this position
and that's why you put H4 so when black
queen went to E4 it was not checked so
it was good awareness and Wesley after
slipping after losing most of Advantage
all the residents deserves a ton of
credit for fighting back in the game it
looked completely hopeless for him but
he trapped Wesley's Bishop on H6 that
was a big turning point in that game and
Donna still a one point lead for Wesley
it's weird to say that because the only
player who's been doing any winning has
been alireza in the three plus one but
that's what happens when you're up seven
to two in the longest high Patrol it's
honestly crazy how the momentum can
shift how the same match can look so
different across the span of let's say
an hour
and Ali Reza with the white pieces a
slightly better position he could tie
the match with a victory in this game
and it's crazy to me Robert confirm
Beyond this Wesley has not won a game in
the three plus one segment
not a single win for Wesley I mean it
seems like he was about to win a few of
them and I'll there is a fought to The
Bitter End let's not forget Dania that
Wesley was up a full piece and blundered
into a Checkmate that alibraza found in
the blink of an eye so let's look at
this position it's a king's Indian
Wesley has the black side of the king's
Indian once again and oh taking on A5
that doesn't look ideal from White's
perspective
not ideal at all and like any of these
King's Indian structures when white
plays C4 you do not want a situation
where black clamps down on the C5 square
and that is why we see alireza Driving
Department to A5 he's going to
discourage black from playing V6 and
then in true King's Indian style for
white is going to drive the other Pawn
up to C5 there we go
and the Knight went to A6 just to
preempt this that if you want to play C4
C5 good luck to you my knight will cover
that square and in this moment I think
that black has a big Choice do you play
Knight H5 and go for F5 and play in that
King's inning aggressive style or do you
make a move like C6 and challenge for
the center he says neither I'm gonna go
backwards with my knight but F5 is not
possible but I don't like Black's
position because I think likely for
Arusha will play Queen C2 you want to
discourage black from playing at five
and delay this move as far as possible
on the other hand black might then play
Knight C5 and if white takes twice on C5
yes Black's Pawn structure is slightly
damaged true but black gets the bishop
pair and black gets much easier access
to playing this F7 F5 move I think
farouza just induced King H7 to make it
harder for Wesley and less palatable for
Wesley to play F5 because in some
situations after the trade the bishop
exerts an x-ray on the F5 Pawn these
types of subtleties uh farusha has been
so so good at throughout the
three-minute segment
and he plays his Knight to D2 now the
engine not a huge fan of it and yeah F5
because you can't exploit the pin on the
diagonal if EF5 gf5 black will be able
to play E4 at the right moment this is
starting to look favorable for Wesley
who has everything you could ask for in
a king's Indian defense there's a crazy
tactic white can take twice on F5 then
pin The Rook with something like Queen
C2 and pick off The Rook with G4 but
when all of the Smoke Clears white king
is going to be wide open in that
situation I can guarantee you knowing
farusha he just spent 20 seconds
calculating that but decided ultimately
on the typical approach here come
Wesley's pawns though
I like starting with Bishop F6 because
you can play Bishop H4 first if you're
worried about having a terrible Dark
Sword Bishop for the rest of the game
and all there is it takes on a six and
play C5 he gets rid of that Knight so C5
is about to happen but maybe it's what's
happening for black can black play it
first
can black play it first and freeze
White's progress on the queen side that
is the important question alireza would
take on passant there instead Bishop H4
following up on Wesley's positional plan
trading off his bad Bishop but Robert
White might strike first here and if
Black's Queen side collapses he won't
have the resources to devote his full
attention to the kingside pawn storm
instead though rookie two a much Tamer
approach adopted by Borussia or a much
more rajaba approach shall we say I was
I knew you were about to say that after
you said sorry but you're all good but
the reason he went rookie two was that
he wants to defend his second rank if he
had decided to trade on H4 once oh the
evil bar is going all the way up but I
was saying Bishop mates were quittish
for if you could get some Bishop takes
H3 business there would be an attack but
not with that Rook on E2 right if you
take on C5 now Knight C5 Queen C5
there's no Bishop takes H3 anymore and
that's what I think Wesley was relying
on in some previous variations you're
absolutely right The Rook on E2 is a
star defensive move and from a disc
distance I think Wesley uh should have
probably probably wanted to play D5 but
in that situation white could have taken
and gone C6 Wesley has to agree to the
complete dissolution of his Queen side
pawns he's saddled now with a weakness
on C6 with a weakness on E5 that white
can attack by jumping to C4 version now
firmly in the driver's seat again
this looks terrible for black here come
the Rooks the D file and oh the bars all
the way up and look at that move Knight
B6 please take me open the a file and if
you trade on B6 it'll probably remove
look at that Westie resigned he's got
any material down but he had enough and
that's not a tilt resignation the
evaluation there is plus five for those
who are curious because Knight C5 was
completely Unstoppable another dominant
game by alireza ferrugia again at some
point it looked pretty good for Wesley
so but he has lost the ability to play
at the highest level in critical
positions the fortunes have changed and
the match is tied
incredible and there is one game left in
this time Patrol I didn't actually look
the clocks down yet but if Wesley was
able to waste the remaining time that
could have been the last game the issue
is when you're facing alireza you don't
actually want to play bullet so you're
essentially as you say you're leaping
from the uh frying pan into the fire if
you are Wesley and he needs this win I
truly believe that if he is going to win
this match he needs to take this game
and he has the white pieces actually in
this one it's it's funny because once
the king's Indian defense Wesley and
Eliza could play with either color
clearly but Wesley does have the white
pieces right now oh man I would
seriously vote that this is the most
entertaining SCC match that we've had so
far and the best is yet to come because
we will have 30 minutes of one plus one
to round off this incredible match the
score is tied at eight and a half a
piece for those joining late Wesley held
a five-point lead throughout the five
minute portion alireza came back and he
didn't even need the bullet it to come
all the way back and tie the match with
one last game to play in the
three-minute segment and yet again
Robert they Resort back to this Pawn
structure which I think has served
alireza very very well throughout this
match I don't like this for white
no I don't like it for white either and
it's control over the E4 square but
let's not forget that when they played
this similar position earlier Wesley who
does have the white pieces in this game
uh he was with the advantage he
sacrificed his exchange for pretty much
no reason Dania and maybe that was the
start of all there is a gaining
confidence
it was indeed and Ali Reza is better
again he's probably much better at this
point G4 Wesley's got nothing going for
him on the queen side and look at the
way that Reza has accumulated his pieces
on the king side his pieces are
breathing a queen is where it needs to
be the bishop is hitting White's queen
and the other Bishop can come out to H6
we've been pointing out this idea quite
a few times and I think now is the
perfect time to involve the bishop and
pressure of the Knight
this looks so pleasant for alireza who
does have the black piece in this game
and he brings a knight to C5 now Knight
D3 is an option hitting the Rook on E1
and that pawn on B2 so we have seen a
swap of pieces on G4 but even if you get
your knight to E4 that's great you have
a 94 that black Bishop gets the H6 and
so in the E3 square is vulnerable
and if alireza so chooses he can support
the Knight with the move B6 he's shown a
predilection for doing that earlier
instead he does yield to the trade but
as I said in the first time that they
reached this position just because white
has a pretty looking knight on e4 it
really doesn't mean anything black can
quite easily work around that night and
he can do that in a variety of ways
there's Bishop H6 that Knight could get
targeted after Bishop E3 and now I think
he will at some point try to double
Rooks on the seventh ring on the f-file
Wesley though doing a pretty good job so
far of holding the position together
and the doubling of the Rooks what does
it amount to that's the big question
will there actually be a checkmating
threat but it can't hurt so he starts
with B6 stopping any kind of C5 business
and then he can play Rook F7 you can
play Rook F5 I don't know where you want
your Rook on the f file but the doubling
of the Rooks seems to be best as it's
the only Avenue into White's position
that black can look for a very
inadvisable move for white would be a
poorly timed H3 because the bishop on G3
would lose the support of the pawn and
it would send the Knight back
to a square that it potentially wants to
access anyway contesting the Knight on
e4 great positional patient play by
alireza farouza setting all of his pawns
up on the same color as White's very
poor Bishop on G3 he bites the bullet
and plays H3
and he brings his King to H2 to protect
that Bishop he wants to see a trade on
e4 because if you have a knight E4
rookie for suddenly Rook G4 becomes a
pretty big threat but black will likely
avoid that and does by not even training
the knights to begin with So Daniel when
you look at this it does look to me at
first glance like what what oh
I almost want to play Rook F1 check you
know it's a distraction we need for a
knight G3 that's a beautiful concept
actually now the reason Wesley dropped
his King back to H1 Robert we should
point out is because black was in fact
threatening to play Knight takes G3 the
queen is undefended the Knight is pinned
and queen takes G3 there would have run
into Bishop F4 but it looks like alireza
is merely accumulating and accumulating
and at some point he will have to
manifest something specific on the king
side maybe it's something like Bishop F4
but I don't really see anything concrete
just yet the Knight on e4 such an
integral defensive piece for Wesley
because it holds the F2 Square
and plus you might play Queen G4 to
trade Queens I think I would do it right
now I'm scared of getting checkmated if
I'm Wesley so the move Queen to G4
offering the queen trade that Knight on
e4 which we said is what white wants
wasn't so scary but it does control the
important squares agree completely I
think you have to play Queen G4 you
might not have had another chance
because alireza might have gone King h8
on the next move and then he would have
been able to sidestep the queen trade
with Queen H6 great awareness by Wesley
I think he's on the way to drawing this
game
well we know that draws are not likely
in speed chess blunders do happen and
you look at the night trade being
offered I do agree with you like if you
put Bishop F4 and Knight takes E4 it
looks relatively equal but I would say
black here because the healthier Pawn
structure
and it's a it's easy to forget that the
pawn on E5 is in fact a protected passer
as Wesley carefully navigates the
Minefield Bishop H6 was the only move to
maintain good drawing chances now
alireza has to find Knight F2 check
otherwise he drops the Knight King G1
and Rook out one wait a second black is
in a little bit of danger here too
although after Rook F1 the Knight can
move because the king oh yeah on F7
so apparently white needs to play rookie
three in order to take the sting out of
Knight takes G4 and Wesley finds that
too and suddenly yes black was on the
back foot that Knight is pretty much
trapped in there so Rook F6 hits the
bishop the bishop slides back but now
the Rook goes to G6 oh he takes on G4
and Rook G6 in response to Rook G3 black
will win the bishop back
what tactical presence of mind with
eight seconds
and I think that if your Wesley have to
go for that right you go Rook G3 you
take on G4 and then your Rook on goes to
F1 to F5 to win back to G Pawn great
call Rick F1 now black has to take Rook
f8 would be terrible because it would
allow a Discovery at the end of the
trade Wesley is going to pick up that
pawn black is a little bit better here
because he's got the better pass Pawn on
E5
but Wesley should be able to hold this
the white king just goes to the center
if that black oh that was a good move
but is there a rook F3 at some point
that could actually transition to a
losing end game
absolutely because black would have
gotten his King to F4 and the superior
King position in a pawn end game can be
the decisive Factor but that will remain
behind the scenes what will not remain
behind the scenes is an incredible 30
minutes of bullet to decide this match
we have a tied match right now you
wouldn't believe it after Wesley so
storm to a 7-2 edge into five plus one
but the three plus one is a mirror image
rolls reverse borugia seven Wesley two
it's nine to nine Donya what did we just
see
listen we've had a lot of tied matches
in our SEC commentating career we've had
matches go to Armageddon over time I
don't think I've ever seen a match
that's actually two matches this isn't
one match this is a series between
ferrugia and so the first match happened
in the five-minute segment it was a
dominant performance by Wesley the
second was a dominant performance by
faruja he holds all of the momentum
Wesley will have to put the last hour
behind him and play the best bullet of
his career if he wants to knock off an
on for Mali Raza faruja we started with
great expectations for Wesley so it then
turned into a tale of two different
matches for alireza frujo we are tied
nine to nine and the players they're
gonna head to break we're gonna do the
same but before we do we just want to
give a shout out to and thank ag1 a new
partner of the SCC ag1 is your daily
support of key Health functions from
mental performance to energy and the
immune system it's the one product that
does the work of many to find out more
visit
drinkag1.com chess or use the command
ag1 in chat thank you to ag1 for
sponsoring the SCC and I think both
players they'll need to refresh
themselves for the upcoming bullet we'll
do just that do not go anywhere
everybody this is the speed test
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
thank you
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
Chase is coming to Chester
um enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze the hairs start
with two jump spells and five free
spells which recharge after five moves
you may cast your spare whenever you
wish before making a regular chest move
jump is a spell cast to one square
wherein if there is a piece on that
square other pieces can jump over the
Charmed piece the freeze spell is cashed
over a three by three square area and
the pieces in this area are temporarily
Frozen in place
and bang your powers of Chess and
surgery to defeat your opponent
he went supercell and chess.com have
cooked up in our new variant spell chess
dropping on September 1st
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
things he is the man of the hour he had
a great hour of three minutes plus one
second increment he went undefeated
against Wesley so and done it with the
bullet come coming up we have to relive
the memories from 2023 bulletins
Championship where Oliver's Cruiser
finished in third place
and I was just lucky I didn't get to
play alireza in the BCC because if he
showed the kind of form that he did in
all of his other matches then I think
that would have been a blowout but Ali
Raza for Asia he's so good at bullet
he's so ridiculously fast and he is
riding the coattails of an hour of
momentum Robert Wesley was the man of
the first 90 minutes veruga was the man
of the hour who's gonna be the man of
the last 30 minutes
that remains to be seen this is a tied
match Dania we know farouja is a bullet
Phenom but Wesley so is no slouch either
in fact coming into this match we were
both shocked that in their bullet
history it was Wesley who actually had
the lead granted that was from three
plus years ago I think we talked about
this yesterday some chess fans tend to
assume that just because the player is
relatively less experienced in a bullet
time control that means they're slow
that means they can't pre-move and that
means they can't play Fast not so with
Wesley he's played a lot of bullet he's
experienced more so than people realize
and he is a very very difficult bullet
opponent here we go 30 minutes to decide
this incredible match and we have
another Karo Khan
yeah this has served the player as well
they I think had an even Affair in a
previous matchup but I like this in
Quaker time controls I stand by it if
you could take a pawn grab it and force
your opponent to prove compensation you
do just that and now you can play Bishop
take C6 and queen A4 this is a common
trap in the Caro and Wesley's blundered
in the first game of the bullet
and queen takes C6 check you have to
play King E7 you're lucky that you don't
lose in the spot because the Rook on 8
is loose but Don just some of this isn't
quite game over even though it looks
very bad for black I think it's very
close G takes F3 you have to pick the
bishop back up I mean you could play
Queen B7 check but there was no need now
Rook C8 could be met with Queen D6 check
trading the queens and then playing B4
whites up two pawns for essentially no
compensation here
yeah once you get B4 and that feels like
it's game over and the misery continues
for Wesley as soon as we left the five
plus one it's like all the reason was a
different person that you are so strong
in bullet chess and the evil bar is
creeping down a little bit do you think
that Wesley has some outside chances
well he has to break through White
Center to Garner any chances whatsoever
is going to prevent that from happening
with F4 I think the only chance to stir
things up for Wesley yeah he's going
after the F Pawn he's gonna try to go
Rook G8 and Rook G4 there's definitely
some chances the Knight is a very
difficult piece to handle in bullet and
we see Wesley fighting tooth and nail to
generate active counter play good job
here but I think for Russia is just in
time to secure that pawn with his King
after King E3 I'm already looking at F6
and E5 ideas exploding a pin on the
diagonal this is kind of messy stuff and
for Wesley he just brings his King in it
says white is frozen white is frozen
he's also down on time and there's your
F6 move opening up a pathway now E5 is a
massive threat Borussia has to step away
with his King very heads up move Robert
because now he's got a pin he's got a
little bit more time to reshuffle his
pieces and bring them to better Central
squares
now speaking of better essential scores
the King goes to E6 and look at this
black has these great pawns on D5 and E5
and the eval Bar says Wesley is worse no
more and he can take the pawn on H2 and
he is no more down any pawns instead he
goes the other way going for activity
I'm a little bit worried about the
prospect of white playing B5 and getting
those connected passers though
what if the is D4 here opening up
King D5 King C4 mating net against the
white king great call this is completely
a three result game
and if King D5 C7 I don't think black is
in time to go for it at that point so
King D6 that feels smarter but there's a
check on F6 defending it upon laterally
now the Knight can jump into C5 and
Wesley's in trouble once again
yes and he's gonna lose the black king
can only go so far you're not getting
into the enemy territory just yet and if
the Rook goes back there this seems too
passive Rook B6 and Rook B8 but that
might be the only move that wins cleanly
does ferrugia see it he does not and the
game continues
wait a second the black king is sneaking
in here
I thought Rook G1 was a Perpetual check
now he's got Knight C4 wow what a move
oh my God preventing the Perpetual
where's the check it's on e66 still
going
oh you stopped rookie too so you aren't
able to win the game
Queen H3 D3
watch out for me in the back rank one
shot for King B3 here and that pawn is
going to be captured by Wesley but he
should be losing now still not easy
no still not easy can you get the H2
Pawn that's a big question
this might be the craziest game to start
a bullet segment I've ever seen he's
going the other way to A1
but now that King is on a very awkward
spot
yes now the king helps the d-pawn go
forward Queen takes A6 there would have
won the pawn I thought he should have
taken the pawn
and they takes it now
okay King C3 just keep giving the checks
the a pawn should help out maybe one
threatened why am I losing this why it's
gonna lose no he's not may not be one
he's got made on B1
oh what a find and made on B2
wow he he had Maiden won two moves in a
row but he's gonna Force the queen trade
and win the game
wow there were ups and downs there miss
Maiden ones but Dania Ali Reza farouza
he found the necessary Queen trade to
win the game he is leading the match for
the first time what a great game I lost
track of how many times the evaluation
turned
just unbelievable from alireza fuja he
was down by five points and he has
obtained his first lead of the match
Wesley he needs to get this game from
the white side of the king's Indian and
they've already had this line as well
they had this structure exactly once
Bishop E5 walks right into F4 I'm very
curious what alireza has in mind here
because generally Robert giving away
your fianchetto Bishop leads to
long-term weaknesses on the king side it
appears that black is okay here because
of the activity of his Knights and the
potential for D4
and the fact that Bishop on E2 is loose
otherwise Bishop takes G7 would have won
the D5 Pawn he goes right after it
anyway and if Knight F5 Bishop back to
F2 Donya I really like this for white I
love the fact that the white king feels
safer those dark squares around the
black king uh that is not going to be
easy to deal with so this position
Wesley ahead by 10 seconds I think he
should be happy
King safety is always crucial but in the
context of a bullet game with such
limited time I think it becomes the most
important factor even more important in
many cases than material if you're
alireza yeah I would put the bishop on
D5 and try to disarm this Knight before
it strikes at F6
watch out for Knight F6 check the queen
takes the bishop on D5 is loose suddenly
white gets the pair of Bishops against a
pair of knights so that's still in
tactic that's in the air and he takes on
e4 for that reason but this should be
favorable for what white white is
definitely better but this queen on F6
does a great job of holding these
Knights together and Wesley covering the
B4 Square he's probably gonna get his
Rook into the game but alireza can do
the same and it's kind of hard for white
to find a clear way to make progress if
you play G4 Robert you weaken the F4
square and the Knight is going to jump
into E3 which it does anyway a great
move by farusha to gain counter play and
Rook a to B1 defending the B2 Pawn
because when you take on E3 the queen on
F6 slices across the diagonal to hit
that B2 Pawn wait a second he didn't
protect it he didn't protect it I think
Wesley should capture it Rook aided d8
would have protected it indirectly
and there's some compensation I mean
White's King is a little bit Airy but it
should definitely be always giving up B2
he wants A4 at the end and the Black
Knight goes into D4 this looks scarier
for white that's for sure totally
White's got the perpetual and I think
he's got to take it
is it a Perpetual news because F6 Queen
E7 check if you go to H6
oh that's that would be clutch he's got
Bishop D1 first just to prevent any
shenanigans
and it's gonna be a draw
but if you're far Asia do you wait the
remaining 13 seconds before allowing the
repetition I guess it was Wesley who had
to play that last move so that wouldn't
have been too wise I would I mean oh
yeah because if he had gone King with
one second suddenly Wesley could have
done something unexpected okay still a
one-point game for alireza he still
hasn't lost the game since the five in a
portion incredible but Wesley he's going
back to his childhood he's digging deep
in the reserves he wants that French
defense done yet he's striking at the
center and I think this is a good choice
for him
I think it's a great choice for him you
have to keep changing your lines and
bullet get new positions pose your
opponent with new challenges and Wesley
I mean he knows everything and he used
to play the French as almost his main
repertoire when he was below 2700.
and this position is one where white has
yet to Castle and can't easily do so but
the queen is just moving around a bunch
and White's pawns they're advancing at
the board that sounds good but they can
be weaknesses later in the game but
speaking of later in the game look at
the king side for black you haven't
developed any of your pieces yeah there
might not be a later in the game and
speaking of weaknesses if white can
induce B6 then the Knight on C6 is
incredibly vulnerable it can be targeted
by Queen A4 that's exactly what he does
The Rook comes out to C1 and Robert the
other problem is this Prospect of Knight
B5 and then Knight D6 check even if you
sack a Pawn on D6 the other night can
come into E5 the square that's vacated
by this Pawn Wesley is already
borderline lost out of the opening
this is really terrible for Wesley white
just castles A7 is hanging on measure
Rook at the C1 threatens tactics along
the diagonal towards the black king you
can't play Knight E7 because Knight D6
check happens oh my goodness it's over
sad Rook takes C6 Queen takes C6 and
1966 B7 you win a piece he's not gonna
miss that he eats that for breakfast
he's eating Wesley's Souls Rook for
breakfast he's got a two-point lead for
breakfast unbelievable
so Ali Rizza just secured his first lead
now it's up to two points he is the
stronger player in bullet chess but
Wesley himself he's nearly 3 100 bullet
he has chances especially with the
increment but something is not clicking
at this stage for Wesley it's only a
two-point lead right normally you would
say that this is still a very close
match but you called it something's not
clicking and these games are getting
worse and worse in the three-minute
portion all of the games were very
combative for the first time in this
match Wesley is starting to lose games
in one-sided fashion that was the most
one-sided game of the whole match Wesley
has to find it in himself to turn this
around
I think this is a good opening Choice
from Wesley because you don't allow
black to play an easy F5 and now white
can strike on the king side and that's
exactly what's happening black is
playing A4 but H5 usually hurts more
than any of this queen side business
and alireza pursuing that Queen side
business but the move Queen A5 doesn't
really create any threats
you often see white driving the bishop
up to G4 but you got to be very very
careful not to blunder a check on D3
so white will probably King F1 first and
then Bishop G4 and if there's a trade
the queen gets the H Val very quick wow
F5 by farugia great call I think he has
to seek active counter play on the king
side otherwise he would have gotten
steamrolled after the H file opened up
but Wesley you called it King F1 and if
black plays F4 obviously the bishop
isn't trapped you can take the Knight
and then follow up with the positional
Bishop G4
and Knight to C7 I like that instead of
committing the pawn to F4 and you keep
the tension alive that way you can open
up files but wow
forever Dania this is a positional
approach in a tactical position
I'm not sure I love H6 he kind of opens
up Schrodinger's box there I would have
tried to keep the pawn on H5 as long as
possible now Wesley's 200 F4
and I guess he can take the Knight on C5
and get away with it
barely but he does seem to get away with
that there was a quintix G5 was the kick
oh the rook and she was protected by the
beach oh my gosh and then there's Bishop
F2 at the end of that line crazy yeah
that's exactly what alirez is
calculating right now he's down at nine
seconds
and he does trade on C5 the white king
should step out the way probably to H2
he goes H1 it doesn't matter the H final
is safe I think positionally black is in
huge trouble because the bishop on h8 is
permanently trapped the bishop is buried
Black has to try to open the position up
and ideally to go after this G5 Pawn
which I think Ali res is doing but
Bishop comes out to H3 at exactly the
right time
and don't blunder mating one oh the
queen get into H3 but he's Rook H2 and
the White Queen can slide over this is
strategically lost for black it's
amazing because it looks nice for black
with this Knight on T4 but now only
Reza's position really starts to crumble
he's dropped upon an A4 the Knight can
Circle back around to D5 and then Wesley
can pursue a campaign of patiently
advancing his Queen side pawns and
playing against this bishop
I'm nervous to jinx him because he's had
good positions before but this has been
Exquisite from Wesley so thus far so far
he's made zero mistakes alireza keeps
trying he's poking and he's prodding and
we know how tricky he is he will not go
down until this game is over
and the G5 Pawn needs to be defended
otherwise that Bishop is free the bishop
is locked in the corner and look at this
he hasn't pushed any of his pawns he
doesn't want to create weaknesses but
done at some moment he needs to push
upon in order to go for a win and he
does and he takes the plunge and this is
still very low risk chest the pawn on C4
is protected everything's protected it's
annoying for Wesley that he has to
babysit his G5 Pawn which doesn't allow
him to use the services of his Queen
he's trying to also gain a little bit of
time but a one second increment isn't
enough to do that as we see an exchange
Sacrifice by alireza I would not have
allowed that if I were Wesley because
the in comes the queen now B4 C4 these
squares are loose and what just happened
here and finally the bishop comes out to
F6 but I think it's too little too late
he's dropping too many pawns he's down
in exchange for no compensation the
rook's gonna go ah C5 beautiful Rook
d7's coming from B7 the seventh round oh
boys wait
not over yet still alirez is fighting
it's crazy
King G8
oh my God
and you take H6
no but rookie Seven's so smart because
you take the E Pawn now you have a pass
Pawn of your own
you have the threat of rookie seven
check I don't think Ali res is going to
be able to keep that B Pawn and even if
he does it shouldn't matter
no and it wasn't perfect here but now he
has found his way to Victory the king
can always come in via the light squares
the E Pawn goes off the board and that
should finally at long last do the trick
Bishop B7 check only Reza is still
trying
my goodness
God you can't bring the guy down he
won't die never and I think an H4
I think it's a draw
oh my gosh E7 wait E7 T6
he blundered E7 if he had kept his
bishop and supervised the square that
was a theoretical draw even without the
two pawns but very difficult to play in
bullet chess because you're tempted by
three different options you picked the
wrong one and as soon as that happens
you allow the pawn to go forward so
Wesley so finally gets back in the
winners column he gets a victory in that
game and now we once again have a
one-point match Dania Alvarez the
favorite in bullet chess but Wes is
proving that he can handle some of the
heat that was Wesley's first victory in
over an hour and that was very important
to show him that yes I can still win
games against alireza farouza now he's
one win away from tying this match once
again
man what a crazy crazy match as Wesley
prepares G5 and G4 I love the strategy
in a bullet game we saw him doing this
in a game in the five minute portion
this plan is even stronger with less
time on the clock
you said crazy he says yes please he
wants to get this game into hectic
Waters he wants to play G5 and G4 but no
he castles King side so Wesley decides
to take a solid approach I don't think
that's called for in a bullet game I
agree now I like alirez's position he's
got this classic Queen side expansion he
hits the queen and perhaps forces it
back to an awkward Square on E8 now you
could still consider G5 but with
Castle's King side I think that's way
too risky and you're also walking into
potential tactics there with Knight
takes G5
yeah I would not want any part of that
so the Knight goes back to F6 but it
feels like white just gained a few free
moves and King H1 is he him to get G4
for himself and is Wesley hinting at G5
for himself
wow the queen side expansion then in the
center Donya E5 it's not loose just yet
so that's the good news for Wesley but
the board opening up is typically not
good for the side without coordination
that we're gonna eat is not playing
out of Wesley's position though it's
it's so awkward it's like he his
position just hit puberty like none of
his pieces are coordinated and uh a
sacrifice on G5 by faruga as he blasts
open the f file I love this in the
context of a bullet game can you imagine
having this with 10 seconds on your
clock
no thank you because look at this he
gives up in exchange but F7 is defended
that's the good news for Wesley you can
play H4 but this game will continue and
I believe that the King on H1 that might
be the less safe King of the two
I agree especially because the G1 Escape
square is covered by Black's Bishop
which is why Ali Reza wanted to keep
this Pawn cover intact Wesley trying to
take some minor pieces off the board
he's given up the E5 Pawn I I still
think alireza should be able to win this
game
but maybe Knight F4 holds on
there goes Knight f8 Knight F7 is a
single check not too scary I just feel
like that King in the corner the dark
squares are going to be a problem and if
that Knight gets to H5 done it if a
black knight gets out there watch out
for that King safety yeah that's a huge
problem and black was not far away from
that I think that's why alireza played
E5 he was trying to prevent Knight F6
and now he doubles on the f file But
Here Comes Wesley's night maybe to G5
Rook F6 was a move
both sides are making mistakes here
natural
just nerves at this point
okay is there some kind of threat I
don't see actual threats me neither
Knight G5
oh and there's a back rank problem
Knight G5 Rook was a great move the Rook
was temporarily undefended But Here
Comes Wesley's Pawn up to A3 it goes
it's anybody's game white could have
taken the pawn but now this takes F7 and
trade Queens
and bullet this has to be winning for
black but how does black progress The
Rook on A4 cuts off the king and white
will bring his own King to the queen
side I think he might be able to save it
tempo for tempo whoa that Knight gobbles
another pawn and the put your Bishop on
D6 and then bring your knight back to
the center with Knight D5
and he's gone to B6 I think alireza
could have played Pawn B6 the trade off
the bonds with point six seconds barely
going to move
gosh gosh no this is scary and Wesley if
he wins this he ties the match up
there's B6 has he chosen a good moment
to play it Wesley's still playing for a
win
yes
King B8 Knight D5
what's he win the pawn he's winning now
if he gets that pawn this has to be a
win this reminds me of a game that
happened recently where this rajaba was
playing as kymer I think it was actually
I think exactly this end game will we
get bishop and Knight versus King I
actually don't think so I think Wesley
can circumvent the need to mate with
Knight and Bishop but you never know
first of all he still has to make actual
progress that's not a given
Knight Knight C7 the Knight comes to E6
into D4
this game is taking another five minutes
off the match clock I feel like they've
played two games and we're already 20
minutes in crazy well that's what
happens when you have long end games but
now the white king cannot protect C4 the
black king is playing his waiting game
Knight B3 to G2 and then the Rook has to
make a decision the black king gets the
E6 and the E5 too few squares too few
squares The Rook has to abandon the C4
pawn and now the position is becoming
resignable and he resigns and Wesley has
won two in a row on demand to tie this
match with 10 minutes to go could this
be any better than what it is
if you told us that somebody is going to
make a comeback and bullet I don't think
we're here to pick Wesley and Wesley
after a two-game deficit he wins
back-to-back games and now it's an even
match up Dania 11 and a half 11 half
nine minutes 50 seconds remaining who
would you say is the favorite
man you're putting me on the spot here
just based on bullet skill I would say
that it's farrugia but the way that
Wesley is keeping his composure in very
difficult positions that last game he
was down 15 seconds his King was wide
open and farouza was objectively winning
and somehow Wesley found one resource
after another to keep that game going
now it's farooza's turn to go after
white skin G5 in a London system as he
tries to drive his King side pawns Up
The King's Indian has served for Russia
very very well and I think he's got
another great position out of the
opening and the Knight goes back to E7
rerouting probably to G6 trying to go
for some expansion on the king side but
Wesley is playing in the center and look
at that move Bishop H5 just poking at
the Knight and at night on E1 can go to
C2 at some point the D file will have to
be fought for and it looks like white is
the first one to bring some heat to that
fight oh and E4 is such a committal move
positionally he opens up the bishop on
H2 which now aims at the C7 Pawn Wesley
improving the placement of his Knight
you called it Robert it's coming over to
D4 the queen could move up to D5 and
suddenly it feels like White's the one
with the big initiative in the center
Black's pawns are not going to Checkmate
whites King on their own
and if you play F4 to blunt that Bishop
the E4 Pawn is very loose so this is a
difficult position always it does strike
with F4 and look at how quickly Wesley
responded with rookie one honestly I
don't even care if it's the best move
the fact is leading on the clock is so
important he's been leading on the clock
most of these games which has been
really impressive he's managed his time
really well he's taking all of Black's
pawns but ferrugia getting really really
active in the center watch out the C2
Knight is undefended can Wesley continue
gobbling up all of Black's Pawns Rook
takes C7 that looks like another Free
Pawn there is no good Discovery he plays
Knight E1 a very wesley-like move he
said I'm already up one Pawn why do we
need a second instead he tries to disarm
the Knight on D3 which is Black's most
active piece his Bishop on H2 also needs
to be freed at some point so you could
consider a well-timed H4 to break apart
Black's Pawn chain
and just don't get back ranked
checkmated that Rook needs to stay on
the board maybe bring your Rook to E7
double on the seventh rank but then
Brook to d8 could be scary uh-oh now
what do you do king F1 Bishop D3 is made
you gotta go to H1 to cover the status
of the bishop that's such a hard move to
play but when it's your only move Wesley
should be able to find it but he plays
G4 so he makes space for his King it
should be for F3 rookie two check this
looks scary and he's gonna drop the F3
pawn and suddenly it looks like ferrush
is in the driver's seat Bishop D3 he's
got the Perpetual check and I think he's
got to take it rookie one and rookie two
is Perpetual but ferrugia playing for
the win now
he's playing for a loss he's trying to
win this game but the white king is not
getting checkmated here but is Wesley
playing for a win or will he take the
plunge and play King G2 no can't really
blame him for that King G2 apparently
the king could have snuck out to H3 but
man that will remain behind the scenes
we're still tied
so farouza he does not lose that game
but he is willing to risk it that much
is clear we get another Italian game
Wesley he's been playing well from the
black side but in this exact type of
structure he went G5 and we saw peace
sacrifice in that last game yeah he
keeps trying out new setups in the
Italian this time he gets his Bishop out
to G4 now of course okay back to D7 he
goes no he did do that in the previous
Italian game the point is to create a
hook on G3 that he can use to expand on
the king side but will he actually play
G4 now and will he really Castle Queen
side oh he does yes with this one out on
A5 Donya that looks so risky it looks
really terrifying farooza is going to go
B4 let me tell you Wesley is not going
to take on B4 he's going to try to keep
the queen side closed for long enough to
give himself the powerful attack on the
king side I like this for black this
looks very appealing to me but look at
this move Bishop B5 he wants Knight C4
next and he wants to go after the black
queen side but who is first here H4
followed by G4 looks like it's lights
out it really does once the G file opens
up and blackplay is H3 I feel like
farouza is actually much much slower on
the other side of the board and maybe he
should play H4 himself to try to slow
down Black's progression of Pawns on the
king side good move heads up Choice by
alireza I think this is the most
resilient option
and look at Wesley he says you're going
to open the G file my Rook is going to
LEAP into yeah oh Queen history is
coming Rook takes H4 check is a huge
threat therefore Bishop C4 doesn't work
I think Wesley's borderline winning here
he's crashing through the bishop on B6
is the hero it pins the F2 Pawn so Rook
H4 queen queen takes G3 check that's the
deciding factor another great move by
farusha to cover the H3 Square the only
way to keep himself in the game now
Wesley can slowly accumulate the attack
but no he does sack The Exchange will
this backfire
why would it backfire Queen E7 go right
after the H4 Pawn if Queen to G3 there
might be Rook G8 bring all of your
pieces to the party you're absolutely
right this wins the game Queen H3 walks
into a discovery with Knight takes F2
white has no time and no position
and I think farouza is gonna drop this
one Knight F6 or Knight H6 the cherry on
top Robert and Wesley's gonna take this
game
Wesley can win the queen he hasn't even
captured it yet I know look at this he
takes the pawn on H4 he wins on time but
he was cruising on the board this is so
impressive we've had amazing
performances by both players in this
match but Wesley's two-point comeback
and now a victory with black to get the
one point lead in the match farugia has
been in the situation before the only
difference is that there are now four
minutes left in the match and so the win
becomes absolutely necessary
dare we say that Wesley might have been
underrated in bullet chess is that over
3 100. Let's get him in the bullet Chess
Championship next year but that's a year
away this is right now and Donna we have
another King's Indian defense Borussia
has had some good success with it from
the black side but Wesley's taking a
positional approach in the context of a
bullet game I really like this Pawn
structure for black because it's very
very tricky the Knight typically comes
to E5 and then you've got ideas like
Knight D3 you often Advance your a pawn
down to A4 so even though white has the
space advantage and an Undisputed
objective Edge in a bullet game it's
very very easy to lose control of this
position let's see how Wesley arranges
his heavy pieces I vote for queen C2 and
Rook a to D1 or queen D2 and Rook 81.
looks perfect bring that Rook to the
center to the D6 Pawn is quite loose and
black expands with A5 maybe A4 in the
future but it does feel at least at
first glance like the D6 Pawn is the
biggest weakness and then I remember C4
is a target it most certainly is the
Knight on C3 is also loose and it can be
targeted by Queen to A5 which I think is
likely to be ferrugia's next move okay
never mind he's jumping into D3 he still
could play Queen A5 next and this is why
I like this from a practical point of
view for black really really hard for
white to handle these complications
and those nice they look a bit flimsy
there you then I don't see five it's
ever kicked and imd3 is loose but you
can't play B4 black has that square
under his control F5 is also a really
really nasty move opening up a second
front in the center and if white plays e
takes F5 your minor pieces are gonna get
overextended because black will be able
to play Rook takes C3 I still like F5
here Borussia has to involve the second
side of the board but if the bishop were
on D7 he might find F5 but with the back
rank so vulnerable it's much more
difficult to play even if the engine
approves of it so he goes back to A5
with his Queen and we look at this
position and we say what is the plan he
goes for F5 done it you called it and
finally it's on the board man but it
would have been so much better a couple
of moves ago things still really really
complicated here Wesley drops his Bishop
back to a defended Square it's anybody's
game in this time scramble Bishop back
to D7 the e-file is now open and I think
all heroes I should trade queens and go
for that end game
these nights though are loose so B4 is
something to watch out for and that's
why he plugs the square with his own
Knight Donna the D6 Pawn still loose but
the V3 Pawn is not much stronger I think
the position is probably dynamically
balanced to use the best commentator
phrase but black is more active Black's
got more prospects to four quite strokes
and win White's pieces and Wesley
hanging by a thread here as far Asia
supports that Knight with D5 Bishop B5
uh-oh uh-oh Knight C2 oh the Ruckus
Drive they come The Rook is trapped and
that should be that then that goes to B2
but now you're down to clean if
Rook takes B3 why do you go Rook takes
B3 ended the game immediately this
should win the game as well he's gonna
win another minor piece on top of the
exchange and he ties the match with a
minute remaining
so this could be the final game
if it is a draw we get four games of
more bullet people fasten your speed
belts this could be the deciding game
for the semi-finals I know you're
rubbing your eyes I can't believe what
we're seeing here let's see who can come
out on top
I can't believe it either and this is
not the best time for the for the board
to freeze
oh that is really not a good time there
we go there we go we have a Mainline
Italian thank God
thankfully in this position double pawns
for black but Dania I tend to like
having the open f file against an enemy
King again it's all about what's good in
a bullet game in the previous game
alireza went for a bad line but because
you don't have time to figure out all
the tricks it's Justified I think the
same thing is true here for Wesley he
goes D5 he's got the space advantage and
he's got ideas like Knight G4 like
Knight H5 Knight F4 but look at what's
going on in the center
yeah we had the Box some chess boxing
there and black decides to take on D4
now the center is opening up and look at
this position the D4 Pawn could be a
weakness the E6 Pawn could be a weakness
is white go ahead and play E5 on the
next turn or trade on D5 these are very
big questions and they do not have much
time to figure out the consequences of
each move and Wesley is trying to answer
those questions but he's taking a lot of
time to do that I see strikes at the
queen side with A3 he is trying to
induce B takes A3 Ali Reza says all bite
we're probably gonna get a trade on e4
and the pieces are starting to come off
the board who do you think has the upper
hand in this position as more pawns are
getting captured by both sides watch out
for Rook takes F3 that's the one thing
that I'm looking at is an expo I think
he could have done it totally okay a
takes F3 Knight takes D4 and something
White's King was wide open
and now he can take on A2 we're getting
Mass liquidation but this is still an
unbalanced position Black's got the pass
Pawn on B7 so I like the end game if
white trades Queens I think farooza
should try to keep Queens on the board
and maybe Engineers
yes farrugia offers a draw Wesley
accepts and you know what even though I
don't like draw first I understand the
situation they both don't want to have
this game decided right here and now
they want the match to continue they're
doing it for the fans
and they got what they asked for the
score is 13 and a half 13 and a half I
think it's a reasonable draw for the
position was objectively equal and I
think that in a Blitz game they would be
likely to draw it this is the most epic
match of the SEC this year and I think
all of the other players would agree
with us
yes and we will start the Thai race
momentarily the players they do get to
stretch their legs but we have fireworks
on the board I'm loving every second of
it these are the fireworks and then
remember wait a second are you really
paying it is September so feel free to
do that but this is an epic brawl
between two of the best players on the
planet let's remind you of the tie break
rules here in the speed Chess
Championship because for those of you
who have not seen it happen before
you're like what's next it's four games
of bullet chess the one plus one
continues they alternate their colors
and if it's two to two in these next
four games we get Armageddon Armageddon
Armageddon
but first they're gonna play four games
from one plus one what an incredible
match it's been I'm impressed with
Wesley Speed and I'm impressed with
Wesley's accuracy in the bullet thus far
he's not as experienced of a player but
it seems like he plays bullets every day
on Chestnut on the way that he's played
this match thus far the games are off
let's go
let's go there is a back in his chair so
let's tune into the action as the
players well it's going to be very
nerve-wracking stuff from them oh we've
seen this before Donna it's that
Sicilian where Wesley he was able to
take control of the white squares and I
hope alireza has done his research
because once Wesley dropped his Bishop
back to G3 the situation was Dire for
alireza I do not like that he's
repeating this line and he's worse again
look at look at his squares in the
center Wesley is doing exactly the same
thing that he did in their Blitz game to
a T
USC
this looks really good for white because
once that Queen slides back you don't
want to go to B3 because Knight C5 would
hit you with the tempo that's when he
puts F3 first later and he can bring his
Queen back oh all the way to eight two
doubly Bishop C4 Knight our Knight at C4
to E3 but I'm just trying to work all my
pieces into Black's territory and Robert
it's bad enough when you suffer from a
weakness on D5 but you've also got a
major hole on F5 so the ideal Square for
White's knife is C3 Wesley has to decide
if he's keeping the bishop though if he
allows the trade maybe alireza could
start advancing his H Pawn and
generating counter play on the king side
but that is very far away Wesley goes
for your approach and hits F7 directly
with the bishop he'll probably plant
something on D5 there it is why not if
you take on D5 the Knight takes back
hitting the queen on E7 so the Knight
goes out to F6 that may encourage a
trade on B7 but white actually isn't
afraid of these Bishop trades it helps
secure complete control of D5 and down
to the bishop on f8 it stares into its
own Pawn months and right now at that
pawn that's staring at D6 is loose
Wesley combining direct play and
strategic play he was attacking D6 using
that to Garner a Tempo I like the way
that alireza is trying to generate
counter play maybe something like G4
just to muddy the waters is what the
doctor ordered objectively black is
borderline lost but alireza still
holding on is he trying to Castle here I
don't think so watch out because 97
check after you castle and group C3 was
a winning threat which is why he traded
Knights on D5 but strategically this is
losing for black
and now it's losing materially too I
think Wesley should just Garner that
pawn on D6 he's got all of the
advantages of an amazing Knight against
a terrible Bishop as well as an extra
pawn and he can get the Queens off the
board this should be pretty much basic
Brian for Wesley
and the good thing for both these
players they don't just stare at the
match clock there is no more matchstalk
it's a best of four the winner of that
they move on to the semis if it's still
tied we get that arm again but look at
this it is Wesley with the Knight
dominating the bishop can you even exit
this pin on the black rank that's
exactly what I was going to point out
king G7 can always be met with Knight F5
truck as long as the Knight remains on
E3 which is why alireza tried to open up
a different pathway for his King Wesley
said not not today Over My Dead Body as
he keeps his Rook on D7 and we'll start
to push his seep on momentarily but look
at this that Rook on A1 will go after
the G Pawn if the white king moves away
from the King side so The Rook is on C7
the white king is in time to defend but
how does white push those pawns forward
Ali Reza's resilience has been on full
display over and over and over again the
guy just does not die but I think he
will die once this bishop is surrounded
by White's forces Bishop H6 can he hold
on like that no no we've got to be
winning look at that Bishop on h8 four
C5 C6 C7 I feel like now is the time
that's the exact same Bishop that
alireza had in that King's Indian game
which Wesley won in the bullet it's a
similar position this one's even more
one-sided because there's zero counter
play on the other side of the board
so how does white actually promote the
pawns that's the big question can black
somehow freeze white that's what you're
aiming for but no and now the second
Pawn drops it should be straightforward
it's resignable there's no stalemate
tricks because you still have an h-bond
and the bishop still has a square F3
wasn't even hanging because of the fork
good awareness by Wesley and he is so
methodical winning the first game of the
tiebreaker and immediately putting all
the residents back against the wall
and immediately going back to E4 E5 he
wants the solid approach in bullet chess
these games have been chaotic even
though they start with a very solid set
of moves but as we see the game continue
um this is one where the players they're
very familiar
they're very familiar indeed and Wesley
keeps doing this he plays Bishop G4 to
induce H3 olly Reza changing his
approach this time he tolerates the
bishop on G4 but Wesley doing exactly
what he did in that sparkling bullet
game Castle's Queen side I love this
approach in the context of Ebola game I
feel like Black's attack is much easier
to conduct on the king side than White's
on the queen side
I'm with you we saw that in the last
game they played in this variation and
others didn't have time to look into
this line but look at this instead of A3
B4 he goes right after the A5 Pawn
that's sticking out and white could just
go after it win it and then that's bad
news for the black king absolutely and
more bad news H5 which is the typical
attacking move is met with H4 and in
this particular version black doesn't
have a rook on G8 black doesn't have a
bishop punch before now he does of
course but it's taking Wesley longer
than he expected to set up these threats
on the king side and farusha takes the
opportunity to grab that pawn in A5 and
he's attacking C6 and he's going to be
attacking B7 and now it's farrugia who's
striking first on the queen side
he is indeed and there was a big
difference that white Paul was on H3 in
that previous game without a Pawn on H3
done yet there's no hook if he plays
Queen A3 Bishop E5 that is sickening
that is incredible geometry that is 2010
geometry Vision right there that Queen
on E7 was left undefended when the Rook
left E8 this is beautiful but the game
is far from over Wesley finally sets the
wheels of attack in motion he should
play C5 here and force the bishop to
give itself away for the Knight yeah but
he got a thumbs up from me that was a
sick tactical fight but black is
striking look at this H5
will it be H3 or G3 you don't even know
so this is looking very scary for
farooges King it's terrifying especially
after a move like H3 you actually can
meet it with G3 that Knight on E3 is a
very stable Defender and the fact that
it guards the G2 square is very valuable
meeting fire with fire that is an
incredible move that F4 push because
that way there were no Force Pawn trades
and now that the F files open up white
has some counter player of his own and
black desperately trying to generate
counter play but such an accurate
response by West by farrugia he takes C6
he's two moves away from winning this
game Queen A4 Queen A4 should do it
your knight from E3 that's the keys stop
the Checkmate holds the Checkmate it's a
resignation we have a tied match once
again Wesley shook his head in
frustration but that might have been the
highest quality bullet game that we've
seen thus far this match it was a wire
to wire victory for alireza going
through a line where he lost several
games and winning it in style on the
queen side two more games and the match
is still tied
and look at this Knight hopped into E5
Wesley's playing these offbeat
variations he just wants the bishop pair
and to play for a long-term Edge this is
actually a very very good line I think
it's an underrated line now typically
you see White's Bishop coming back to D3
and the knight from B1 swings on over to
F3 and potentially later clamps down on
E5 the position resembles a London
system but it's an improved version for
white
although the Black Knight might jump
into E4 and then black Falls up with F5
and he was a move too slow so he didn't
jump in too soon with the Knight and
that means you're not going to be able
to create some counter play on the king
side well if you're not creating counter
plan like King side you might create it
on the queen side with B7 B5 but his
last move indicates that alireza is not
thinking about the minority attack he is
thinking exactly about the idea that you
outlined I love this for black the
Knight on e4 is very hard to dislodge
without opening up the f file for
Black's Rook so Knight back to H3 they
kicked that night there with Pawn to F3
no he takes on e4 but done this looks
scary for white this Pawn is in White's
Grill the Knight is coming around to F5
the most important thing is that it's an
easier position to play for black and he
takes F3 and there's Bishop takes G3
he missed it no that that is a hard move
because you don't actually win material
with that Bishop takes G3 you actually
sacrifice a piece for two pawns but that
was available to him the engine of
course off to the side helps us spot
these tactics Wesley has to secure his
Bishops and he does just that Rook E1 to
F1 is such a mature move Knight takes G3
is now not possible the bishop would
have recaptured and now he moves his
Bishop away from F3 it looks like Wesley
has more or less stabilized the
situation as farusha prepares the double
Rooks on the f file
and I would take white in this position
I love the bishop pair at the right
moment white might think about G4 and
Bishop H4 just to unravel a bit and
Bishop H3 watch out for that E6 Square
Bishop H3 is a heads up move for
focusing his forces on that square but
farouza going back to home base trying
to get this Knight around to E4
he trades the Rooks first giving Wesley
the f file and look at the light squares
on the king side Robert Wesley kind of
surrounding them with his Bishop
I love that decision from Wesley but Ali
Rizza he's hanging in tough right now
the E6 Pawn is loose so you have to be
very careful here for farrugia any
anytime there's a knight in the center
there is going to be danger Wesley
repeating moves is he gonna go for the
drug no he's not he feels that he's got
some winning chances in this end game
and I think he does I think he's still a
little bit better but ferrous are doing
a great job of seeking active counter
play on the king side it moves like G5
are excellent you can't get an H5
because the bishop run F3 covers that
square along with the queen on E2 so
this is what fruition needs to do he
needs to make sure that he has space of
his own otherwise the Bishops will
Thrive but here look at that Queen into
B1 this could get tricky for Wesley it
absolutely could I actually think Wesley
should bail out and farush is the one
who's making motions to play for a win
but look at that move Bishop G4
immobilizing the Knight because white is
now aiming at the E6 Pawn he goes back
to F3 and we might get some sort of a
three move repetition here Robert I
don't think either side can really make
any progress here
Queen E4 check
and he goes he does he goes for it
and we're gonna get a trade and we're
gonna get another trade and is black
trying to get the king to B3
but there's no way that you're in time
because the white can go to G4 and H5
who's winning the race
it could have been white but Wesley
doesn't want to find out he wants the
next game to decide the match this is I
think almost a guaranteed draw at this
point ferrugia is technically in the
driver's seat but he can't make any
progress from here
yeah well that's what E5 but that could
backfire because that pawn H6 was
Untouchable we have a draw which means
this fourth and final game of overtime
could decide the match if we have a
winner well it's going to be either this
game or the next game so there's really
no point in taking a quick draw and we
are going to get another Italian for
Russia has the white pieces in this
final bullet game of the tiebreaker
which approach will Wesley take again
there's that G5 move but this time
Wesley follows up by castling kingside
something that he hasn't done yet in
this line
I think Wesley would be happy with the
draw because you get to Armageddon which
Wesley as the older player between two
has more experience in but how can you
force a draw in this position it's about
to be a slugfest on the king side King
G7 97 Knight G6 made me push some pawns
over there both sides will have their
chances I'm biased in favor of Black's
position because I feel like Black's
attacking ideas are easier to perceive
and so easier to play at the same time
black is riddled with holes right the F5
score big weakness the king is a lot
less safe so Wesley has to justify that
with accurate play on the king side G4
really powerful move blasting open the
king side getting the Knight involved in
the attack this is getting dangerous for
alireza
yeah the bishop slides up to G3 uh
that's the good news is that you don't
lose the piece still comes to cheat Pawn
to F5 and here they come oh my gosh D
takes E5 I think he wants F4 sneaking
the pawn and no he takes on e4 and
vacates the F5 Square for his night
Wesley is attacking with his pieces and
don't sleep on the roll that the bishop
on A7 could play what is happening here
he went D5 with a four but Knight F6
hits the bishop on H5 which is loose and
if Knight F6 ef6 the Knight on E7 is in
trouble the King on h8 is also in danger
suddenly this seems to be turning around
in alibraza's favor he missed that move
and Robert you're right if you take
twice on F6 you run into Bishop E5 and
so he's got to leave that F6 spawn alive
the Queens could get traded here and
we're gonna get some sort of a weird end
game where black still has enduring
chances against White's King but it
looks like the worst is behind alireza
yeah because White currently is up two
pawns and after Knight takes G3 Rook
takes F6 it's just gonna be one Pawn
it's a double Pawn but I still think
that there are chances for both sides
given that there isn't a clear bailout
and black has control over some key dark
squares on the cake side the white king
is currently kept in a cage but it can
eventually uncage itself via H2 and H3
as our alireza activates his rook and
tries to infiltrate D7 Wesley prevents
it this Knight on H4 could also jump
into G6 at the right moment or move back
to e to F3
and look at the Rook it goes back to d8
but we're gonna see a rook trade being
offered and denied so this could be a
repetition at any moment but who's
playing for the win well Ali Reza was
the one who declined repetition I think
Wesley as you said probably okay with
the draw but I think this might be
backfiring because of the terrible
terrible position of White's King
but look at this Knight F5 the trade has
happened so it doesn't matter if the
king is unsafe with opposite colored
Bishops it should just be a simple draw
Robert Wesley actually had to move King
F6 there and the pawn on H6 was
Untouchable because the Knight would
have gotten trapped but this was so hard
to see especially because Wesley was in
the back foot for most of the second
half of the game I can't believe this
but we're gonna get an Armageddon
look at these players they've given it
their all and they're all is good enough
for us as fans and commentators but it's
not good enough to get by the other
there is only one game remaining that
will separate this title break it
because these two players Donya there
were ups and downs and a five plus one
for Westing the three plus one for
alariza but all is said and done they
have been every bit equals I started
feeling that paying of sadness Robert
because I could feel that this match was
coming to an end no the players are
giving us more entertainment this match
is the gift that keeps on giving and how
fitting is it that a match where the
players have been this evenly matched
and have gone back and forth so many
times is ultimately going to come down
to a nervy incredible exciting
Armageddon and these are the rules for
Armageddon the most important thing is
that black wins with a draw so the
players they bid the time for the
opportunity to choose their color the
big winner plays with the time that they
bid the opponent starts with five
minutes so how this often works is let's
say Dania and I are the two players who
are playing Tanya throw out a number
uh four and a half
okay so Daniel bids four minutes in 30
seconds I bid four minutes 29 seconds
that means Dania gets white with the
five minutes I get black with 429 and a
draw means that I move on and Donya is
sent home so this is going to be
interesting we'll wait to hear who the
players that's not who what numbers the
players are going to pick but in the
meantime just like the two of them we
will take a break but when we return it
will be Armageddon do not go anywhere
this is the speeches Championship
presented by coinbase Armageddon on the
flip side of the spray
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase all
there is a farusha is the man you see on
the screen in front of you and he is the
player who is going to get the black
pieces Dunya he had the winning bid he
bit three minutes at 40 seconds Wesley
bid
348 so an eight second difference in
their bids while there is a secure is
black it meets his rods and bidding and
Armageddon is kind of an art and it
depends on how comfortable you feel
playing with little time the second most
important thing in an Armageddon format
Robert the first being the black wins if
it's a draw is that there is no
increment everybody in the chat should
remember this flagging for the first
time pure flagging for the first time in
the SEC match actually becomes a thing
in the Armageddon and that really
influences your bit if there was a one
second increment I think a player would
be totally comfortable bidding something
like three minutes now they bid closer
to four which I think is a very sensible
bid especially for someone SPD as
alireza ferrugia
three minutes 40 seconds that's quite a
Time deficit because spotting a minute
20 to Wesley so we've seen his Exquisite
technique on full display in many of the
matches today and I think that Wesley
will be happiest that he starts with
five minutes remember in the five plus
one he dominated seven to two
indeed and if you're Wesley remember do
not be afraid to flag if you've got a
situation where you can get Rook rook in
three versus rook in three and your
opponent has 10 seconds as fast as far
Asia is play the clock as well as the
game and we've got no surprise there
another Italian Wesley has white
Borussia starts with three minutes and
40 seconds and here we go Mainline
Italian
if you are Wesley in this H6 G5 stuff
comes up do you sacrifice the piece
because always doesn't have enough time
to calculate or we just have to remember
that it's no longer bullet three minutes
even if you're down on time is plenty of
time to work with I think it's the
latter and that actually makes it very
hard to adjust you just played something
like 50 minutes of bullet chess you've
kept one eye on the clock for the last
hour suddenly you can slow down you can
breathe there's no increment but that
doesn't mean that you have to Blitz out
moves and a case in point farrugia with
a big decision here Robert does he take
the bishop does he go Bishop B6 he keeps
the status quo by dropping the bishop
back to B6 as is so typical in these
Italian positions
right there's a stared on the Bishops
but if you take on E3 after F takes E3
there's some pressure down the king side
with the queen sliding E1 and out on
that diagonal so look at black just
playing solidly I like it how how
quickly Wesley's playing he's kept the
initial time Advantage although the
position is quite symmetrical I like I
like this choice for Wesley because the
position is also open-ended this
promises a long middle game and this
promises the middle game as farouza
forces the exchange of Bishops but in
return it cost him a potential Tempo and
it costs him control of the center it
will force black to make a lot of hard
decisions in the next couple of moves
and we're finally getting Robert some
sort of direct confrontation between the
armies as Wesley pushes D4
yeah this Pawn on D4 is well defended uh
you would like to play B4 and expand on
the queen side but then you have to
contend with e takes D4 and the B4 Pawn
might be loose but they're Queen B3
tactics in the air so this needs to be
thought of it can't just be played
without using your calculation skills
and Wesley he might expand with his B4
push Queen B3 itself was a low risk move
but then you would have run into Knight
A5 related ideas so he does play on The
Queen side but he does it a little bit
differently he establishes a bishop on
this very nice Square notice that black
can no longer play A6 because he took on
B6 with a pawn that is the drawback of
the exchange on V6 the strength of it
for black is that he's got this
long-term pressure with his Rook on the
A4 Pawn without the Rook having made a
single move as far Asia tries to trade
another pair of minor pieces and the
more the position simplifies the easier
it becomes to play quickly for Black
who's brought this time Advantage down
to 40 seconds
that's huge because Frozen is the faster
player between the two of them but
Wesley he had the type of position that
he typically is able to to win games
even from equal positions he just
Maneuvers he just gets a little plus
here the Knight gets an F5 first but
Donna there isn't too much happening
just yet there isn't too much going on
and black is definitely maybe a tiny bit
worse because of his damage structure
but if you showed farrugia this position
and said this is what you're gonna get
after 18 moves I think he would be
relatively happy now the next big
question does black establish a presence
on F4 the drawback of playing that move
prematurely is that you're softening up
the E5 pawn and white can put a rook on
D1 and start threatening things like d
take C5 instead Knight F6 back to H7 is
he aiming for G5 it's a moot point does
Wesley blunder the pawn A4 he blooded he
just hung A4 Pawn the queen of The Rook
are lined up as soon as he takes it oh
that's a huge deal and Wesley had been
doing great building up that time
Advantage back to a minute now he's a
pawn down for no compensation and now
farouza can play down the a file and try
to trade more Rooks
the only good thing is Wesley is up
nearly 50 seconds on the clock so he
could try to use that to his Advantage
Wesley is a very nice person Shameless
flagging is not in his vocabulary but
let's learn some new language today I
have to go for it it absolutely has to
be in your vocabulary and let's not
overstate the case Wesley is down upon
but he has this bind in the center that
he's just established he's also got
access to the F5 square and that means
he has serious attacking chances against
Black's King I'll be honest with you
Robert I actually do not dislike White's
position here especially after something
like Knight F5 which is on the board
the extra Pawn is not actually playing a
part Knight takes G7 followed by Knight
F5 check probably Queen takes H6 that's
a checkmating attack and a great
defensive move by faruga very heads up
play there as he contests the F5 square
if Wesley takes and plays Knight F5 that
is now out of the question because black
will give up in exchange for the second
night Wesley building up the attack with
F4
and there are Knight takes E4 ideas in a
position like this because the Knight
and F5 will lose its Defender but white
will throw in Knight takes H6 check
after which black takes back and then
Black's King is open so it's actually
just an equal trade but the position
does not look Pleasant for black there
and it's time to start talking about the
clock Borussia is still down a minute
but he's now down almost to a minute on
his clock again there is no increment
and I think he just spent a bunch of
time assessing Knight takes C4 this is
what Wesley is so good at doing he's
constantly asking for user questions and
forcing him to spend a certain amount of
time what's going on here as the queen
moves up to C6 the pawn is now hanging
well I can capture it on the next move
if Wesley doesn't respond to the threat
and it's a pretty big threat because you
cannot afford to give that pawn and he
brings his King to H2 so if Knight takes
E4 done there might be tactics with
Queen slime to B2 or D4 even like just
attacking the G7 Pawn with a mating
threat but you see what he's doing every
move he is forcing farusha to calculate
Knight takes E4 and alireza has no
choice he has to assess that move he's
down under a minute and flagging now
becomes a serious consideration Knight
takes C4 is on the board and we're gonna
see Queen B2 the Knight will drop back
to F6 and black is hanging on by the
skin of his teeth instead he goes Queen
to D4
but Knight takes H6 with check the
g-pawn takes the F6 Knight is loose I
mean the black king is not safe at all
Here and Now farooza down under a minute
on the clock and he's got to take back
with a knight if he takes with a queen
apparently there's Knight takes G7 and
then this move B4 to dislodge The Rook
from the fifth Rank and that might win
the game Wesley can win with the Knight
takes G7 and he found it wow he finds it
because B4 kicks The Rook off the fifth
Rank and the Knight H5 check is
devastating what a tactical spot from
Wesley so oh my lands girl and how crazy
is it Robert that there isn't a single
Square not one on the fifth rank that
The Rook can move to he's got to allow
Knight F5 farusha keeps the game going
though he's gonna try some sort of
sacrifice on G2 to force a Perpetual
check
oh and that's scary Knight F5 check the
king moves back Queen F6 Rook G2 there's
King H one maybe in somebody's positions
there is also King G2 and King G3 and I
think he escapes the checks but it might
be Point Robert 20 seconds for alireza
no increment he's Gotta Move
and if Rook takes you to his plate and
doesn't work it loses on the spot so
that means that farouza Who's down to 14
seconds he is not going to be able to
find a way out of this and Wesley should
trade Queens don't even think about it
don't even think about a trade Queens
flag him
can you just go queen dhak queen queen
takes C7 and then rinse and repeat I
wouldn't I would only be looking at my
opponent's clock but he is playing this
objectively
careful now ah this is lost King F3
there's no check there is no Perpetual
here no way no way there's a Perpetual
there's only a check on E2 after the
king went to F3 and said it goes to G3
and now there are no more checks that
means the game is Wesley's there's a
resignation and Wesley so breathes for
the first time since the five plus one
time that's exactly right and he
deserves a breath because Wesley so has
just delivered on a must-win Armageddon
game and not just in any fashion he
found Knight takes G7 and B4 that was
absolutely incredible I have a pretty
good feeling Robert of what our move of
the day is going to be I don't know
about you well Wesley decides to get out
of this chair he was so happy you could
see it on his face I know what our move
of the day is and Wesley he looks out
into the wild that was an absolutely
back and forth match Wesley so Beats
alireza farusha by a final score of 16.5
to 15 and a half and it was as close as
as the final score indicates it was as
close as the final score indicates and
even the Armageddon game itself was
incredibly close Wesley blundered upon
at some point his time Advantage started
to dwindle and he found it in himself to
set up an incredible decisive attack
against alirez's King and capped it off
with a beautiful sacrifice this is a
very deserving win for Wesley so who had
to go through so much in this match
alone
and Wesley so is our first semi-finalist
here at the speed test Championship
presented by coinbase he outlasts
alireza faruja to get there what a match
that was Donya I have to give Hearts to
both these players I mean let's come on
chat get involved all right give those
hearts for the players they deserve it
they played such a great match it went
down I don't get last game yeah yeah I
didn't have the tech that I did you know
a guy moves and now suddenly he's got
all the cool Tech
my God what a match that was huge props
to both players it takes two players
right it takes two to create a work of
art and I think it's safe to say that
this match as long as well as a bunch of
games within it was a work of art in
itself
well we know when our Savvy move of the
day so let's take a look at the Saturn
move presented by coinbase we'll be
reviewing some key moves in the
chessboard from today's match and we
don't have to go back in the day we know
what the Savvy move was because Dania
the queen took back a rook how much more
natural could he get but it earned that
question mark and earned Wesley a trip
to the semis and it wasn't by means of
Knight takes H6 check that is the
low-hanging fruit that you can pick off
the problem is that black doesn't have
to take the Knight and keeps his Pawn
structure intact instead you take not an
H6 but actually on G7 the double
exclamation mark is awarded for a good
reason now Robert after King takes G7
Ali Reza saw this idea and both players
saw that Knight H5 doesn't work because
the Rook laterally defends the key H5
and F5 squares this is the follow-up
Savvy move of the day it's before
so nice and earlier Wesley played F4 to
take away squares like E5 and G5 so that
Rook was out of real estate on the fifth
rank it couldn't go anywhere Knight H5
was the follow-up and it led to a
devastating attack and all the reason
just didn't have enough time even if
there was a way to defend so Wesley so
he wins the match in Armageddon and he
moves on to the SEC semis and that
indeed was her Queen base Savvy move of
the day how crazy is it Wesley's ability
to deliver in clutch situations it would
be one thing if he scored a blowout
Victory yes that would be very
impressive but to me the more impressive
thing is that he suffered a very
disappointing three plus one segment he
was down by two in the bullet we were
already spinning that narrative in our
mind alireza comes back that's it he's
the better bullet player take that and
toss it all in the trash says Wesley I
ain't going down that easy
no Wesley Rises to the occasion he moves
on and we will bring on Wesley for an
interview so those you who are still
here don't go anywhere and please ask
your questions we will be able to ask
some lucky Chatters questions to Wesley
so when returned to his break this is
the speeches Championship presented by
coinbase West and so is your winner and
you'll hear his thoughts and just
appeared
[Music]
thank you
foreign
yeah I was in Silicon Valley it was like
the Heyday of like things going on all
my friends were like going and getting
jobs or they were like out there raising
Venture Capital money and I'm like hey
I've got this chess idea and like I'm
going into like Venture Capital firms
and they're like uh chess is way too
small to be investable and so I
literally have a list of of investors
including something still I'm friends
with who are like I missed my channel
like everybody said no except your
friend's mom except my friend's mom
shout out to friend's mom yeah she she
was like I'll loan you money but I don't
want to invest he's like I don't want
Equity no in your in your ridiculous
chest situation but just pay me back my
70 grand in a few months and we'll be
good yeah yeah it was actually after
three years so they paid her back like
100 Grand after anyway those were the
details of our first loan but the thing
is is that not having Venture investment
not being able to run the Silicon Valley
like Playbook made us do everything
different from the very beginning
chess.com was a place to capture that
chess curiosity from the very beginning
if you go back you know 20 years in the
internet there when you would go to your
browser search bar there was no search
it was just a browser bar if you typed
chess in there and hit enter it would
just put the.com on there and take you
there and so chess.com captured the
chess curiosity of the world long before
the search engine was even built into
the bar it was just chess enter add
the.com go and there were thousands of
people each day showing that level of
curiosity and arriving at chess.com and
then starting to see like oh my gosh
there's a community here oh there's some
articles written by this guy Danny oh I
can create a profile but from the very
beginning chess.com has been the
receptacle of you know of the The Funnel
of like curiosity and then bringing you
on in to show you the awesomeness that
is chest when all the other chess
companies out there at the time and
there were more than there are now uh
back then they all had logos of you know
Kings or they had Knights or whatever
and we were like we're doing the pawn
and the reason we're doing the pond is
because we're doing chess for everyone
we're not doing chess just for
professionals we're not doing chess like
just for beginners we're doing chess for
everyone starting with the pawns and on
up and that's why you know people like
that's not that's not the strongest
piece it's not the most commanding piece
I'm like no but it's the Peace of
everyone a piece of everybody and that's
why we started that way so anyway they
just was putting that together that I
think I was at the perfect spot reading
wise I just understanding was to make
this happen and maybe it would have gone
a totally different direction if I had
been weaker or stronger or whatever
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to speed session presented
by coinbase we are thrilled to be joined
by none other than Wesley so Wesley you
just won one of the most epic matches in
speed Chess Championship history how are
you feeling right now
oh thank you well I'm very happy and
very relieved uh
yeah I really wanted to win that last
game badly to go all that we played over
30 games and that win will be
heartbreaking so uh
you know I I it's a it's just it's
incredible
I I thought at first that the match
would be mood sailing after the five
plus one portion but uh yeah I wasn't
sure if alireza's work was working on
his Jeff or anything but quietly he does
Wesley what was your proudest moment of
the match was it that your performance
in the five plus one or was it your
ability to uh surmount the two-point
deficit that you faced in the bullet and
then top it off with the victory in the
Armageddon
well I wasn't proud of all of the match
I mean I had a five-point lead then to
lose it
very quickly again a bit embarrassing
but uh I mean of course I'm happy to
take the lean five plus one portion
against level one also against alireza
but I'm supposed to have very good a
very good track record than the three
plus one portion not sure exactly what
went wrong there but uh I obviously
gotta keep it up and uh I actually got
coming before
coming for the bullet portion I need to
be up at least like three games in order
to have a chance
and surprisingly enough you know it
worked out
well
uh
I was playing fast enough
and uh yeah it's just
in the end Anything could happen I
thought alireza for sure was the favor
in the bullet but didn't didn't work
that case uh
yeah so so uh
yeah I'm not sure exactly what happened
there but but I think the last game was
pretty nice in the Armageddon I lost a
pawn and I thought all hope was lost but
then he started using a lot of time
in the clubhouse
happens I think they've made some
mistakes uh
in the three plus one portion there was
this game where I was completely winning
and then
I lost on the club or something and also
I kept playing with white the king's
Indian I think I lost four or five games
with white there so maybe it's the bad
idea to keep it going
I'm playing one D4 or Knight S2 like I
was
very happy with the positions getting
with one E4 or even the London opening
but the king thingy I thought why it's
always better but it's not easy to play
yeah but see that makes a lot of sense
and normally you're very stoic we don't
see many reactions from you but after
you started losing your lead you were
reacting quite clearly on camera did you
feel the match slipping away from you or
what were your emotions like during the
match
uh
yeah for sure yeah for sure definitely
let go I I thought
alireza was gaining the initiative
slowly but surely
in the middle of match I I just tried to
stop bleeding losing three games in a
row and then losing a further two more I
I just tried to make a few draws you
know and get some wins here and there if
he lets me
uh but that was that was definitely a
turning point in the match I thought
earlier thought the initiative also
going to the bullet
and I was just quite quite lucky to be
able to hold
what's your potentially yeah
oh sorry go ahead
go ahead go ahead I apologize
no yeah yeah I was gonna uh
yeah I was gonna mention that the NHS
players have different personality and
I'm not I'm not like Hikaru but it's
it's fun to watch Hikaru matches
for instance
uh Wesley that makes a lot of sense
you're likely going to play Magnus
Carlson in the SEC does the prospect of
facing Magnus excite you is that
something that you would be actively
looking forward to
yeah yeah for sure I mean if you want to
improve on chess you gotta play
the very best of whoever there
whoever is the very best at the moment
and uh
you know Magna has been number one for
over 10 years now
yeah but but you still have to win a
match I mean I assume Ian is a big
favorite against Arjun
and then
you know hopefully Ian get a good match
against Magnus maybe I'll play him but
uh
yeah I'll have a very good record
against Magnus uh it depends
on how good of a form he is on that day
because uh without the OnePlus One I
think I have a chance you know I I like
I like playing chess
but uh
with the one plus one portion
um I'm not really very good I did
so uh depends on how
Magnus does
that day but I'm very excited of course
to
compete against the best player
well see we have um
you don't really have much choice
because you either play Hikaru either
run into Hikaru or you run against
Magnus so it's either one or the other
but
if uh but
meanwhile I look forward to watching the
other matches for example the Nakamura
carwana match should be pretty exciting
too and uh
and yeah
well Wesley you know you just won such a
thrilling match against alireza how are
you going to celebrate that victory
oh it's good well I'm actually in Berlin
right now my mother so
it's uh 7 30 in the evening here I I'm
playing in this uh Armageddon chess
Series so it's it has a blitz time
control to uh three plus two but this is
a very good practice and a warm up Sam
Shanklin this year from the United
States
so we're gonna go have a nice
Chinese dinner we've been here a few
times previously we know we know all the
good places to eat
well you're making me hungry speaking
about Chinese food Wesley you deserve a
very nice meal you are playing in the
semi-finals of the SEC so
congratulations once again you made the
fans so happy watching you play what was
an epic Armageddon mesh
thank you yeah I always look forward to
the speed test Championship every year
it's become an annual tradition whether
I'm playing or not you know I'm watching
the videos watching you guys so so I'd
like to thank you Daniel and Robert for
your hard work today match was a bit
longer but but also I'd like to thank
Goran and Oprah Judith for
for all the hard work with me so thanks
okay
thank you Wesley always the kind words
we'll let you enjoy your dinner but we
will see you soon for more on the SEC so
thank you so much for playing an amazing
match stopping by congrats
that was Grand Master Wesley so the
first player to etch his name into the
semi-finals you see he beat levona
ronian then he takes down all the Rays
of faruza in the quarters his name alone
is in the semis Dinah he awaits the
winner of Magnus Carlson versus somebody
a name we don't know yet but Wesley said
no matter who he faces he loves the
speeches Championship well first of all
whoever that somebody is going to be
this is not going to be a walkover for
Magnus whether he plays our generic icy
uh or Yan Napoli so that is going to be
a fascinating uh matchup in the
quarterfinals but man selfishly imagine
a Wesley Carlson match what both players
are in such good form I said this
yesterday I'm going to say it again
today Robert I feel like the form of
some of these players in this year's SCC
is particularly amazing
Wesley just demonstrated that but he was
disappointed with himself he wants to
win each and every game but then when he
stumbled in the middle portion losing a
bunch of games in a row I think that
remains with the players even more than
their fine victories absolutely of
course Wesley he's hard on himself he's
self-critical he demands complete
Excellence but I think that he should be
proud of the way that he surrounded a
two-point deficit when he previously
held a five-point lead that doesn't just
take a lot of Chess skill it takes
tremendous resilience it takes
psychological stamina uh it takes
gumption it takes a lot of skills that
some of these top players possess more
than any other player in the world
it's crazy
yes it was indeed in a one-point match
victory for Wesley he says all roads the
SEC Crown go through Hikaru Nakamura who
plays in the second half of the
doubleheader tomorrow or Magnus Carlson
but that first half the Yanda palmsee
versus Argent aragaisy the winner of
that match plays Magnus Carlson the
winner of Magnus versus the winner of
this one plays Wesley so young he just
entered the tournament done yet you know
that he was hungry for victory and
Fabiano he faces Hikaru as the huge
Underdog will we have a second day in a
row where an underdog upsets one of the
favorites man two amazing mouth-watering
matches tomorrow uh it's sad that Ding
is not in the SEC but I think I'm an
adventurer guess that Jana pondichi is a
pretty able replacement I've actually
never seen Yan and Arjun play in any
format so I'm looking forward to that
one and obviously any match featuring
kikaru Nakamura is bound to be a crowd
favorite particularly when his opponent
is someone as strong as Fabby who's
shown such tremendous Improvement in
faster time control over the last couple
of years
it remains to be seen who will move on
like Wesley so just did but that is
tomorrow's news and we also want to
announce a very exciting series for the
community join The Fray in the brand new
variance Community series we're looking
to Crown the best players in chess
variants starting off with King of the
Hill enter weekly Arenas each Thursday
that's tomorrow don't you forget it to
prove your prowess in King of the Hill
and book your ticket to the championship
at the end of this variant cycle for
more information on the Arenas and how
to join use the command variant Series
in chat Dunya I know you love chess
variants it's King of the Hill one of
your favorites definitely I would put it
probably in the top three alongside
Fisher random and maybe three check King
of the Hill is fun because you can
Checkmate somebody in conventional
fashion but you on top of that you add
this really interesting rule which
honestly creates some fascinating
tactics and some beautiful combinations
let me tell you we had plenty of both of
those things today
yeah and I never mind when I lose King
of the Hill because my King's supposed
to be in the center so I'm not castling
if I get checkmated so be it but it is a
lot of fun and done it we just had a lot
of fun watching the match any final
thoughts of what we saw between Wesley
so and all there is afruza well first of
all a great privilege to to be here
throughout this match and commentate it
with you I had an absolute blast what's
stressful for the players is fun for the
commentators and we had so much fun we
thought that this might be a blowout and
I'm gonna say this I'm really happy that
it wasn't I'm really happy that this
came down literally to the final game it
was an amazing performance by both
players But ultimately Wesley so that
guy see is Unstoppable in scc's
and when you hear the word clutch maybe
Wesley so epitomizes that that was a
clutch finish in Armageddon he wins in
the end taking down alireza faruza he
moves on to semis he acts him at the
speed test him to present by coordinates
does not stop here it continues tomorrow
enjoying the rest of your nights enjoy
the ride tomorrow we'll see you then
tomorrow in the SEC presented by
coinbase
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you